THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE HIGH SPEED RAIL
OVERSIGHT HEARING WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE MEETING TO ORDER. SO
IT WILL BEFORE WE BEGIN. I NEED
TO TAKE CARE OF A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING. TO THE CURRENT
STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE THE CHAMBERS AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
IN THIS SPACE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A RELATIVELY FEW
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET. SPACING
THERE ARE ALSO A STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE FIFTH PUBLIC TO ENTER
AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY IN THE HEARING. WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ARE INSURING A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY. FIRST OF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ALSO
ASK YOU TO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ONCE YOU ARE DONE
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITED
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON. AT A TIME. SECOND WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
PROVIDE COMMENTARY WE GET TO
THAT POINT IN THE AGENDA.
EXCUSE ME. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
BE SURE TO ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MORE COMMUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
ONE PLACE IN THE QUEUE YOU ALSO
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
A MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE THREE. AND MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU. I
ALSO TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEND YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE AND WE WILL
DISTRICT DISTRIBUTE THEM
APPROPRIATELY. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US- AS WE
IMPLEMENT MATH IS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE. OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. THIS IS AN ANXIOUS TIME I
KNOW BUT WE ALL RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF AN OPEN AND
WORKING LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES. CONTINUE
TODAY WE ARE HERE TO DISCUSS
AND PROVIDE COMMENT ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITIES DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN.
THE SPEAKER MY COLLEAGUES AND I
BELIEVE THIS HEARING IS OF
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE RIGHT NOW.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE THIS IS THE
LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE AND
WE ARE AT A CRITICAL DECISION
POINT. THE FRANK THE PANDEMIC
CRISIS WE ARE CURRENTLY FACING
IS GOING TO FORCE US TO REALLY
EXAMINE OUR SPENDING PRIORITIES
RIGHT NOW. THIS TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL BEFORE US TODAY
IS A PLACE TO BEGIN THAT
EXAMINATION. THE STATUE
REQUIRES TO THE HILT A FORTY
PUBLISHED AND SUBMIT TO THE
LEGISLATURE A DRAFT PLAN EVERY
TWO YEARS. EXISTING LAW ALSO
REQUIRES THE AUTHORITY TO
INCORPORATE ANY COMMENTS
RECEIVED FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE PUBLIC INTO ITS FINAL
BUSINESS PLAN. THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY IS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT FOR THE AUTHORITY
TO CONSIDER BEFORE ADOPTING ITS
FINAL VERSION OF THIS PROPOSED
PLAN. SINCE BEING ELECTED
GOVERNOR SOME HAS SHIFTED THE
FOCUS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROGRAM. THESE SHIFTED AWAY
FROM CONNECTING TO REGIONS WITH
THE VALLEY TO VALLEY INITIAL
OPERATING SEGMENTS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO BAKERSFIELD. TO A
SHORTER INTER REGIONAL TRAIN
AND ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE FROM WERE SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD. THE AUTHORITY
ESTIMATES CENTRAL VALLEY LINE
WILL COST EIGHTEEN POINT THREE
BILLIONTO BUILD AND WILL BE
OPERATIONAL BY TWENTY TWENTY
NINE. ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR
REMAINS COMMITTED TO BUILDING
THE FULL SYSTEM HE STATES THAT
HIS NEW PLAN IS FOCUSED ON WHAT
THE STATE CAN DO WITH THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE. RIGHT NOW.
THIS SOUNDS VERY REASONABLE
WHAT IS LESS CLEAR IS WHY HE IS
CLAYTON CONSULTANTS WHO HAVE
NOTHING TO LOSE AND EVERYTHING
TO GAIN DICTATE HOW THE STATE
SHOULD INVEST ITS RESOURCES.
EVERY ITERATION OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL PLAN THAT IS PRESENTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE SEEMS TO
GROWING COST. AND SHRINK IN
SCOPE. AND AT SOME POINT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER WE ARE JUST
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRUST THE
AUTHORITIES ABILITY TO DO WHAT
IT PROMISES. OR ARE WE GOING TO
FIND BETTER WAYS OVERSEE THIS
PROJECT AND JUST SPEND THE
STATE'S NOW LIFTED RESOURCES.
WE ALL KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT THE VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION ONE EIGHT TO
PROVIDE NINE BILLION IN BONDS
TO HELP BUILD A FIVE HUNDRED.
MILE LONG HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
LOS ANGELES. AND AT THAT TIME
THE ESTIMATE FOR THE FULL COST
OF THE PROJECT. WAS THIRTY
THREE BILLION. AND IT WAS GOING
TO BE COMPLETED. THIS YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY. SINCE THAT TIME
WE HAVE SEEN NUMEROUS
VARIATIONS ON WHERE THE REAL
AND WOULD BE BUILT. AND COULD
BE BUILT AND WHEN WE COULD
EXPECT A COMPLETED SYSTEM. KATA
FLUCTUATED FROM HIGH OF NEARLY
ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
DOWN TO SIXTY FOUR BILLION AND
MOST RECENTLY EIGHTY BILLION
FOR THE FULL PHASE ONE SYSTEM
IF IT WAS COMPLETED BY. TWENTY
THIRTY THREE. EVERY NEW
BUSINESS PLAN PROMISES THAT
PROBLEMS OF THE PAST HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED AND THAT THIS TIME WE
HAVE IT RIGHT. MEANWHILE WE
HAVE IS A CONSULTING FIRMS AND
HAVE BILLS. VERY LITTLE. THOSE
JOBS A CLAIM TO CREATE OR NOT
CONSTRUCTION JOBS THEIR
CONSULTANTS PUSHING PAPER. THIS
PLAN PROMISES TO INCLUDE
ACCURATE COST AND TIME LINES
AND PROMISES THE BEST RETURN ON
OUR LIMITED INVESTMENTS. I'M
NOT SO SURE. IT SEEMS HARD TO
BELIEVE ANYTHING THE AUTHORITY
CLAIMS AS PLANNED. NEARLY EVERY
STATE IN THE PLAN FROM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS TO JOBS CREATED FROM
INVESTMENTS IN THE BOOKENDS TO
RIDERSHIP COMPARISONS. SEEM
EITHER MISSING. OR DOWN RIGHT
NOT TRUE. MY HOPE IS AND ALWAYS
HAS BEEN THAT WE CAN JUST HAVE
AN HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL OUTCOMES OF THIS
PROJECT. AND HOPEFULLY TODAY WE
CAN FINALLY BEGIN THAT
CONVERSATION. NOW I WANT TO BE
CLEAR. I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR
THE END OF THE DREAM OF A HIGH
SPEED RAIL CALIFORNIA. WE
COMMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
TO THE VOTERS. THAT WE WOULD
PURSUE HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE
AND THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO DO. BUT IS THE
AUTHORITY HAS SAID FOR YEARS
NOW. THAT DREAM MUST BE BUILT
IN BLOCKS. WHAT I'M SEARCHING
FOR I AM SURE YOU ARE ALSO AT
THIS POINT WHAT'S SET OF BLOCKS
SHOULD WE BUILD FIRST IN
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS AS THE
FUNDING PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT
WE THE LEGISLATURE SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS PROJECT.
OF FUNDING AND ALSO THE
OVERSIGHT. AND WE MUST TAKE
THIS RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. THIS IS THE TIME
COLLEAGUES TO REALLY DIG INTO
THE PLAN. AND WE REALLY SHOULD
GET STARTED. TODAY THE
AUTHORITIES DIRECTOR BRIAN
KELLY AS WELL DID KIM THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY OR PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATING TODAVíA VIDEO
CONFERENCING FROM A ROOM
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL. IT
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS. OF THESE WITNESSES.
FOLLOWING THEIR PRESENTATION WE
WILL HEAR FROM HELEN KIRSTINE.
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE VIA TELEPHONE. NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM LUTON SO THE
CHAIR OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
YOU GROUP HE WAS SURE HIS
GROUP'S RESPECT OF VIA
TELEPHONE ALSO ALSO. THIS GROUP
NEED THIS GROUP IS THAT OUR
EXPERTS ADVISING THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN
BENEFIT FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE
OUTSIDE THE PROJECT. DEVELOPERS
THESE PRIVATE CITIZENS ARE
PUTTING THEIR YEARS OF
EXPERTISE AND HELPING US GOVERN
THIS MONUMENTAL PROJECT AND WE
OWE THEM A GREAT DEAL OF
GRATITUDE. AND IF YOU CAN
FINALLY WILL HEAR FROM- VIA
PHONE DR BRIAN TAYLOR DIRECTOR
OF THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES AT UCLA.
AN EXPERT ON TRAVEL BEHAVIOR.
SO MEMBERS I REALLY WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR JOINING ME
TODAY FOR A FOR THIS IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT HEARING. I HOPE THAT
TOGETHER WE ARE ABLE TO MAKE
CLEAR THE ASSEMBLIES HOAX. AND
VERY CLEAR THE EXPECTATIONS FOR
THE FINAL BUSINESS PLAN. MR
FUNG WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS. MISTER
KHAN THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE. I WOULD ALSO ASK
THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE WE GET STARTED WITH OUR-
OUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU THAT
FOR THAT. MEMBERS I HOPE THIS
CAN BE MORE OF A QUESTION
DRIVEN HEARING AFTER WE'VE THE
WITNESSES TALK I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ENGAGE. THE FORTHCOMING
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. FEEL FREE TO
INTERRUPT ENGAGE OUR PANELISTS
AS NEEDED. I WANT US TO GET THE
TO THE HEART OF THINGS TODAY AS
MUCH AS WE CAN. AND FOR THE
PUBLIC. THERE WILL BE AMPLE
TIME TO HEAR FROM YOU FOLLOWING
THE PANELS. BECAUSE I SUSPECT
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK I'D ASK
YOU TO MAKE YOUR COMMENTS
COMPLETE BUT THE STATE. FOR
THOSE OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
ABLE TO SHARE OUR COMMENTS
TODAY YOUR COMMENTS TODAY
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SEND YOUR
COMMENTS TO MY COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND WE WILL HAVE THE SHIP ALL
MEMBERS IN ATTENDANCE TODAY.
OKAY WE'VE GONE THROUGH THE
HOUSEKEEPING WE'VE GONE THROUGH
THE PANEL OF EXPERTS WILL BE
HERE BEFORE US TODAY AGAIN I
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR BEING
HERE AND GAS. WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS INTRODUCE OF. NUMBER ONE
ON OUR- ON OUR PANEL OWN IN THE
ORDER OF GOTTEN MISTER DAVID
KIM SECRETARY CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION OR AGENCY MISTER
CAMP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE IT IS GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU TODAY- ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT. IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY THIS HEARING
WAS SCHEDULED ORIGINALLY FROM
MARCH SIXTEENTH OR SOMEWHERE
AROUND THERE SO- IT'S REALLY.
IN ORDER. NOT JUST FOR WHAT.
HEARING LOGISTICS WHICH WILL BE
ROUTINE FROM THIS POINT OUT SO
THANK YOU FOR CAN US. SO WE
KNOW THAT I CAME HERE ABOUT TEN
MONTHS AGO TO TAKE ON THIS NEW
THINGS WE DID WHAT GOD TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. WAS TO DEVELOP A NEW
VISION ST. THAT VISION IS VERY
SIMPLY. TO TRANSFORM THE LIVES
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS THROUGH THE
SAFETY. ACCESSIBLE LOW CARBON
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. MULTI
MODAL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
ARE VERY MUCH BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROJECT THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT EMBODIES THE
VISION AND WILL TRULY TRANSFORM
THE NATURE OF TRAVEL.
CALIFORNIA AND- UNDERSCORES
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO BRINGING CLEAN
ELECTRIC HIGH SPEED RAIL TO
CALIFORNIA. AND OVER THE FEW
MONTHS AS ALL OF US HAVE
COLLECTIVELY GRAPPLED WITH THE-
INCREDIBLE ECONOMIC. ACT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN AND DEMOCRATS.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
BOLSTERING ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IS
A MAJOR PRIORITY FOR ALL OF US.
THAT MEANS DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO CREATE WELL PAYING
JOBS FOR CALIFORNIA. THIS
PROJECT IS NOT JUST A SOLUTION
TO THAT IMPERATIVE BUT IN FACT
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
PROGRAMS ALREADY UNDER WAY.
IT'S A JOB CREATION. NOW AND
WELL INTO THE FUTURE. DURING
THE GREAT DEPRESSION YOUR DEAL
IS AN ACTIVE BY PRESIDENT
FRANKLIN D. ROOSEVELT THAT
STIMULATED THE ECONOMY PROJECT
THAT INVOLVES. THE STRUCTURE.
AS CALIFORNIA BEGIN TO
RECOVERING FROM THE CURRENT
RECESSION WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE
FROM HISTORY THAT DEMONSTRATES
SUCCESSFUL RECOVERY EFFORTS AND
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROGRAM FOR. IF WITH
YOU JOBS IN SOME OF THE MOST.
HARD HIT REGIONS OF THE STATE.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT CONTINUES
DANCING PURSUANT TO THE
DIRECTION OF THE VOTERS. AND IS
OUT ONE. WITH WHAT THE SIZE THE
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT IT IS
OFTEN AND OPERATE A LOOK HIGH
SPEED TRAINS IN CALIFORNIA. THE
STRATEGY LAID OUT BY THE FORTY
OUT ONCE THE BILL'S PRUDENT WAY
TO PAY THE SUBJECTIVE WITH CARD
AVAILABLE FUNDING. THE PLAN
DESCRIBES REGGIE JUDICIARY HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE FROM HER
SAID THE BIGGEST. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME BROWN WORKED TO
EXPAND BEYOND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY INTO THE BAY AREA AND
TELL A- I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS IS A LONG TERM YES
MA'AM. THAT IS DIRECTLY TIED
THE STATE'S TRANSPORTATION AND
OF OUR LOCAL. CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION REACH FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE BY THE YEAR TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE. WE NEED A PLAN THREE
TRANSFORMATIVE SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
PROVIDED BY METAL PETER
TRANSPORTATION ALTERNATIVES.
LET'S CONSIDER FOR A MOMENT THE
IMPACT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ONE IT IS THE- ABOUT A FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED HIGHWAY
LANE ALSO. NINETY ONE AIRPORT
GATES. TO BRAND NEW AIRPORT
RUNWAYS. BUILDING THIS KIND OF
STRUCTURE WOULD COST THE STATE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT THAT BY ADVANCING HIGH
SPEED RAIL WE ARE SHOWING THAT
CALIFORNIA IS INVESTING IN THE
PRESENT. AS WELL AS BUILDING
FOR THE FUTURE. THROUGH THIS
PROJECT WE ARE LEADING THE
NATION IN ARCHERY IN A NEW ERA
OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. WHAT A
TO FLY HIGH SPEED RAIL SERVICE
DR. STATE REAL SAID. LET ME
STATE AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
EDITING ELECTRIFICATION NOW AT
THIS CRITICAL CRITICAL JUNCTURE
WOULD DELIVER A SERIOUS WELL IN
THE STATE EFFORTS TO MEET OUR
OFFICIALS CLIMATE GOALS. IN
FACT I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT REDUCE GHG
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHICH
CONTAIN. TO BE THE LAW PRODUCER
OF EMISSIONS WILL BE
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT WITHOUT
WIDE EYES RAIL. ALSO I THINK
IT'S A TO RECOGNIZE THE
CALIFORNIA IS AT THE FOREFRONT
OF DEVELOPING AN ENTIRELY BRAND
YOU AMERICANS INDUSTRY WERE
INVESTMENT IN AND THE DEFAULT
OF TECHNOLOGIES MANUFACTURING
CAPABILITIES AND INNOVATIVE
BUSINESS PRACTICES WELL CREEK
HIGH SKILLED. GOOD PAYING JOBS
IN THIS WILL CLEARLY HELP
REBUILD OUR STATE AND NATION.
AS WE RECOVER FROM CODE NINETY.
BUT BEYOND TECHNOLOGICAL
TRANSFORMATION THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT IS ALL ABOUT
TRANSFORMING PEOPLE'S LIVES. UP
WITH THE REGIONAL ECONOMIES IN
CALIFORNIA'S POOREST HARDEST
HIT AREAS AND PROVIDING FULL
ACCESS TO THE ECONOMY TO
RESIDENTS FROM ALL REGIONS OF
THE STATE. THE SERIES OF MERCED
FRESNO AND BAKERSFIELD REMAIN
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED FROM
THE REST THE STATE WHICH IS
MADE IT CHALLENGING FOR
COMMUNITY LEADERS TO ATTRACT
MORE BUSINESSES. BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
THIS NOT ONLY CREATING
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
I'LL PUT. IT WILL BREAK YOUR
GEOGRAPHIC BARRIERS AND GREAT
CRITICAL LINKAGES BETWEEN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND LARGER. MORE
DIVERSE ECONOMIES IN THE BAY
AREA AND LA BASE. THE BUSINESS
PLAN EXPLAINED FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE INVESTING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INITIAL
OPERATING SEGMENTS. WILL RESULT
IN IMMEDIATE. MEANINGFUL
BENEFITS TO THE TRAVELING
PUBLIC COMPARE TO SIMILAR LEVEL
OF INVESTMENT HIGH SPEED RAIL
INVESTMENT IN NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER ANOTHER
PERSPECTIVE. MY FIRST EXPOSURE
TO THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT OCCURRED DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHEN I
WAS A SENIOR OFFICIAL AT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
IN RESPONSE TO THE GREAT
RECESSION. PRESIDENT OBAMA
PROPOSED AND CONGRESS ENACTED.
BURKE AND- REINVESTMENT AND
RICK RECOVERY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINE. TO CREATE JOBS.
EIGHTY ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF THE
NATION'S POOREST AREAS SPUR
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT AND
BUILD NEW TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THE PROVIDE LONG
TERM ECONOMIC BENEFITS. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO CONVERT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT TO A
CONVENTIONAL DIESEL RAIL
SERVICE RATHER THAN A HIGH
SPEED ELECTRIFY TRAIN SERVICE
THERE IS A CONSIDERABLE RISK
THAT THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION WILL WILL ASSERT
THAT THE AUTHORITY HAS. LARA
PRACTICALLY. AS THE BENEFICIARY
OF OR HIGH SPEED RAIL GRANTS IT
IS NOTABLE THAT MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS HAVE BEEN
DISPATCHED TO WORK ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SINCE THE START
OF CONSTRUCTION. ALSO. FIVE
HUNDRED SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
INVOLVED IN THE PROJECT IN
RECENT YEARS WE'VE SEEN
INVESTMENT OF FIVE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN PLANNING AND
BUILDING RESULTING IN EIGHT
POINT ONE TO NINE POINT TWO
BILLION IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT.
EVERY WHAT I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THE- A GROUP OF. THE THREE OF.
THE WAY. YEAH YEAH YEAH. THE
PROBLEM WITH. BUT THE CURRENT
OF THE. WITH THE- CAN WE GET OF.
WE'RE TO MR KENNEDY'S WE'VE
LOST THE FEED. OKAY YEAH WE
LOST ABOUT A MINUTE AGO SO IF
YOU CAN BACK UP A LITTLE BIT.
OKAY SURE. THE HERE. OKAY IF
THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO CONVERT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT TO A
CONVENTIONAL DIESEL RAIL
SERVICE RATHER THAN A HIGH
SPEED ELECTRIFY TRAIN SERVICE
THERE IS A CONSIDERABLE RISK
THAT THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONCLUDE.
HAVE REACHED THE ARE. AS THE
BENEFICIARY OF OUR HIGH SPEED
RAIL GRANTS IT IS NOTABLE THAT
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
HAVE BEEN DISPATCHED TO WORK ON
A HIGH SPEED RAIL PROGRAM IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SINCE THE
START OF CONSTRUCTION. ALSO
FIVE THIS IS OUR INVOLVED WITH
THE PROJECT IN RECENT YEARS WE
HAVE SEEN INVESTMENT OF FIVE
POINT SEVEN BILLION IN PLANNING
AND BUILDING RESULTING IN A
POINT ONE TO NINE POINT TWO
BILLION ECONOMIC OUTPUT. IN
EVERY WAY. THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT HAS EXCEEDED CONGRESS'S
INTENT. OF LIFT REGIONAL
ECONOMIES AND CREATE JOBS IN
THE HARDEST HIT AREAS LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AS THE PANDEMIC
BEGINS TO GRADUALLY SUBSIDE
THIS PROJECT IS EVEN MORE
ESSENTIAL AS RETURN TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. THAT'S I WANT YOU I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE FULLY
SUBSCRIBE TO THE VIEW THAT
BOOSTING TRANSIT AND RAIL
INVESTMENT IN SOUTHERN AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. AND ON
THAT POINT I WANT TO NOTE THAT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENTS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN RECENT YEARS AND
THESE RICH WILL CONTINUE LET ME
JUST REVIEW A COUPLE OF KEY
DATA POINTS. SO THE- DOESN'T
FOUR POINT ZERO. BILLION
DOLLARS. IN TRANSIT AND
COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEMS PROJECTS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
NUMBER IN NORTHERN. POINT FOR
BILL IT. NUMBER FOUR POINT SIX
DOLLARS AND SEVEN CALIFORNIA
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LOOKING
AHEAD OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
UP TO FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
STATE PROGRAMS FULL FORM HEADED
OF. OTHER STATE FUNDING WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO VANCE RAIL TRANSIT
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
I WANT TO NOTE THAT NOT THESE
DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT. THESE FUNDS WERE.
REALLY OF MY SB ONE THANK TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP MISTER CHAIRMAN
A K. AND TRADE IN THE SHOWCASE
YOUR COMMITMENT ALONG WITH THE
COMMITMENT OF OUR VOTERS TO
EXPAND TRANSIT OPTIONS FOR ALL.
IN FACT. JUST LAST HEALTH
AWARDED FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT TO WORK
THROUGH THE TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM
FOR T. R. C. P. TO SEVENTEEN
RECIPIENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THESE GRAVEL PLAY A HUGE ROLE
IN GENERATING MUCH NEEDED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. THEY WILL
ALSO ADVANCE TRANSFORMATIVE
HELP WILL PREVENT THAT WILL
MODERNIZE INNER CITY. COMMUTER
AND URBAN RAIL SYSTEMS AS WELL
AS BUS AND FERRY TRANSIT
SYSTEMS. THESE INVESTMENT WILL
SIGNIFICANT. WHILE TROUBLED AND
CONGESTION IT IS WORTH POINTING
OUT THAT PREVIOUSLY AWARDED T.
I. R. C. P. GRANTS HAVE
SUPPORTED SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE INCLUDING THE BART
EXTENSION TO SAN JOSE AND
MULTIPLE RAIL PROJECTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OUGHT TO
PREPARE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT. SUMMER OLYMPICS. RICHARD
SHERMAN MEMBERS AS WE
COLLECTIVELY WORK TOWARD
RECOVERING FROM THE COLD IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME TALKING THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND
BUILDING A MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE. I VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO COLLABORATING
CLOSELY WITH YOU. AND THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
BEFORE YOU AND I LOOK FOR TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SECRETARY KIM ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE SECRETARY OF THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE. US
SECRETARY WILL I APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENDING THE- HEARING
TODAY AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
SUCCESSFUL- TERM AS THE SECTOR
YOU'VE DONE A WONDERFUL JOB
THUS FAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL.
ANALYST MISTER KELLY BRIAN
KELLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WELCOME TO OUR BRAIN. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S BEEN
SOME TIME SINCE I'VE SEEN YOU-
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN. EVEN
VIRTUALLY AND- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE HERE TODAY I
AM ALWAYS HONOR TO APPEAR
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THOUGHT I
WOULD- USE A POWER POINT
PRESENTATION TO CONVEY SORT OF
A SUMMARY. OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN WHICH I WILL ROLL
THROUGH. THAT WITH YOU HERE
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS.
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN THE- NEW
WORLD OF COVERT NINETEEN I
THINK THAT'S A RELEVANT- ISSUE.
CAN BE LOST. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU GUYS CAN SEE THE POWER
POINTS I WANT TO TRY TO GET
BACK ON THE SCREEN. BEAR WITH
ME JUST ONE SECOND HERE. OKAY
THANK YOU ANYWAY I AS I SAID I
AFTER THE POWER POINT A COUPLE
COMMENTS ABOUT- WHERE WE ARE
NOW WE'RE NEVER GETTING TO THIS
IS A VERY UNIQUE TIME- ON
FEBRUARY TWELFTH WE DID RELEASE
A DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN OF- FOR HOW WE WOULD
PROCEED A MOVING FORWARD- WITH
THIS TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECT.
FIVE TEETH IN THE CALIFORNIA IS
A NATIONAL LEADER ON CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS A VERY INTEGRAL
PART OF THAT AND WE ENCOURAGE
THE STATE POLICYMAKERS I DO NOT
TURN BACK OF THAT COMMITMENT TO
MOVE FORWARD ON A CLEAN
SUSTAINABLE- FAST THE RAIL RAIL
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA. WE KNOW
THE COST ESTIMATES THAT ARE
CONTAINED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN ARE GENERALLY
WITHIN THE RANGES OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- BUSINESS PLAN WHICH
WAS THE FIRST BUSINESS PLAN
SINCE I. CAME OVER THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL FORTY WHERE. USE
RANGES TO DESCRIBE ACOSTA
ESTIMATES AND I WANT TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT THAT. UP
THE REASON WE MOVED TO RANGES
AS I. AS I. TOOK THIS POSITION
AND MOVED INTO THIS- JOB I DID
NOT THINK IT WAS. OF
APPROPRIATE- TO TRY TO. PROVIDE
A SINGLE A DOLLAR SIGN ESTIMATE
FOR WHAT THE PROJECT WOULD
COST. WHEN SO MUCH OF THE
PROJECT IS STILL IN THE PROJECT
DELIVERY FACE. EARLY PROJECT
LIVE BATES. IT'S WORTH
REMINDING. THEM THAT- ABOUT SIX
OF OUR REMAINING. OF SEGMENTS
ARE STILL IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS NOW IS I'LL GO THROUGH
ALL INDICATE THAT WE ARE.
MOVING IN AND OUT ACCIDENT.
THROUGH THE FARM PROP AS- I
THAT IS EARLY IN THE
DEVELOPMENT. ROSS SAYS TO TRY
TO ESTA WITH SPECIAL WHAT THE
COST WOULD BE AT THAT POINT IS
A KNOT INVESTOR PRACTICES- BEST
INDUSTRY PRACTICES FOR COST
ESTIMATING SO WE MOVED TO A
RANGE OF- ESTIMATED TWENTY
TWENTY PLAN- CONTINUES THAT
THAT- THAT APPROACH. A THIRD-
WE TAKE THAT THE BEST USE OF
AVAILABLE HIGH SPEED RAIL
FUNDING IS TO EXPAND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT- OF.
FROM CURRENTLY RIGHT A POPULAR
AVENUE A HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
STRETCH. TO REALLY CONNECT
THREE THE MAIN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SAID FRESNO IT MAKERS.
OF WE'VE GOT ADDITIONAL REVIEW
THAT PROPOSAL AND OUR BUSINESS
PLAN LAID OUT. SOME OF THOSE
WERE BOTH FROM. G. AND ENJOY.
LOOK AT A REFINED CASE AND ALSO
OUR TRAIN A WHO'S THE FROM THE
RUN TYSON RAIL IN GERMANY WHO
ALSO- DID AN ANALYSIS AND- LAID
OUT THE BENEFITS OF THIS
APPROACH SO. INCLUDED BOTH OF
THOSE- SUMMARIES OF IN OUR IN
OUR TWENTY. A TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN FOURTH. AND I THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT NOTE OFTHIS
ORGANIZATION CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE UNDER NEW LEADERSHIP WE
HAVE HAD A LOT OF CHANGE- IN
THE LAST- TWELVE TO FIFTEEN
MONTHS- I THINK WE'RE NOW ON
THIS COMING UP WITH THE SIX-
CHANGE ON OUR BOARD- WE'VE-
WE'VE CHANGED ALMOST THE
ENTIRETY OF THE- OF EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT TEAM IN HIGH SPEED
RAIL. WE HAVE A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE NOW THE BUDGET-
THAT MOVES- AWAY FROM A SOME
CONSULTING SERVICES TOWARD IT'S
THAT TO LINE. THE FORMER
ORGANIST INTO REALLY FUNCTION
INTO THAT THAT'S A PROPOSAL
SPENDING A NOW THE PROCESS
AGAIN PART OF AN ORGANIZATIONAL
REFORM THAT STARTED EARLY I GOT.
WE CONTINUE TO ADVANCE. IN FIVE
WE NOTE THAT RAIL IN KEEP IT IN
CROSS THE STATE. WHILE HIGH
SPEEDS ARE DELIVERED FROM A
MERCED THE BIGGEST BILL I THINK
YOU SECRETARY KEMP LAID OUT A
WHILE WE HAVE. THE SORT OF THE
WELL DEFINED THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER. TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
SOURCES AVAILABLE. BUDGET IS
AROUND THE STATE THE END UP
CERTAINLY THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY THE LEGISLATURE OTHERS
PLAY A KEY ROLE. IN IN WHERE
THOSE DOLLARS GO BUT THERE'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE.
TO MOVE THE STATE OF AS I
INDICATED A NUMBER ONE ABOVE. A
TO CONTINUE TO BE THE NATIONAL
LEADER BUT NOT JUST WITH THIS
PROJECT. WITH SMART REGIONAL.
LOCAL TRANSIT PROJECTS WELL. SO
THOSE ARE THE BY T. THEMES ARE
IN THE BUSINESS PLAN AND THEN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS WORTH WHILE TO
SORT OF TAKE A SNAPSHOT OF
WHERE WE ARE. WITH ELECTRIFIED
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. NOT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
OF ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT IN THE STATE-
IN THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION MOST IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR.
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE CALTRAIN
SAYS CALTRAIN IS THE COMMUTER
RAIL THAT RUNS BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN JOSE. VITAL
VERY DIDN'T INVENT. IN A- THAT
CORRIDOR. WHICH PROVIDES SHORT
TERM BENEFITS FOR CALTRAIN AND
ULTIMATELY WATER BENEFITS FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN OUR SERVICE.
THEY GO THROUGH THAT STRETCHES
OF THE ELECTRIFICATION. IS BOTH
THE SHORT TERM GAIN IN THE LONG
DURING GAME FOUR OF THOSE WHO
RIDE. A TRANSIT IN FUTURE SB
RAIL IN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
MIDDLE PART OF THE STATE IS
THE- ACTION OF A ARE ALSO
APPEARED. ADVANCE
ELECTRIFICATION ON A HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE MILES. TODAY WE ARE
UNDER CONSTRUCTION ON A HUNDRED
NINE MILES BETWEEN MADERA. BUT
THE LOCATION ABOUT EIGHTY
THOUSAND. OF BIG CALL POPULAR
AVENUE- WE ARE PROPOSING TO
EXTEND THAT HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILE STRETCH INTO THE URBAN.
AREAS OF BAKERSFIELD AT THE
SOUTH MERCED A TO THE NORTH OF
GIVING US A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND ELECTRIFIED RAIL. AND
THEN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I
THINK THAT THE NEW PLAYER ON
THE BLOCK IS. IS VIRGIN TRAINS-
WHICH THE- IDENTITY THAT IS
CAUSING TO BUILD UP HIGH SPEED
RAIL BETWEEN LAS VEGAS. AND AT
LEAST AS THE FIRST BUILDING
BLOCK DOWN THERE- TO
VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA
ULTIMATELY OF COURSE VIRGIN AS
OR AS I SAID ON EXTENDING TO
PALMDALE AND THEN FURTHER
SOUTH. THE INTO THE LA BASIN SO
WE SEE GREAT OPPORTUNITIES TO.
SEE IF WE CAN'T WORK TOGETHER
TO. BRING ELECTRIFIED SPEED AND
THAT BASIN AS EARLY AS WELL THE
DOTTED LINE ON THIS MAP UP. ARE
WE STILL IN THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT APPROVAL SAYS AS OF
TODAY. IF WE LOOK FOR ABOUT TWO
YEARS WERE YOU NOW WOULD HAVE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILES. OF
FULLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN ALL OF
PHASE ONE BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- IS PROPOSED TO BE
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEAR. THAT'S
WHY THOSE DOTTED LINES NOW
BECOME SALAS. UP THIS IS NOT A
MINOR ACHIEVEMENT- A CLEARING
OF FIVE HUNDRED IN ROUGHLY FIVE
HUNDRED MILES. ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL OF ROUTE IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH VERY
DIFFERENT TOP GRAFFITI AT THEIR
VERY DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHY OF.
THESE VERBS REGIONS OF. FORMULA
IS QUITE AN ACCOMPLISHMENT THE
NAY ALLOWS. BUT THEN THE START
DOING SOME OF THE IMPORTANT PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK EXPANDING
DESIGN. ENGAGING AND I WENT
NEARING AS ARE THE MAP THE
NECESSARY RIGHT AWAY. ODJICK
THEY AS THIS IS IN A MILE AND-
AND AGAIN OF REFLECTIVE OF TRUE
ADVANCEMENT IN THE SPIRIT OF A
PROP ONE A. AS I KNOW WE- WE
PROPOSED TO EXTEND IN THIS
BUSINESS PLAN- THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE SEGMENT TO GET
INTO BAKERSFIELD AND PERCENT.
MAKING IT A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
MILE INTEREST THIS IS THE ONLY
SECTION THE STATE THAT- WROTE
TRAINS CAN A TRULY RUN AT HIGH
SPEED RAIL IT'S DESIGNED TO RUN
DOING ANY MILES PER HOUR- AND-
BRING HIGH SPEED RAIL- WHAT
YOUR FIGHT HIGH SPEED RAIL INTO
THIS AREA. WILL REVIEW OF ALL
TIME BY. UPWARDS OF NINETY
MINUTES. ONE MILES WOULD ALSO
EXPANDS OF THE ECONOMIC. IMPACT
AND DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES
THAT SECRETARY KIM REFERENCE IN
HIS TESTIMONY- IT WOULD EXTEND
THE A NUMBER OF JOB YEARS
CREATED BY THE PROJECT TO OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE A THIRTY EIGHT
BILLION IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
FOR THE INVESTMENT. OF A JUST
OVER TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS I
SHOULD ALSO SAY IT HELPS US
WITH BILL COMMITMENTS THAT WE
MADE TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY ON A
PERMANENT JOBS IN PERMANENT
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF FROM
THE ARRIVAL OF ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL THE MORNING. I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE
EARLY TRAIN UP PERFORMED A SIDE
BY SIDE. ANALYSIS OUTLINE THE
BENEFITS OF DOING THE
EXTENSION- INTO A BAKERSFIELD
TO THE SOUTH OF OR SET OF
NORTH. END OF THESE WITH THE
CONCLUSIONS. OF REALLY OF BOTH
THE- EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR AND
CONFIRMED BY OUR- A FINANCIAL
ADVISER THAT- THIS IS REALLY
THE BEST VALUE FOR THE MONEY.
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE HERE
EXPANDS THE TRAIN SERVICE
TREMENDOUSLY A TODAY THAT SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICE HAS ABOUT-
SEVEN DAILY TRIPS BUT WE'RE
LOOKING TO EXPAND THAT TO
EIGHTEEN. OF THROUGH USE OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CENTRAL
VALLEY- REDUCING THE TRAVEL
TIMES I MENTIONED I BETWEEN. A
HUNDRED AND THE NINE. HUNDRED
AND- OUR THAT. INCREASED
RIDERSHIP WITH OR AS OPERATING
COSTS THAT EXISTS TODAY IT'S
ALSO UNDER CURRENT BUDGET
ESTIMATES AND AFFORDABLE OF
PROGRAMS- ESTIMATED TO COST
ABOUT TWENTY POINT FOUR
BILLION. AND WE ESTIMATE AT. WE
PUT ON OUR DROUGHT BUSINESS
PLAN THE OF THE ESTIMATED
BUDGET- OF AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROJECT TO BE BETWEEN TWENTY
POINT SIX BILLION TWENTY THREE
POINT FOUR. BILLION DOLLARS IN
THAT RANGE IS REALLY A RANGE
BECAUSE- IT'S IS DEPENDENT ON
ON THE OF FUNCTIONALITY AND THE
RESULTS OF CAP AND TRADE. IT
ALSO CONNECTS THE SOME OF THE
THREE FASTEST GROWING AREAS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MERCED
FRESNO AND BAKERSFIELD. IT
PROVIDES INTERIM CONNECTIONS IN
MERCED THE PLAN IS TO CONNECT
WITH BOTH THE SAN JOAQUIN AND A
SERVICE AT A- OF A SINGLE
STATION IN THE DOWNTOWN OR SET.
UP ALLOWING FOLKS TO MOVES
TRAINS I CAN GO ON WERE TO A
SACRAMENTO OR TOWARD THE BAY
AREA. OF THE A SERVICE IN THE
WORKING. THE SERVICE AND- ALL
OF ITS STAND A TRAVEL INTO THE
LA BASIN OUT OF BAKERSFIELD THE
ABBAS CONNECTIONS. IT ALSO
DEMONSTRATES THE PUBLIC AND THE
MARKETS THE VIABILITY OF AN
OPERATIONAL HIGH SPEED RAIL
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU PLEASE
THE FIRST BUILDING BLOCK ONLY
THE FIRST. BUILDING BLOCK OF
THE PHASE ONE STEPS GO TO LA
AND I'M VISION APPROVED. BY THE
VOTERS THIS IS JUST A DEPICTION
OF A- AGAIN WHY WE DO A
PROPOSED TO EXTEND- THE- THE
ORIGINAL- SERVICE TERRITORY
AGAIN THE HUNDRED NINETY MILES
THE- CURRENT SOUTHERN TERMINUS
IS. AT A PLACE CALLED POP RAP
IN DOING. YOUR CHAPTER
CALIFORNIA- SURROUNDED LARGELY
BY AGRICULTURAL FIELDS- WE
PROPOSED TO EXTEND THAT
FURTHER- INTO DOWNTOWN
BAKERSFIELD- IN A- ALONG AN
ALIGNMENT AND AT A LOCATION IN
BAKERSFIELD. OF THAT IT'S BEEN
PART OF A LOCAL AGREEMENT-
THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS WHERE WE APPROVES OF
THE GULF THE- OF. OF LOCAL-
LOCAL ALTERNATIVE FOR. THE
BAKERSFIELD THE EXTENT. IN THE
NORTH IT'S A SIMILAR EXTENSION
IN THE MORE URBAN AREA- FROM A
SERB SORT OF SUBURBAN. OF A
MADERA TRAIN STATION IN A
MADERA WE ARE PROPOSING TO
EXTEND FURTHER A RIGHT IN THE
HEART OF THE MERCED- HAVE THE
NERVE NORTHERN TERMINUS. OF
MEAT IN DOWNTOWN MERCED WERE
AGAIN IT'LL BE BOTH THE ACE IN
SAN JOAQUIN SPACES- HEADING
NORTH AND WEST OF THE BEAR. I
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE AS AS A
MAN EARLIER IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES- WE PUT
IN PLACE. OF A SERIES OF
GOVERNANCE MOVES AND OTHER
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE THAT. WE
DEPICT- INTO DETAIL AND- IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN BUT WE'VE ALSO
REALLY START TO FEEL SOME
MOMENTUM. ON THE GROUND YOU
HAVE DONE. THE THINGS PICKING
UP IN TERMS OF OUR CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITY AT THIS CHART IS A
SIMPLE DEPICTION OF. A WHERE WE
WERE ABOUT A YEAR AGO A
SPENDING ABOUT TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS A PER MONTH
THIS IS A MONTHLY EXPENDITURES
BY QUARTER. OF THE SECOND
QUARTER TWENTY NINETEEN WORST
ABOUT TWENTY TWO MILLION. OF
MODIFIED CONSTRUCTION- CENTRAL
VALLEY. NOW TRIPLE THAT. IN THE
COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR. OUR
LATEST NUMBERS FOR THE FIRST
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY. I
HAVE A SAID ABOUT SIXTY SIX
MILLION OF PER MONTH. THIS IS
THE THESE ARE THE NUMBERS FOR
THE WEEKLY AVERAGE WORKERS. A
DISPATCH TO THE PROJECT THAT'S
IT EACH WEEK THE NUMBER WORKERS
ARE OUT WORKING ON THE SITE.
AND AGAIN YOU SEE A GROWTH OF
FROM THE VERSA A SECOND QUARTER
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. AT EACH
QUARTER WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
EXPAND THE CONSTRUCTION WORK
DOWN THE VALLEY NOW WE HAVE.
MORE WORK TO DO WE NEED TO SEE
THESE EXPENDITURE RATES
CONTINUE TO CLIMB- AND WE NEED
TO BE DISPATCHING MORE MORE
WORKERS TO THE- BUDGET SITES
BUT I PLEASE THAT. IF I GO BACK
ALL THE WAY TO. HE DO YOU WITH
QUADRUPLED THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS DISPATCH THE TO THE
CONSTRUCTION SITES ON A WEEKLY
BASIS IN CENTRAL VALLEY. I AND
THIS IS A COURSE JUST A
DEPICTION OF A OF HOW THE
LARGER PROJECT ALL OF THE-
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT IN CENTRAL
VALLEY. ARE PICKING UP BACK IN
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD
ABOUT FIFTY TWO MILES OF
GUIDEWAY CLEAR THAT'S NOW UPTO
SEVENTY EIGHT MILES- AND WE'VE
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES WE'RE- DELIVERING
WITH A DOUBLE. THE NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES THAT ARE EITHER
COMPLETE OR IN PROGRESS OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR OR
SO- INVESTMENT ON THE GROUND
IS- IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING VERY
UP OUT OF THAT AGAIN WE HAVE.
MORE WORK TO DO WE ARE WE HAVE.
BONTA OF DEADLINE TO COULD THIS
WORK BUT I'M HAPPY TO REPORT
THAT WE ARE- MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND- AND WHILE
WE ABSENT CHALLENGES I'M HAPPY
TO. TALK ABOUT THEM I AM
PLEASED TO SEE- THAT OF THE
WORK WE'RE PUTTING IN IS. A
PAYING DIVIDENDS- DUTIES FOR
THE- A PART OF LAST YEAR. HI
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL- CLEARANCES WE
HAVE A TOTAL OF TEN
ENVIRONMENTAL SEGMENTS. THAT
NEED TO BE CLEARED FOR THIS
PROJECT- IT'S BEEN FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAD APPROVED THE
RECORD OF DECISION. CERTIFYING
A RECORD OF DECISION FOR. A
SEGMENT AND I'M- HAPPY TO SAY
THAT- WE- WE- CERTIFIED A ROD
RECORD OF DECISION FOR THE- OF
LOCALLY GENERATED ALL TURN INTO
BAKERSFIELD. IN OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN. OF WERE POISED TO DO
THE SECOND ONE FOR WHAT WE CALL
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHY THAT
SHOULD BE DONE IS NUMBER. OF
THIS YEAR SO THAT RODS- IN
ABOUT A YEAR'S TIME. AT THE END
OF WE HAVE A PUT OUT. OVER THE
COURSE OF LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
AND WE WILL THROUGH JULY. OF
THIS- OF FOR ADDITIONAL
STATEMENTS WILL HAVE THE DRAFT
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS. ON
BOTH THE FEDERAL AND STATE.
THANK FINISH THAT TO GO THROUGH
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS. A
GET COMMENT TAKE COMMENT AND
RESPOND TO COMMENTS. IN THAT
ABOUT THIRTY MONTHS LATER WE'RE
PROPOSING. A TO GET THESE RODS
THAT AS WELL THE LAST TWO THAT
WILL FOLLOW UP OUR- THE BALL
PALMDALE TO BURBANK. SEGMENT
WHICH WERE PROPOSING. A WILL
PROBABLY THAT DROP WILL
PROBABLY GET OUT TO THE VERY
END. OF TWENTY TWENTY EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DELAYED AND
I'M SECTION- WHICH WILL COME
OUT LATE TWENTY TWENTY ONE- SO
YOU SEE THE REVISED ROD DATES
IN THE- SECOND COLUMN OVER. OF
THE REGISTER COM OVER THE LAST
COUPLE. IS SORT OF THE-
DEPICTION OF THE FLOAT WE HAVE
IT IS. THE NUMBER FUNDS BETWEEN
WHEN WE POST GET THE RODS
CERTIFIED AND ARE A FEDERAL
DEADLINE IF THIS. WERE COMPLETE
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF. TO GET
IN HERE IT'S VERY INVOLVED
PROCESS WITH. COMMUNITIES AND
STATE BUT WE ARE MOVING. OF
EFFECTIVELY RIGHT NOW CROSSES.
I'M I THINK A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE WILL AT EITHER HAS
HEARD OR WE'LL BE HEARING SOON
ABOUT VARIOUS IMPACTS FROM CO
IN NINETEEN TO TRANSIT SYSTEMS
IN THEIR DISTRICTS YEAH THE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT- BUT WE ARE NOT A DICEY
REAL AUTHORITY A MEDIUM- TO
IMPACTS FROM THE COLD IN
NINETEEN- VIRUS- THIS GLOBAL
PANDEMIC IS THAT QUITE AFFECT.
ACROSS THE BOARD BOTH AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH MATTER IN AS AN
ECONOMIC MATTER LOCALLY- BUT IS
ALSO HAVING SOME IMPACTS THE
CERTAINLY A RIDERSHIP OF THOSE
WERE OPERATING. OF FOR US THE
BE IMPACTS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT- WE ARE GETTING SOME
REQUESTS TO. SLOW DOWN A SOME
OF OUR PROCESS IS TO ASSURE
THAT- PEOPLE CAN COMMENT FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS- THAT- ARE- THE
ARBITERS OF THE DRAGON SYSTEMS-
PROGRAM ARE ABLE TO SECURE- UP
ON FINANCING OTHER THINGS THEY
NEED TO. RESPOND PROPERLY TO
THE BEDS AND SO- WE'VE OF SLOW
DOWN SOME OF THESE PROCESSES-
TO ACCOMMODATE. THOSE REQUESTS
SO WE ARE VERY MUCH OF. A PART.
OF THE ACTIVE OF THE GOAL TO
NINETY OF PROCESS I SAY THAT.
OF NINETEEN THAT MAKE AND I
SAID IN PART BECAUSE I THINK
YOU WILL BE SEEING AS WE MOVE-
TOWARD OUR FINAL BUSINESS PLAN
FROM THE- DRAFT IS A PLAN THAT
WE- UP OUT- A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENT STRATEGY THAT ALLOW
US TO COMEDY. OF WITH THE THIS
EMBED OF WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
ADVANCE. IS THAT THREE WORDS
I'D USED WILL WE'RE GOING.
ADVANCE READ. AND REPORT. AND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS AS I
NOTED EARLIER WE HAVE. AN
EXPANDING CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
IN THE VALLEY WE ARE MOVING
THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK-
WE ARE ASSIGNING DOLLARS TO
BOOK AND PROJECTS. YEAH THE LOS
ANGELES AREA YEAH AND WE HAVE
B	C IN PROJECTS UNDER WAY. IN
THE NORTH HELP. YOU DO ADVANCED
THAT WORK THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD- SO WE
CAN KEEP PEOPLE PUTTING
CONTINUED. PEOPLE TO WORK- AS
WELL AS GET THAT GET THAT WORK
DONE- WE HAVE TO RECALIBRATE OF
THAT- I DO THINK- THAT- AS THE-
GLOBAL PANDEMIC A IS NOT.
CONCLUDED YET ANONYMOUS OR
TIGHTLY CERTAIN WHAT COMES NEXT
WITH THIS AND WE HAVE A VERY
PRUDENT AND CAUTIOUS. I AM
HAPPY MOVE MOVE FOR. SO WE WILL
BE DOING MORE EXPANDED RISK
ANALYSIS. OF RICH DON'T DROP
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT ALL
THESE IMPACTS ARE HOW. THE
IMPACT THE WORK THAT WE DO-
AND- ALL WE ARE LET OUT OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN A VISION THAT WE
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT. TO
MOVE THE PROJECT FOR A WE WILL
BE OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
FOUR MONTHS. OF THE CONDUCT THE
BILL FOR RISK IN A SAYS. THREE
WEEKS. I THESE IMPACTS ARE
AFFECTING OUR PRO. AND OF
COURSE WILL REPORT. OF THOSE IN
AS WE GET TO THE END OF THE AN
EXAM WHERE WE STAND. AS WE HAD
TO THE BALL FIVE I THINK THE
BUDGET CYCLE FOR. NEXT YEAR OF
COURSE WERE ALSO- WE HAVE A
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT THAT'S
DUE TO LEGISLATURE- IN THE
EARLY PART OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND SO ADVANCE RECALIBRATE
AND REPORT WILL CERTAINLY BE.
THEMES THAT I THINK- YOU'LL SEE
AS WE MOVE UP FROM THE DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN. I TO THE FINAL A
BUSINESS PLAN- SO WELL WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN- I'M HAPPY
TO CONCLUDE MY REMARKS. IN
AGAIN I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING. YOUR QUESTIONS AND
THOSE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MR GET
CITIES RAISED HIS. HAND AND
MIKE TO ME NO WILL HAVE OTHER
MEMBERS. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AS CHAIRMAN- TO SECRETARY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR PRESENTATION. I HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE AS WE
LIVE IN THIS. PANDEMIC
ENVIRONMENT WE CALL BIG
NINETEEN. ONE WATER SURE SAYS
CAN YOU GIVE- MAY AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS WELL
AS THE CONSTITUENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT ONE THAT WITH
ALL THE- PLANS THAT HAD THE
BUSINESS PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN.
TAKING PLACE NUMEROUS TIMES AND
DANGEROUS TIMES- THAT WE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK- FOR SUCCESS.
THAT'S ONE QUESTION AND IN THE
AND THEN THE OTHER QUESTION WAS
SIMPLY BE- CAN WE DO THIS
WITHOUT THE USE OF PUBLIC MONEY.
CAN WE DO THIS PROJECT- USING-
PRIVATE MONEY EXCLUSIVE I KNOW
CHINA HAS DONE VERY WELL WITH
USING NO PUBLIC MONEY BUT ALL
PRIVATE MONEY. AND THEY SEEM TO
HAVE HAD DONE THEIR HIGH SPEED
WHERE ALL- WHEN I VISITED-
CHINA AND THERE YOU KNOW.
GALLAGHER RETURN THEIR DAUGHTER
AND SEEM LIKE IT'S MAKING SENSE
THAT'S MY SECOND QUESTION AND
MY THIRD AND FINAL QUESTION
WILL IN FACT THE- WITH THE-
BUDGET THA'S BEFORE US TODAY
WITH A FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET SHORTFALL. HOW
MUCH YOU GUYS ARE ASKING FOR IN
THE BUDGET. TO HELP OUR WITH
THIS PROJECT IF ANY. UP SORRY
DAVID. WELL THANKS THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION MISTER GIBSON-
I'LL TAKE A SHOT AT THE FIRST
ONE AND THEN WILL DEFER TO
BRIAN FOR- THE SECOND AND THIRD
QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF ALL ARE
WE ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND I
LOVE THE EUPHEMISM- THE ANSWER
IS- WITHOUT QUESTION YES I WAS
NOT HERE- IN PREVIOUS YEARS
WHEN ALL SOME PEOPLE SAY THAT
THE BUSINESS PLAN WENT THROUGH
NUMEROUS CHANGES SO I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT. WELL WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THE GOVERNOR HAS MADE
CRYSTAL CLEAR HIS EXPECTATIONS
ROSS WHICH IS TO TAKE A
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH A LIVE
WITHIN YOUR MEANS APPROACH TO
GET GOING ON THE MERCED THE
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT WHILE THE
SAME TIME PURSUING-
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK AT THE
BOOKENDS AND EVENTUALLY
EXTENDED TO THOSE AREAS THIS IS
A PRUDENT APPROACH AND I
BELIEVE IT'S ONE THAT WILL WORK
THAT'S HIS EXPECTATION FROST
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING. AND ON. TO A ORDER FOR A
BRIGHT. I THANK YOU- MISTER
SECRETARY I WOULD. JUST ADD
THAT- IN TERMS OF THE RIGHT
TRACK- QUESTION- A PARTICULAR
IN THE COPA NINETEEN-
ENVIRONMENT THAT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHY WE WANNA- WE DO THINK WE
PLAYED OUT THE MOST PRUDENT
APPROACH A GIVEN THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO THE
PROJECT FOR HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS- WE THINK IT IS
IMPORT TO GET ALL OF THE-
HUNDRED NINETY MILE. SEGMENT
DONE- WHICH IS A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT FOR US SO WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE THAT WORK
COMPLETELY ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
GET THE BOOK AND A PROJECTS
DONE BOTH IN LA IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- AND THEN THAT AGAIN
EXPAND TO A MORE OPERABLE
SEGMENT FROM HUNDRED NINETY TO
ONE SEVENTY ONE AGAIN AS THE
FIRST. BUILDING BLOCK- COMMENCE
TESTING OF TRAINS AND THEN
MOVING TO OPERATION SO WE THINK
THOSE ARE ALL THE IMPORTANT
THINGS TO DO IN AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT IN THE EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS OF THE PROJECT- ARE
SUCH THAT- ESPECIALLY COMING
OUT OF A WHAT MIGHT BE OF LIKE
THE RECESSION THE KIDS- A VITAL
THAT WE HAVE THESE GUYS THE-
NAMIK GOVERNMENT OPPORTUNITY
THE- HAPPENING SO- SO I THINK
THAT'S OF IMPORTANCE. IN TERMS
OF DOING THE PROJECT- WITHOUT-
WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC MONEY- I
THINK UP THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES THERE THAT THAT ARE
IMPORTANT BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY-
I THINK YOU DO HAVE TO USE
PUBLIC MONEY AND WE ARE USING
PUBLIC MONEY OF FOR SOME OF THE
INITIAL THE CAPITAL WORKING TO
GET ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE TO
DO THINGS LIKE WEAR. A
PROCUREMENT I A USING THOSE
FUNDS TO. BETTER DEFINE THE
PROJECT TO THE RISK OF THE
PROJECT THAT I THINK. THAT IN.
THE PRIVATE CAPITAL TO. EVEN
WHERE YOU HAVE A WHAT'S
CONSIDERED A PRIVATE ARE THE
WITH THE VIRGIN TRAINS AS IN
THIS OTHER CAL REGION I MEAN
REMEMBER THAT THERE IS THERE
ARE PUBLIC ACTIONS NECESSARY TO
MAKE THAT PROJECT OUT OF FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE USING PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY OR PROPOSING TO
USE A PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY THAT
MUST BE SEATED TO THEM BY THE-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY'RE
GETTING FINANCING HELP FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IF THEY
ARE TAKING SO THE FIST OF THE
INVESTMENT RISK BUT WE ARE
PROVIDING OTHER HELPFUL PARTS
TO THAT- TO THAT PROJECT AND
THEN LASTLY JUST AS THE BUDGET-
EXERCISE WE ARE ONLY SEEKING IN
THE BUDGET WHICH ALREADY
APPROPRIATED A TO THIS PROJECT
THIS THROUGH A CAP TRADE
DETAINEES BRITISH AUCTIONS I
THINK IT'S A MAJOR ABOUT THE
POINTS. FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
THAT'S A OF TO THIS PROGRAM.
BUT THAT'S ALREADY. AS I SAID A
USE THE APPROPRIATE A FUNDS FOR
THIS PER AND SO WE ARE SEEKING
NOTHING. UP BEYOND THAT- AND-
THAT MISTER QUESTION RICH KELLY
IF I MEMBERS CHAIRMANSHIP. WITH
THE WITH THE ACTUAL THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES OR THE
MILES THAT YOU- POSING TO DO
THIS ACTUAL OBJECT. HOW MUCH IF
YOU PURCHASE ALL THE LAND AND
ALL THE ROADS ALREADY. TO
COMPLETE THIS PROJECT TO GET
THIS PROJECT GOING OR IS THERE
ANY OUTSTANDING PROPERTY THAT
YOU NEED THAT YOU HAVEN'T
PURCHASED. AND IT'LL HOW YEAH.
YEAH THERE THERE IS OUTSTANDING
PROPERTY BECAUSE- NINE NINETY
MILE SEGMENT- WE NEED A TOTAL
OF ABOUT TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
PARCELS- TO COMPLETE THAT
CONSTRUCTION WORK WE HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED- IN POSSESSION
OUR WORKING THROUGH. THE REST
SO THAT'S ABOUT 70% OF THE
HUNDRED NINETY MILE STRETCH.
AND THEN BEYOND THAT TO EXTEND
THE INTO BAKERSFIELD MERCED. A
WE ARE JUST FINISHING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK ON THAT NOW
AND SO OUR NEXT STEP. YOU REACH
THE DESIGN. OF THAT OF SEX SO
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY A MAP. OF
THE RIGHT AWAY THAT WE NEED AT
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT LESSON
LEARNED. UP PROJECT- THAT I
WANNA CORPORATIONS I'VE BEEN
HERE IS- YOU KNOW BUT-
UNDERSTANDABLE REASON THEY GOT
IN BECAUSE- PRETTY EARLY. ON
THE EARLY PART OF THE PROJECT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THEY WERE
UNDER A FEDERAL DEADLINE TO
SPEND FEDERAL MONEY. AND SO THE
AUTHORITY I GOT A CONSTRUCTION
BEFORE HAVING ALL THE RGHT
AWAY AND- WE DON'T INTEND TO
REPEAT THAT- AS WE GET THROUGH
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN. AND
LOOKED TO EXTEND TO THE ONE
SEVENTY ONE. A ONCE WE COMPLETE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK WE'RE
LOOKING TO. THE EXTENT DESIGN-
MAP THE RIGHT AWAY PARCELS-
IDENTIFIED UTILITIES THAT NEED
TO BE REAL OKAY. AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS WOULD BE WOULD
BE COMPLETE BUT BEFORE WE GOT
INTO. A CONCERT NEW
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS. MR FALL.
ALL RIGHT. HEAR ME NOW ALL
RIGHT. CERTAINLY MISTER KELLY
AYE AYE I APPRECIATE YOU
TESTIFYING- YOU KNOW AND- AND I
APPRECIATE YOU MEETING WITH ME
ON ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS I
CERTAINLY HAS SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS PROJECT- AND ITEMS
AND IT'S NO SECRET THAT I'M NOT
A FAN OF HOW THIS PROJECT HAS
PROCEEDED- IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE TO MY COLLEAGUES- THAT.
THIS PROJECT. HAS NOT BEEN
AFFECTED IN THE BUDGET. THAT
WHILE WERE IN A VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET. SIT AT A VERY BUDGET
DIFFICULT BUDGET SITUATION. AND
WE'RE ASKING CALIFORNIANS TO
MAKE SACRIFICES THIS PROJECT
REMAINS UNAFFECTED. AND I WANT
TO FOR. I GUESS FOCUS MY
QUESTIONS- AND I AM GLAD THAT-
IT WAS MENTIONED THE PHRASE
LIVE WITHIN OUR MEANS. AND I
WANT TO USE THAT FRAMEWORK IN
TERMS OF HOW- HOW WE DIVE INTO
THIS PROJECT AND HOW WE
EVALUATE CAUGHT. SO CURRENTLY-
THE PROJECT AS YOU'VE OUTLINED
IS GOING FROM MERCED TO SHARE
AFTER WITH THE HOPE OF GOING TO
BAKERSFIELD SO IS IT YOUR
ATTENTION MISTER KELLY TO STILL
EXPAND THIS PROJECT TO THE BAY
AREA AND LOS ANGELES. YES AND
THEN HOW MUCH WOULD IT COST TO
EXTEND TO THE BAY AREA. I THINK
THE INCREMENTAL COST TO GET TO
THE BAY AREA FROM- MERCED-
PURELY ON- HIGH SPEED RAIL
ASSETS THROUGH THE PROJECT GOES
INTO SAN JOSE IN DECEMBER JUST
GOES ESTIMATED AROUND.
SEVENTEEN OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO DO THAT. SO
SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
GET TO- TO THE BAY AREA AND HOW
MUCH WOULD IT COST TO EXTEND A
TO LOS ANGELES. THAT'S THE
BAKERSFIELD THE PALM DALES
ABOUT SIXTEEN POINT THREE-
PALMDALE TO BURBANK IS ABOUT.
SEVENTEEN TO THAT'S TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SIX ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY. ED YOU KNOW I'D
CERTAINLY ONE DOT THE HIGHLIGHT
WHAT THE WOULD- THE CHAIR IS
LEGIT OR NOT SORRY I MISSPOKE
FORGIVE ME- I SAID TWENTY EIGHT
I SHOULD IS AT THIRTY EIGHT
THIRTY. SO THIRTY EIGHT BILLION
TO GET TO LOS ANGELES AND
SEVENTEEN BILLION TO GET TO THE
TO THE TO THE BAY AREA
BACKTRACKED. ROUGH YES ROUGHLY
YEAH AND YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN
THIS IS OUR FONG IF I COULD I
THE ONLY I WANT TO BE CAREFUL
ABOUT HERE'S BECAUSE YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE MISTAKES OF
THE PAST I SAID BEFORE. THAT
YOU KNOW WE USE RANGES BOTH OF
THESE STRETCHES YOUR
IDENTIFYING ARE IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAYS. AS WE WORK
THROUGH. IS THE GOOD POINT.
WHAT THOSE BECAUSE ARE BUT
AGAIN THAT'S OUR- ESTIMATES
TODAY AND- AND SO I JUST WOULD
SAY THAT THE- WORST WERE EARLY
IN THAT PROJECT SO I PROCESS SO
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE. THE USE
OF RANGES AND IF I EVEN IF
WE'RE UTILIZING THE AGES THAT
WAS PROVIDED- THAT THE CHAIR S.
AS STATED. THIS PROJECT HAS
GROWN IN HOT SHRUNKEN SCOPE AND
IF I'M LOOKING CORRECTLY THE
LOW RANGE OF THIS PROJECT IS
SIXTY THREE BILLION. THE HIGH
RANGE OF THIS PROJECT IS A
NINETY EIGHT BILLION AND YOU
HAVE A BASE ESTIMATE OF EIGHTY
BILLION. CORRECT. YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN CORRECT SO WHAT IS THE SO
THE TOTAL AMOUNT TO COME TO
COMPLETE THE LA TO THE ENTIRE
LA TO SAN FRANCISCO SEGMENT. IS
YOU'RE ESTIMATING THE LOW RANGE
OF SIXTY THREE BILLION AND A
HIGH RANGE OF NINETY EIGHT
BILLION. CORRECT AND BUT IT
COULD GO HIGHER. WILL GO WELL
IT I MEAN. YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WE DID IS. WE'VE UP YOU KNOW
INVESTMENT WHAT THE UNIT PRICES
ARE FOR THAT WORK TO GET THAT
WORK DONE IT KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
WE'RE STILL IN THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS EARLY IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAYS THOSE
SEGMENTS ARE ABOUT 15% DESIGN-
NOW THERE'S A LOT. MORE TO DO
THERE YEAH WE'VE ESTIMATED
RANGES AT THE ENTIRETY OF PHASE
ONE IS SIXTY THREE TO NINETY
EIGHT WHAT WE DID IS WE USE
THOSE MEASUREMENTS AND THEN WE
APPLIED THE BEST INDUSTRY
PRACTICES WITH THE I THINK I'M
GONNA HAVE A MEMBER HERE. BUT I
WANT TO SAY IT'S SORT OF A
THIRTY GOING UP IN 20% TWIN
DOWN. FROM THOSE OF THOSE BUT
THOSE. RISE AND THAT. UP APPLY
RAIN AND SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
WE GET WE'VE DONE ARTS SO THEN
WHAT WOULD BE ESTIMATED TIME
LINE BE TO COMPLETE I KNOW
YOU'RE FOCUSED ON- PHASE ONE
BUT FROM THE WHOLE MADE WHAT IS
ENVISIONED IN PROP ONE A WHAT
WOULD BE AND GET TO SEE A TIME
BUT YEAH IT IT'S GOING TO BE
ENTIRE TIED TO THE- FUND. AND
SO WHEN FOR TALK ABOUT THE- A
PROGRAM SCOPE SHRINKING- IN MY
VIEW IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
SPRING A SHRINKING BUT IT'S HOW
WE DO THE BUILDING BLOCK
APPROACH. AND THAT IS OF LIKE
IN ANY OTHER TRANSIT PROJECT.
THAT IS DETERMINED BY THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUNDS- SO WHY
DO WE PICKED BAKERSFIELD TO
PERCENT- WE PICK BAKERSFIELD
MERCED BECAUSE- THAT THAT'S AN
APPROPRIATE EXTENSION FROM
HUNDRED NINETEEN. THAT WE THINK
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH WITH OUR
ESTIMATE AVAILABLE REVENUES.
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY THIRTY.
IN SO AS MORE MONEY BECAME
AVAILABLE WITH MORE FEDERAL
MONEY FOR EXAMPLE. OF GAME
AVAILABLE WE- ROB LOOK. FOR
EITHER TOWARDS ANODE OR A
TOWARD- POPULAR IN THE SOUTH SO
WITH YOU KNOW AGAIN. UP IT'S
ALL FUNDING DEPENDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTIMATING COSTS-
WE ESTIMATE A TWENTY THIRTY
THREE A TIMELINE FOR ALL OF
PHASE ONE. I THINK A TWENTY
THIRTY ONE TIMELINE FOR THE
VALUE BALLOT WHICH IS. SILICON
VALLEY INTO THE BAY AREA THE
SUIT YOU HAVE ESTIMATED
TIMELINE OF TWENTY THIRTY ONE.
FOR TO FOR HEARINGS AND THERE.
TO THE BAY. OUT SO THE FRONT
FROM THAT THE CENTER OF A LEAD
PORTION TO THE BAY AREA. TWENTY
THIRTY YES OKAY YEAH. ONE OF
THE- RIGHT SO TO FOCUS ON THE
CENTER PORSCHE IT IS MINE THAT
THE FEDERAL HAS ASKED FOR THE
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS BACK FROM FROM
THE FROM FROM A ARE A CORRECT.
YEAH IT'S ACTUALLY NOT A NOT A
SPECIFICALLY ARE TECHNICALLY
FROM OUR IT WAS A LATER FISCAL
YEAR APPROPRIATION THEY ALL GOT
THE ALL ABOUT THAT YEAH WE ARE
WE HAVE SPENT AND THE FISCAL
YEAR APPROPRIATION THE- TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING. WE
GIVE BACK. SO OF V. SO IN THE
PROGRESS ON THE MERCED TO
SHAFTER HOPEFULLY GETTING TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT WHAT IS THE
ESTIMATED PERCENTAGE OF WHAT IS
CURRENTLY BEEN. COMPLETED AND
HOW MUCH DID THAT COST. HEY
WHAT'S LEFT TO DO. CAN YOU I'M
SORRY CAN YOU AS A SERVICE SO
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION
HOW MUCH HAS BEEN COMPLETED TO
THIS POINT TO THIS POINT. I
WANT TO SAY APPROXIMATELY 40%
OR SO OF THAT HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILE. STRETCH IS. A COMPLETE
WE'VE SPENT A TOTAL OF ABOUT-
OF FIVE POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
THAT IN THAT AREA SO YOU SO
YES. APOLOGIZE SO YOU'VE SPENT
FIVE POINT SEVEN BILLION EARLY.
OF A PORTION AB OF IN THE
CENTER VALLEY IN THE YOU'VE
ESTIMATED THAT- THAT RANGE FOR
THE MERCEDES TO BIGELOW SEGMENT
IS TWENTY. FOUR BILLION TO
TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR BUT-
YEAH THE TALKS THE TOTALITY OF
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
STRETCH. WILL BE ABOUT A TWELVE
POINT FOUR BILLION. CAPITAL
COST. OF FOR THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE STRETCH. AND THEN
THAT. YOU WE ADD TO THAT ABOUT-
FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION MORE.
OF GET BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED.
STILL THERE THERE'S FIFTY THIS
IN BILLION DOLLAR LEFT THAT TO
BE. SPEND IT. TO COMPLETE P.
WERE SAID TO BAKER SEGMENT OKAY
AND THEN WHAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
COST OF THE OF THIS SEGMENT. I
DON'T THINK THERE WASN'T A
RESERVE ORIGINAL- SEGMENT FOR
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD- THE
INITIAL SEGMENT- UNDER
CONSTRUCTION WAS OF THE HUNDRED
NINETEEN I THINK ORIGINALLY
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN A- WELL
BEFORE. THEY GOT DONE WITH ALL%
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK I
THINK THERE WAS A SIX BILLION
DOLLAR COST ESTIMATE ROUGHLY TO
GET THE ONE NINETEEN DONE THAT
THAT ESTIMATES NOW TWELVE POINT
FOUR. SO THEN I LOOK I GET THIS
QUESTION ALL THE TIME FROM FROM
MY CONSTITUENTS AND
CALIFORNIANS- YOU KNOW
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. WHICH IS
THAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
EVERY COST ESTIMATE HAS BEEN
SEVERELY OFF TIME LINES HAVE
ALSO BEEN SEVERELY OFF. IN THE
PAST HAS SHOWN US. THAT THE
BUSINESS PLAN ESTIMATES HAVE
BEEN INACCURATE SO WHY IS THIS
PLAN ANY DIFFERENT. THAN WHAT
WE SEE AN INCREASE YEARS
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING. THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT.
HAS EXTENT TODAY. THAT
ASSUMING. YOU KNOW POTENTIAL
FEDERAL FUNDS BEING CALLED
BACK. ASSUMING THE LEGISLATURE
IS MEET WITHOUT ASSUMING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS FACING A
MASSIVE MASSIVE BUDGET DEFICIT.
WE ARE THOSE INCORPORATED INTO
THIS BUSINESS PLAN. YEAH I MEAN
WE HAVE IT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
YOU KNOW RISKS THERE ARE
FUNDING RESEARCH THERE ARE
INCLUDED IN THAT FUNDING RISK
IS THE CALL BACK AT THE FEDERAL
FUNDS- OF FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION I MEAN OUR VIEW
WAS THERE'S NO BASIS- TO CALL
THOSE DOLLARS BACK LITIGATION
ON THAT IN THAT LITTLE ASIAN.
OF PROBABLY GO THROUGH MUCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- TOLD EMILY-
UP THE SIDE I FUNDAMENTALLY THE
DISKETTE THE DECISION A CALLING
BACK ANY MONEY FROM THIS
PROJECT IS GOING TO BE. OTHER
THE PROJECT IS BEING
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS AND- AND
WE ARE IN SO. AND I AM EX. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO- AND SO WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THAT.
AND YOU KNOW THE COURTS WILL
ULTIMATELY DECIDE. WHETHER NOT
THERE'S A BASIS TO CALL BACK
THOSE DOLLARS ARE NOT WHAT'S
DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS. FUNDING
PLAN AND LOOK AT YOU AND I'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS BEFORE BOTH.
IN SETTINGS LIKE THIS AND IN
MORE PRIVATE. THE CONVERSATIONS.
YOU KNOW I THINK I'VE SAID TO
YOU FROM DAY ONE SINCE I. GOT
HERE THE REASON I MOVED- TO
RANGES TO ESTIMATE THE COST OF.
BUILDING A PROJECT LIKE THIS IS
IT IS A MASSIVE PROJECT. WITH
GREAT COMPLEXITY. AND THE
REALITY IS IT'S EARLY IN. A IN
MANY PLACES IT'S EARLY IN THE
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT PROCESSAND
IT'S INAPPROPRIATE. TO TRY TO
GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC DOLLAR
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT'S GOING TO
COST WHEN WE ARE STILL WORKING
THROUGH. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS AND THAT'S WHY WE APPLY
RANGES. OF STARTING IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PLAN. CONTINUE
THROUGH THE TWENTY NINETEEN
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT- AND IN
THIS TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN. I UNDERSTAND THAT PASSED-
BUSINESS PLANS IT BOUNCED
AROUND I THINK IT WAS. BUT NOT
WISE TO EVER GET TO A TRYING TO
FIGHT IT TRYING TO IDENTIFY A
SPECIFIC. ACOSTA THIS EARLY- IN
THE PROGRAM- AND SO THEN THE
OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS I
THINK WE'VE ACHIEVED GREAT
CONSISTENCY. BUT NOT ROLLER
COASTER RIDE BUT CONSISTENCY.
OF BETWEEN WHAT WE SAID IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN
WHAT WE SAID THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PROJECT UPDATE REPORT.
AND WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING THE
STRAP BUSINESS PLAN. WE STARTED
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN BY SAYING WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE FUNDING WE NEED. TO DO
EVERYTHING THE AUTHORITY SAID
IT. HAD TO DO. AND SO WE HAVE
TO TAKE ON A BETTER. MORE ROAD
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH AND
THAT'S WHAT WE- STARTED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WE STUDIED IT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. WE BROUGHT
AFFORD IN THIS TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN. AND WE ARE
LARGELY OPERATING THE RANGES
THAT WE FIRST INTRODUCED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS. SO I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE ROLE
THAT YOU'RE IN I THE ROLE THAT
WE ARE IN AND YOU KNOW BECAUSE
YOU'VE YOU'VE YOU'VE WORKED IT
LET'S JUST. IS THAT ASKING IN
THIS BUDGET FORD TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AND THEN OF
COURSE WE'RE DEALING WITH A
PROJECT FOR WHEN IT'S FULL
SCOPE. WITH HOPE THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE WITHIN THE RANGE OF
SIXTY THREE TO NINETY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AT A TIME THAT
WE ARE IN MASSIVE ECONOMIC-
ECONOMIC- YOU NOTE THAT
STRAIGHT THIS. IS A STRAIGHT
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT A LARGE BY
THE SAID AND ON TOP OF THAT
YOU'RE ASKING A YOU YOU ARE. OF
AS THE AS THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY ARE LOOKING TO SIGN
CONTRACTS. A LOT IN A THIRD
YEAR COMMITMENT. SO WHAT ARE
THE POTENTIAL RISKS. BEING
TAKEN BY THE STATE IF THE
HIGHEST AUTHORITY MOVES FORWARD
WITH SIGNING CONTRACTS THIS FOR
ALL I WILL PROVIDE A THIRTY
YEAR COMMITMENT AT A TIME WHERE
YOU WILL BE MET. THERE THE
MONEY THEN THEIR. WELL YOU SAY
IT THIRTY YEAR COMMITMENT JUST
WHERE WERE. ALL CLEAR WE ARE.
WE ARE REQUIRED UNDER ARE FED.
OF FUNDING GREEN TO GET THE
TRACK STOLE THE ON THE ON THE
PROJECT. AND SO WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING WHAT WE HAVE PROPOSES
TO MOVE FOR. WITH THAT
PROCUREMENT PROCESS A WEEKEND-
MAXIMIZE OUR- ABILITY TO MEET
THE FEDERAL DEADLINE. OF
GETTING THAT TRACK AND STOLE.
THE SO CALLED THIRTY YOU'RE A
COMMITMENT IS TIED TO A MAIN
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE THESE
ASSETS THAT WE BUILT ARE GONNA
LAST FOR GENERATIONS- AND WE'RE
REQUIRED EVEN UNDER OUR FEDERAL
AGREEMENT TO HAVE AT LEAST A
TWENTY YEAR MAINTENANCE PLAN.
OF FOR THOSE- FOR THOSE ASSETS
AND SO WE HAVE PROPOSED IN ARE.
A CONTRACTOR RATHER FAMILIAR
DESIGN- BILL MAINTAIN. A
CONTRACT STRUCTURE WHERE THE
BITTER A WILL ALSO PROVIDE A
COST TO MAINTAIN- THE TRACK.
AND THAT TRACK ONCE BUILT IN
ONE TO LATE WILL BE THERE- FOR
GENERATIONS. AND WHAT THIRTY
YEAR MADE IT IS NOT
UNREASONABLE. FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO LAST PROBABLY A
HUNDRED YEARS. IT SO. THAT IT
RIGHTS IS STRUCTURED THAT WAY I
WOULD ALL OVER THE TAKING MY
JUSTICE. OF THE CAR. IS THE
SEPARATE. NOTICES TO BE FIVE
PRINT INTO THESE THAT CAN ONLY
BE AND ON. WHAT ONCE WORK IS
READY TO EXTEND THAT TO AND
ONCE FUNDING IS IDENTIFIED THE
FOR THAT ATTRACTED THE FUND- IN
TERMS OF THE TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION THAT'S IN THE BUDGET
AGAIN. THESE ARE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED A CAP AND TRADE
DOLLARS A WE'VE ALREADY WE
ALREADY HAVE FOR THE MOST PART
OR ARE ESTIMATED. TO COME IN IN
THE FISCAL YEAR. THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW COME TO THIS
PROJECT TO DEVELOP- WHAT IS ONE
OF THE CLEANEST INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS- IN THE COUNTRY- AND
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
ANYTHING. MORE THAN THAT AT
THIS TIME I THINK I. EVEN IT
SAID YOU IN A PRIOR. A
CONVERSATION. DON'T TELL I GO
UNDER STRING OF GREAT BETTER
AND IMPROVE PERFORMANCE. I
DON'T WANT TO ASK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL-
PREPARATION OF BOND FUNDS AND
THEN THAT'S IN PART WHAT WE PUT
IT OFF. UNTIL NEXT YEAR A
BECAUSE OF I DO THINK WE ARE
TURNING THIS IN THE BETTER
DIRECTION- MORE ADVANCED
DIRECTION. AND I THINK AS WE
CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE WILL HAVE A
BETTER CONVERSATION. ABOUT THE
NEED TO ULTIMATELY GET BOND
DOLLARS APPROPRIATED BUT AGAIN
IN THIS BUDGET. IT'S CONTINUED
ARE SORRY I CONTINUES
PERFORATED FUNDS- THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE. OF OR THAT ARE
EXPECTED MINUTES FISCAL YEAR.
I'M WHY A BILL EVERY YOUR
CANDOR IS AYE AYES WANT TO SAY-
MISTER CHAIR. NO ONE WE ARE
ASKING CALIFORNIANS LIVE WITHIN
OUR MEANS THE- THIS PROJECT
DOESN'T LIVE WITHIN THEIR MEANS
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
MEANS ARE. THIS PROJECT KEEPS
CHANGING THE RANGES KEEP
CHANGING- HIGH SPEED RAIL IS.
SIGNING IT LONG TERM CONTRACTS
WERE LOOKING A RISING COSTS ARE
PUTTING TAXPAYERS AT RISK AND
WE NEED TO SERIOUSLY RE
EVALUATE THIS PROJECT
ESPECIALLY WHEN THIS STATE IS
ASKING CALIFORNIANS TO
SACRIFICE AND I WILL JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT ON PAGE ONE
HUNDRED OF THE BUSINESS PLAN IT
SPECIFICALLY STATES QUOTE IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT A
FINANCIALLY UNCONSTRAINED
SCHEDULE IS NOT REALISTIC GIVEN
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE FULL
FUNDING TO COMPLETE. THIS
PROGRAM THE ONLY THAT THE BUT
THE BUSINESS PLAN THAT DOES
THAT HAS BEEN RELEASED
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT THIS
PROJECT IS UNCONSTRAINED IN SO
WAY AS WE DEBATE THE BUDGET AS
WE'RE ASKING TO MAKE A VERY
TOUGH DECISIONS I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT THIS
PROJECT. HAS NOT LIVED UP TO
ITS EXPECTATIONS IN FACT THE
ONLY PREDICTOR OF FUTURE
BEHAVIOR FOR THIS PROJECT IN MY
PERSONAL OPINION IS PAST
BEHAVIOR. IS A WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS PROJECT WITH OUR EYES
WIDE OPEN AND IF WE'RE GONNA
ASK. SCHOOLS TO GET FUNDING
REDUCTIONS IF WE'RE GONNA ASK
HEALTH CARE- PROGRAMS TO GET
CUT IF WE'RE SHIFTING A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AT
THE STATE HIGHWAY FUND. AND AT
THE SAME TIME TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IS SITTING IN A
AN ACCOUNT FOR THIS PROJECT AND
THIS PROJECT WILL NOT. SEE ANY
REEVALUATION IN MY OPINION
THAT'S NOT RIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. L. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY AND SECRETARY FOR
BEING HERE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION YOU KNOW WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE TOGETHER I THINK
IT WAS TWO MONTHS AGO RIGHT
BEFORE WE WENT ON RECESS SO
MUCH HAS CHANGED. IN THOSE
SHORT TWO MONTHS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS BEING THE FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT THAT WE
CONVENE TO DISCUSS JUST.
YESTERDAY AND I THINK THAT IT.
RINGS THE STARK REALITY OF THE
FINANCIAL. SITUATION OF THIS
PROJECT TO THE FOREFRONT TO
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE VICE
CHAIR WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
CUTS THAT WE ARE FACING. TO
SIRIUS PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
DEPENDS ON EDUCATION HEALTHCARE
SENIOR SERVICES FOOD NEEDS OF
THE CALIFORNIANS THAT WE ARE
HAVING A CONVERSATION ABOUT
GIVING ANOTHER TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO THIS PROJECT
FEELS LIKE. SOMETHING THAT IS
HARD FOR ME TO STOMACH TO PUT
IT NICELY SO. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION- I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND I REVIEWED YOUR
BUSINESS PLAN. AND I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT SO FIRST
ABOUT RIDERSHIP SO. THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PLAN. ANTICIPATED I'M
GOING ALL THE WAY TO THE AREA
CONNECTING YOU TO SAN JOSE AND
IN NOT PLAN YOU HAD AN
ESTIMATED FOUR MILLION WRITERS
IN THIS PLAN YOU'VE NOW
SHORTENED THE CORRIDOR TO
BAKERSFIELD MERCED AND YET THE
RIDERSHIP. IS IDENTICAL. CAN
YOU EXPLAIN HOW THEY WILL BE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF WRITERS ON
THE TRAIN. WHAT IT DOES NOT
CONNECT INTO THE BAY AREA. I'M
NOT LOOKING AT THE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT. THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
YOU'RE REFERENCING FOR VALUE TO
VALLEY- BACK IN TWENTY I THINK
YOU SAID EIGHTEEN OR SOMETHING-
BUT THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS. FOR
THE VALUE VALLEY SERVICE THE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS OF ARE NOT
FOR MILLION THEY ARE WELL
ARGUMENTS ABOUT SORRY FORTY
MILLION I MISS THAT FORTY.
FORTY MILLION IS THE PHASE ONE.
OF SAN FRANCISCO TO ANAHEIM
ESTIMATE OF TOTAL RIDERSHIP. OF
DOUBT ABOUT A BY ITSELF- A
GROSS BETWEEN TWENTY OF THIRTY
THREE AND TWENTY FORTY. BETWEEN
FORTY MILLION EIGHTEEN. A
MILLION OF PHASE ONE GROWS FROM
A TO- TWELVE TO TWENTY THE
COMBINED AND THEN GET YOU TO
ABOUT FORTY MILLION WRITERS. SO
THE FORTY MILLION RIDER
ESTIMATE IS PHASE ONE SAN
FRANCISCO TO LA AND I. CHECK
THE RIDERSHIP THAT WE HAVE- FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT. OF
TODAY IF WE DO NOTHING THAT
RIDERSHIP IS ABOUT A THREE AND
A HALF BILLION RIDERS A DAY IF
WE JUST. LEAVE THE SYSTEM AS IT
IS- UNDER OUR PROPOSAL- WE'RE
PROPOSING TO INCREASE A WRITER
THREE RIDERSHIP CENTRAL VALLEY
SERVICES- TO ABOUT EIGHT POINT
EIGHT. SO OUR OUR INCREASE. A
NET. GAIN OF ABOUT FOUR POINT
EIGHT- BUT- WE GO FROM ABOUT
THREE POINT SIX. BUT TO ABOUT
EIGHT POINT- OVERSIGHT THREE
POINT NINE TO EIGHT POINT
SEVEN. PERCENT ABOUT A
RIDERSHIP THE RIDERSHIP ABOUT A
VALLEY IS ABOUT EIGHTEEN
RIDERSHIP STATEWIDE GOES TO
ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT OKAY THANK
YOU SEVEN. NOW WOULD YOU
ESTIMATE THOSE NUMBERS EIGHT
POINT EIGHT MILLION- HOW MANY
OF THOSE. ARE JUST RIDING THE
HIGH SPEED LINE ARE YOU ADDING
PEOPLE WHO RIDE IN THE
CONNECTING SERVICES- ALL YES
TWENTY WRITING ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL. YEAH BECAUSE WHAT WE WHAT
WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA. STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND THOSE
OF WILL PUT TOGETHER THE STATE
RAIL PLAN- IS TO OF IMPROVE THE
ENTIRE CORRIDOR OF RAIL
SERVICES- IN THAT SECTION SO
WHAT ARE. ELECTRIFIED THE
ELECTRIFIED GEN FOR WHICH
SERVICE WOULD BE PROVIDED IS
FROM MERCED THE BAKERSFIELD. IT
DOES THAT INCLUDE CONNECTIVITY
POINTS FOR WHICH THE STATE HAS
ALREADY MADE MONEY AVAILABLE A
TO CONNECT WITH WERE SAID- IN
MERCED WITH THE SAN JOAQUIN
SYSTEM. THE H. SYSTEM AND POP.
IN SORIDERSHIP ALONE ON THE
MERCED THE BAKERSFIELD
STRETCHES. AT ABOUT A TWO
MILLION. BUT OF. THE RIGHT IN
THAT ENTIRE. CORRIDOR
IMPROVEMENT GET UP TO A POINT A
WOULD YOU INCLUDED AT THE
BENEFITS OF. OF THE CAPTIVITY
WITH ALL SO IT'S A- AND WHAT.
AND THE. RIGHT NOW IT. IF WE DO
NOTHING WE DON'T INCLUDE THE
SPEED RAIL. THAT WRITER SHE- IS
ESTIMATED AT ABOUT THREE POINT
NINE AND THEN WE WOULD LOOK TO
BUMP THAT TO A POINT. RIGHT SO
AS I UNDERSTAND IT FOR THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR PIECE OF
RAIL THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
BUILDING IN PHASE ONE. THAT'S
TWO MILLION WRITERS. SO AND THE
CONNECTIVITY POINTS ADD SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION SO AS I
HEAR THAT I WOULD THINK THAT
THE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE THING
TO DO WOULD BE TO BUILD THE
PORTIONS THAT HAVE HIGHER
RIDERSHIP WHICH ARE NOT THE
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR SEGMENT
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE TODAY BUT
THE CONNECTORS. OUT OF IT WHICH
I IMAGINE NOT BEING HIGH SPEED
RAIL WOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS EXPENSIVE. WELL THERE'S A
THERE'S A FEW THINGS HERE IF
YOU WANT TO SEE IMPROVE
RIDERSHIP ON. RAIL IN IN THIS
AT THIS IN THAT. A CENTRAL
VALLEY- THE ELEMENT OF BRINGING
IN HIGH SPEED RAIL- REDUCING
THOSE TRAVEL TIMES BY. A NINETY
MINUTES- IN THAT AREA- AND
HAVING THE SIMPLER CONNECTING
POINTS WITH ACE- AND THE- SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICES WERE SET. IT
ALL WORKS TOGETHER TO IMPROVE
THE RIDERSHIP THROUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF THAT CORRIDOR IT'S
NOT ONE THING BY ITSELF IT'S
THE COMBINED WORK THE OTHER
THING I WOULD JUST. NOTE IS
THAT YOU DON'T WE- WE HAVE TO
COMPLETE WORK ON OUR FEDERAL
GRANT AGREEMENT NOW FOR THE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE STRETCH.
BETWEEN POPULAR ADD MADERA IN
SO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS TO
EXTEND- USE ABOUT FOUR POINT
EIGHT. BILLION MORE TO EXTEND
THE WORK. TO GET THE BILL IN
THE SOUTH URBAN- AREA AND THE
DOWNTOWN MERCED IN THE NORTH
AND SO INCOME AND- IS NOT. A
THE TWENTY POINT FOR ITS JUST A
IS THE FOUR POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. INCREASE THE OTHER
THING I JUST THAT IS FOR THOSE
CONNECTION POINTS. IN MERCED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
THROUGH OTHER ADULT. THE YEAH
DISTRIBUTORS IN OTHER. IS
ALREADY GIVE. ABOUT A BILL
DOLLAR FOR X. OF THE- A SYSTEM
INTO A PERCENT. WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO IS- HAVE THAT
MEET HIGH SPEED RAIL BUT THEY
ARE WITH A- FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT. SO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT SO AS YOU
MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW I REPRESENT
THE TRI VALLEY INCLUDING
LIVERMORE RACE RUNS CURRENTLY.
AN ACE RUNS FOUR TIMES IN THE
MORNING AND FOUR TIMES THE
EVENING BECAUSE OF RIGHT AWAY
AS ON THE RAIL TRACK. I DON'T
ANTICIPATE THAT BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASED RIDERSHIP
THAT YOU ARE ANTICIPATING HERE
SO IS THERE WHAT KIND OF
IMPROVEMENT IS GONNA HAPPEN TO
THE A SYSTEM TO ALLOW FOR THAT
INCREASED DEMAND THAT YOU'RE
PREDICTING. WELL THE FIRST IS.
THEY'RE GONNA EXTENDED PERCENT-
WHICH THEY THEY DON'T TODAY-
THERE ARE- DETERMINATION POINT
ON THE EAST IS IN THE STOCKTON-
THE AREA SO THE FIRST EXTENSION
IS DOWN TO SERIES AND THEN A
FURTHER DOWN INTO- MERCED- AND
THEN- BETWEEN THAT AND- UP BUS
SERVICES- ACES PROPOSING
WORKING SEPARATELY REALLY FROM
FROM US- IS ALSO PROPOSING TO-
EXTENT- ITS OWN OPERATING
SERVICE THE NORTH TO. A
SACRAMENTO- BY THE END OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY SO THEY'VE GOT A
BROADER WHAT THEY CALL I THINK
IT'S CALLED THE VISION VALLEY
VISION PLAN ABOUT LIKE FORWARD-
PLAN WHICH IS- IN INVESTMENT IN
BOTH THE SAN JOAQUIN'S- AND THE
AGE SERVICES TO EXPAND- WRITER-
EXPAND SERVICES A GOING NORTH
INTO SACRAMENTO AND WEST INTO
THE OPEN OF COURSE THE BIG
RACES THE EXTENSION ALL THE WAY
DOWN 2% BUT EXPAND. IS SORRY
GOING DIRECTLY STATE OF THE
OTHER THING IS THE- THERE IS
WORK- GOING ON TO HAVE THE A
SYSTEM OF ALSO- EXTEND ITS-
IT'S- STATION LOCATION AND WERE
SAID TO ME THE SAN JOAQUIN IN
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM AND
A SINGLE A SINGLE STATION SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT- ARE PART OF A THE
PROGRAM. SO AS THOSE OF US THAT
LIVE AS A FORMER BURKE COMMUTER
AND SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS
MUCH OF THE PART AND COMMUNITY
EXTENDING BART OUT HAS BEEN A
POSITIVE THING SESSION
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT BUT IT
SURELY DOES NOT INCREASE
CAPACITY IN FACT IT DOES JUST
THE OPPOSITE SO WHAT I'M ASKING
IS THAT THERE IS CURRENTLY IN
SUFFICIENT PASS YUNIS AROUND
FOUR TIMES THE MORNING FOUR
TIMES THE EVENING MAKING GO
FURTHER DOESN'T INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF WRITER THE ABILITY OF
A WRITER'S ON THAT TRAIN IN
FACT IT JUST MAKES IT MORE
IMPACTED. SO MY QUESTION IS HOW
YOU CAN IMPROVE BASE TO MEET
THE DEMAND THAT YOU'RE SAYING
IT CAN. HOLD WANTED TO SEND IT
OUT I BELIEVE THEIR INTENTION
IS TO EXTEND THEIR FOR YOU. AS
ALTHOUGH. I DON'T HAVE BEEN FOR
OF ME X. OF WHAT THAT IS IT IS
YOUR RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST THE-
PHYSICAL EXTENSION BUT IT'S
ALSO THE- FREQUENCY EXTENSION
OF THOSE- THOSE SERVICES. AND
THAT'S PART OF AN EFFORT THAT
THEY ARE WORKING- BUT THE- THE
CAL STATE SO LEAD ON. A RAIL
CHAD EDISON IS OF THE AUTHOR OF
THE STATE RAIL PLAN- A AND-
AGAIN WITH THE DOLLARS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN. I GIVEN SO
THERE'S BOTH A FREAK FREQUENCY
EXPANSION. OF A AND A AND AS I
SAID THERE. PROGRAM IS TO GO
NOT JUST TO. NOT JUST BACK TO
THE BAY AREA BUT THEY ALSO. THE
LINE EXACTLY. SO THAT WE DO TO
DESTINY POINTS NORTH SAID WORSE
TODAY ACES JUST OFFER A SERVICE
TO WHAT. SO I MEAN I THINK BACK
TO THE VICE CHAIRS POINT
EARLIER WE NEED ANSWERS RIGHT
FOR BUILDING TRAIN ASSUMING WE
CAN CONNECT INTO THE VERY USING
A CITIES CURRENTLY RUNS AT SUCH
LIMITED CAPACITY. WE CAN'T
ASSUME ANSWERS WE NEED TO HAVE
A PLAN THAT ACTUALLY LEADS TO
CONNECTIVE ITTY AND I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR
IN THAT I AM A HUGE BELIEVER IN
BRAILLE PROJECTS AND CLEAN RAIL
PROJECTS- I AM A HUGE ADVOCATE
FOR VALUING WHICH I THINK IS A
WONDERFUL CLEAN REAL PROJECT.
AND TO THAT POINT I THINK USE
THE SECRETARY SPOKE ELOQUENTLY
ABOUT. NOT WANTING THOSE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO BE
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED AND
WANTING THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT COME WITH. EXPANDING
TRANSPORTATION TO COME TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BUT I THINK
MANY OF US IN THIS BODY
UNDERSTAND THAT PART OF THAT
GEOGRAPHIC ISOLATION MEANS
CONNECTING THEM IN. THE LARGER
URBAN CENTERS WHERE THERE ARE
SO MANY JOBS. AND THIS CURRENT
PHASE DOESN'T DO THAT IN
ANTICIPATING THAT WE WILL COME
UP WITH A PLAN FOR A IS TO BE
ABLE TO HANDLE THAT IS
INSUFFICIENT I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE A PLAN. AND ONE THAT IS
MEANINGFUL AND THAT MEANS THAT
THESE BOOKENDS. THAT ACTUALLY
MEANINGFULLY CONNECTS. TO THE-
URBAN CENTERS WHERE THE JOBS
ARE THE WILL BRING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO PLACES LIKE
STOCKTON AND THIS IN NORTHERN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY NEAR LOS ANGELES. HAVE
TO BE A PRIORITY AND NOT THE
WELL WE'LL DO THIS IF WE GET
THE MONEY DOWN THE LINE.
BECAUSE LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU PRESENTED TO THE VICE
CHAIR OF SEVENTEEN BILLION AND
THIRTY EIGHT BILLION TO CONNECT
TO LOS ANGELES AND- THE BAY
AREA I THINK GIVEN THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC TIMES IN THE FORECAST
IS NOT. REALISTIC ANY TIME. IN
THE FUTURE THAT I CAN SEE SO.
BUT I HAVE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
I'M THE TICKET PRICE IT ISN'T
MENTIONED IN THE BUSINESS PLAN.
RIGHT UP. YEAH WE HAVE TO AS WE
GET INTO THE OPERATING- MODE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THAT'S GOING
TO BE PART OF AN AGREEMENT-
THAT'S- THAT'S RIDGE WITH- THE
OPERATORS OF THAT SYSTEM WHICH
HAS WE PROPOSE THAT WE ARE NOT
WE WOULD NOT BE- DIRECTLY
OPERATING THAT SYSTEM IT WOULD
BE A THROUGH THE SAN JOAQUIN'S
A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE MODELED
WITH RIDERSHIP WOULD BE A BASED
ON- PRICES THAT ARE THE SAN
JOAQUIN SPARES TODAY SO THE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD FOR
EXAMPLE IS ESTIMATED TO BE
ABOUT THE- BETWEEN THE TWENTY
SIX AND TWENTY EIGHT DOLLAR
FARE WHICH IS. IN LINE WITH SAN
JOAQUIN'S- FAIRS TODAY A MORE
BROADLY ON A PHASE ONE AND
OTHERS THEY- HIGH SPEED RAIL
DEVELOP THE FORMULA SOME YEARS
AGO ON WHAT- TICKET PRICES THAT
WILL. AIRLINE PRICES THAT ARE.
A SORT OF THE PLAY HOLDER FOR
DOING REVENUE AND RIDERSHIP-
ESTIMATES BUT SPECIFIC FAIRS-
WILL BE PART OF THE OPERATING
AGREEMENT THAT'S NOT YET IN
PLACE- BUT- AGAIN FOR PURPOSES
OF ESTIMATING RIDERSHIP WE USE
THE- A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY.
AFFAIRS FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
SYSTEM IS ABOUT. SEVEN CAN YOU
TALK TO ME ABOUT. PROFIT OR
LOSS. ONCE IT'S BUILT WHAT I
MEAN I DON'T SEE THOSE NUMBERS
ANYWHERE OF WHAT IT WILL CALL
THE COST OPERATE THIS. WITH
BEES AND FAIRS THAT ARE COMING
IN WITH YOUR RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
WHAT KIND OF. AMP SYMBOL OF THE
OPERATING PROFITS SO WHAT KIND
OF LOSS WILL YOU BE OPERATING
AT. WELCOME TODAY- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIZES THE SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICE- THE TO THE
TUNE OF ABOUT EIGHTY ONE
MILLION. DOLLARS A YEAR AND-
WHAT WE- ESTIMATE HERE- UNDER
OURS- OUR PLAN. STILL HAVING
THE SAN JOAQUIN'S OPERATE THE
ENHANCED. A HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE IN THE VALLEY. OF THAT
SUBSIDY WOULD BE CUT IN HALF A
DAD ABOUT FORTY ONE MILLION.
FROM THE CURRENT EIGHTY ONE. A
SO COSTS WOULD BE TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN A MILLION AND A%
TOTAL REVENUE WOULD COME IN
ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE.
OKAY THANK YOU. SO OF I THINK
AND I THINK YOU ANSWERED THIS
BUT I DIDN'T FULLY GATHERED SO
I JUST WANTED TO ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE COST OF
BUILDING THE PHASE ONE HOW MUCH
OF THAT IS ACTUALLY BUILDING A
TRAINED AND HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
OVERHEAD CONSULTANTS. AND THE
LIKE THE- THE OVERHEAD
CONSULTANT RELATED COSTS ARE-
YOU KNOW RELATIVELY LOW WELL
BELOW. BUT YOU KNOW. 10% OF
PROJECT COSTS- YOU KNOW
EFFECTIVE IN. EVEN MORE A
CURRENT CONTRACT WITH OUR- A
CONSULTANT THAT WAS ENTERED
INTO BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. IS
A SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR.
CONTRACT AND- IN SO THAT-
THAT'S A SEVEN YEAR- CONTRACTED
AGAIN BURKE- YOU KNOW
EXPONENTIALLY. THE THROUGH THAT
IN- CONSTRUCTION COSTS SO IT'S
A- RELATIVELY MINOR- COSTS OF
THE OVERALL. THE PROJECT- TO
GIVE YOU. YES I MEAN THE
MAGITUDE OF IT IS WELL BELOW-
10% EVEN 5% THE OVERALL. GOOD
CONSTRUCTION COSTS. I'M THANK
YOU I MEAN I THINK. AS I LOOK
AT ALL OF THIS AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS AND WHAT
OUR CONSTITUENTS NEED AND WHAT
WE NEED TO LEAD TO THE ECONOMIC
I WITH THE RECOVERY THAT WE ARE
NOW FACING AS A STATE- KNOWING.
YOU KNOW THE AREA I REPRESENT
THAT BORDERS CENTRAL VALLEY THE
JOBS THAT WE'VE HEARD THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE AND IN THE BAY
AREA IT IS WITHOUT QUESTION
THAT I THINK CONNECTING THOSE
AREAS INTO OUR URBAN CENTERS IS
CRITICAL AND I DON'T SEE HOW
THIS PROJECT ACCOMPLISHES THAT
AND- THAT LEAVES ME PERPLEXED
AND IT IN THE OPENING- IT WAS
MENTIONED I THINK BY THE
SECRETARY THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THIS PURSUANT TO THE
DIRECTION O THE VOTERS I THINK
WE LONG AGO. LAUGHS WHAT THE
VOTERS BELIEVED WE WERE GOING
TO DO WITH THIS PROJECT WHEN
THEY VOTED YEARS AGO- ON A NINE
BILLION DOLLAR TRAINTHAT WOULD
CONNECT FROM LA TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN OUR BUILDING. JUST
IN THIS PHASE A TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR TRADE FOR MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD. SO HEARING THAT
YOU ANTICIPATE COMING BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE NEXT YEAR FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THIS I
HOPE IT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE VOTERS
TO RE EVALUATE. AND TO ASK THEM
THE QUESTION ARE WE ON THE
TRACK THEY WANTED US TO BE ON
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU SPEAKING
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS. IT WE ARE
NOT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF. MISTER
KELLY WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
AND CHANGE UP A LITTLE BIT E
HAVE A- WITNESS- DR BRIAN
TAYLOR HAS TO AS OF A PRIOR
COMMITMENT WE WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND GET HIM IN THE QUEUE-
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
IN PATIENTS. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CONNECT DR BRIAN TAYLOR-
DIRECOR UCLA IS TO
TRANSPORTATION STUDY. BUT
DOCTOR TAYLOR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME. HELLO IT
TOOK A- OKAY GOOD. AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- IT'S AN HONOR TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AND TO BE
ALLOWED TO DO SO REMOTELY
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME
THESE ARE INDEED UNUSUAL TIMES-
I'M A PROFESSOR OF URBAN
PLANNING A PUBLIC POLICY IN THE
LEFT IN SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE TRANSPORTATION
STUDIES THE UCLA. SEVEN SETTING
AND PUBLISHING A TRAVEL
BEHAVIOR AND TRANSPORTATION
FINANCE PLANNING A POLICY FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS BEFORE THAT I
WORKED AS A TRANSPORTATION
ANALYST IN THE BAY AREA. A
PUBLISHED OVER TWO HUNDRED
PIECES OF TRANSPORTATION
RESEARCH AND 75% OF THOSE ARE
REFEREED ACADEMIC PUBLICATIONS.
I WOULD HAVE TO COME HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT AN ASPECT OF MY
TRAVEL BEHAVIOR RESEARCH
RELATED TO TRANSFERS GENERALLY
AND THE CONCEPT TO TRANSFER
PENALTIES IN PARTICULAR. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THE PROPOSED
INCREMENTAL ROLL OUT OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PLAN WILL
NECESSARILY ENTAIL MORE
TRANSFERS THAN WOULD OTHERWISE
BE THE CASE OF A BILL THAT MY
RESEARCH IN THIS AREA FOCUSED
MERRILY ON ENTRAPMENT
TRIPOLITAN TRAVELING NOT
INTERMINABLE AND TRAVELS. TO
THE UNDERLYING BEHAVIOR OUT
THERE IS THE SAME. I SHOULD
NOTE THAT MY COMMENTS TODAY ARE
NOT SPECIFIC TO PLANS FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA. SO I
DO HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
FINDS THE MUSEUM THE
DELIBERATION. FIRST SOME
BACKGROUND A TRAVEL BEHAVIOR.
THE INDIVIDUAL DEMAND FOR
TRAVEL IS MOSTLY DERIVED FROM
THE NEED OR DESIRE TO ENGAGE IN
ACTIVITIES LIKE WORKER
SOCIALIZING. TO PAIN GOODS LIKE
GROCERS ARE CLOSER- SERVICES
LIKE MEDICAL CARE AMERICA. WELL
THE EXPERIENCE IN RECENT WEEKS
WHAT IT MEANS TO NOT BE ABLE TO
SATISFY THE DEMAND IN THE HIGH
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC COSTS THEY
CAN ENTAIL. SECOND WHEN PEOPLE
TRAVEL THEY ENCOURAGE THREE
SORTS OF COST. MONETARY COST.
HI I'M COST AND RISK AND
UNCERTAINTY COST. SEVEN
DECIDING WHETHER TO GO OUT TO
DINNER WE TRAVEL TO ANOTHER
CITY. PEOPLE BALLOTS THE THREE
KINDS OF COSTS TO GET THE
BENEFITS OF THAT ACTIVITY GOOD
OR SERVICE AT THE DESTINATION.
AND THIRD ONCE ONE HAS DECIDED
TO TRAVEL TO SAY A PHARMACY AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS CONCERNS MODE
CHOICE. SHOULD I WALKED TO THE
PHARMACY RIDE A BIKE OR SCOOTER
TAKE A BUS OR STREETCAR LIFTER
UBER. GET A RIDE FOR A FRIEND
OR IF I HAVE A CAR SHOULD I
DRIVE. DOWN BUT TRAVELERS
TYPICALLY DO NOT GET A PENCIL
AND PAPER AND WEIGH THE COSTS
AND BENEFITS OF THE TRAVEL MODE
EACH TIME THEY TRAVEL. THEY DO
MAKE THESE CALCULATIONS IN SOME
MANNER. THE ONES TRAVEL CHOICES
ARE MADE IN HABITS FORM. SUCH
AS WHEN MOST PEOPLE DRIVE TO
MOST DESTINATIONS. ARE MOSTLY
BLIGHTED CITIES. THEY TEND NOT
TO REVISIT THESE OPTIONS UNLESS
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO MAKE THEM
RETHINK THEIR CHOICES. THE SAME
DECISION CREDIT- PROSTITUTES
APPLY TO INNER CITY TRAVEL AND
MODE CHOICE. SHOULD I DRIVE
ALONE DRIVE WITH OTHERS TAKE A
BUS TO TRAIN OR AIRPLANE. RIGHT
THE TIME IN THE RICH CONCERT
BECAUSE OF THESE VARIOUS
OPTIONS ALL WEIGHED AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER AS WELL AS FOR GOING
THE TRIP OF THE COST YOUR
DEEMED TOO HIGH. SO WHERE DID
TRANSFERS COME INTO A LITTLE
BIT. EXCEPT FOR TRAVELING
SOMEWHERE BY FOOT VIRTUALLY ALL
TRIPS ENTAILED SOME KINDS OF
TRANSPORT. I MIGHT WALK TO MY
CAR IN MY DRIVEWAY DRIVE TO THE
PHARMACY AND WALKED TO THE
PARKING AT THE STORE AND THAT
ENTAIL TRANSFERS. I'M I WALK TO
MY HOUSE TO RIDE YOU TAKE IT TO
AN AIRPORT WALK THROUGH
SECURITY TO THE GATE ONTO AN
AIRPLANE. AND FLY TO CHICAGO
CHANGED PLANES IN CHICAGO AND
THEN FLY TO WASHINGTON DC. IN
DC I WALK FROM THE PLANE TO DC
METRO CHANGE TRAINS AND WALKED
MY FINAL DESTINATION. AT THE
LEAST EIGHT TRANSFERS WERE A
LONG CROSS COUNTRY TRIP.
RICHARD SHOWS THAT ADDITIONAL
TRANSFERRED INCREASE THE
OVERALL TRANSFER PENALTY MORE
THAN PROPORTIONALLY. WHICH
EXPLAINS WHY AIR TRAVELERS WILL
PAY A PREMIUM FOR NONSTOP
FLIGHTS. AND WHY SO FEW TRANSIT
PASSENGERS WILL MAKE TWO OR
MORE TRANSFERS BETWEEN BUSES OR
TRAINS ON THE GIVEN TRANSIT
TRIP. FURTHER NEED COURSE
TRANSFERS SUCH AS CHANGING
PLANES ARE MOVING FROM ONE BUS
TO ANOTHER TYPICALLY ENTAIL
HIGHER TRANSFER PENALTIES OF
THOSE MADE AT THE TRIP IN. THAT
IS SUCH TRANSFERRED BEADED BY
TRAVELER MORE HEAVILY THAN
OTHER PARTS OF THE JOURNEY.
THIS IS BECAUSE THEY RAISE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS WHERE WILL I
GET OFF THAT PLANE IN CHICAGO
IS THE GATE FOR MY CONNECTING
FLIGHT NEAR OR FAR STILL HAVE
TIME TO MAKE THE SWITCH WHICH
WAY DO I GO. WOULD HAVE MY
FLIGHT IS DELAYED THE MY NECK
AND CONNECTING FLIGHT IS NOT.
THE MORE HALF TO UNCERTAINTY
THE HIGHER THE TRANSFER PENALTY.
THE RESURGENT PUBLIC TRANSIT
WHICH I KNOW BEST SHOWS THE
PASSENGERS. WEIGHT TRANSFER
TIME AT ABOUT ONE AND A HALF.
TO FOUR AND A HALF TIMES THE
VEHICLE TIME. FOR ABOUT THREE
TIMES GREATER ON AVERAGE. THAT
IS TO AN AVERAGE TRAVELER WHO
RIDE THE SUBWAY FOR TEN
MINUTES. TRANSFERRED TO. WAIT
TEN MINUTES FOR DIFFERENT TRAIN
AND THEN RISE TWENTY MINUTES TO
A DESTINATION. THAT TEN MINUTE
TRANSFER IS CONSIDERED A BALLOT
IS BURDENSOME IS THE ENTIRE
THIRTY MINUTE SPENT RIDING THE
TRAIN. THIS IN A NUTSHELL IS
THE TRANSCRIPT AND- NINE
MENTIONED IN THAT TRAIN PENALTY
IS A- TO ABOUT ONE AND A HALF
TO FOUR AND A HALF TIMES THE
VEHICLE. BUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A TEN MINUTE WAIT
FEELING LIKE FIFTEEN MINUTES
GREAT TEN MINUTE WAIT FEELING
BY FORTY FIVE MINUTES A LOT. SO
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT CAN BE
DONE TO REDUCE TRANSFER THEM TO.
MY COLLEAGUE HERO EFFECTIVE
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND AYE
ADAPTED MASS LAWS HIERARCHY OF
NEEDS TO CREATE A TRANSFERRING
PASSENGERS HIGHER THE KIDNEYS.
BASED BOTH ON OUR OWN RESEARCH
AND ON FINDING THE BEST IN THE
STATE IS A REVIEW. AND THE
FIGURE THAT I SUBMITTED SHOWS
THAT. IN ITS HIERARCHY THE
FIGURES THAT THE FACTORS AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE PYRAMID MUST
ADDRESS BEFORE THE HIGHER RUNS
BECOME MEANINGFUL. FOR EXAMPLE
IF CONNECTING ON A COMMUTER
TRAIN IS LATE OR IF THE
EVENTUAL ARRIVAL OF THAT
CONNECTING TRAINS UNCERTAIN.
PASSENGERS ARE UNLIKELY TO
FULLY APPRECIATE CLEAR SIGHTED
YOUR COMFORTABLE SEAT AT THE
BAR. SO WHAT IS THE HIGH. IF
YOU'RE TRYING. WHETHER YOU'RE
TRANSFERRING FROM ONE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO A BUS TO BE
TRANSFERRING FROM AN AIRPLANE
TO ANOTHER PLANE OF FROM A BUS
TO THE SUBWAY. THE FIRST AND
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS SAFETY
AND SECURITY. THE QUICKEST WAY
TO DRIVE AWAY PASSENGERS WOULD
MAKE THEM FEEL UNSAFE. FOR ITS
RISKY WHILE THEY'RE WAITING OR
TRANSFERRING. THE SECOND MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS CONNECTIONS
AND RELIABILITY. SEAMLESS
CONNECTIONS AND RELIABLE AND
ARRIVAL DEPARTMENT DEPARTURE
TIMES ARE CRITICAL. WELL I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'VE MISSED THAT
OTHER FLIGHT TO THAT BACK TO
THE LEFT JUST BEFORE WE WERE TO
CATCH IT. IS EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING IN AND AGGRAVATE
PASSENGERS IMMENSELY. THOSE
FAMOUS. TIME TRANSFER YOUR
ATTENTION. FOR IS THE PROCESS
ACT THAT INFORMATION CHRIS
CLEAR SIGN AND DIRECTIONS SHORT
WALKS WITH THE TRANSIT.
COMFORTABLE PLACES THE WAITER
ALL CONNECTIONS AFTER THE
CONNECTIONS ARE KEY TO MAKE
THAT BETTER. AND THEN FINALLY
IN FOR IT OUR AMENITIES LIKE
CLEAN EASY TO FIND RESTROOMS
WIFI FOOD DRINK PLACES TO SIT
WHILE WAITING. THERE ARE NICE
BUT ONLY IF THOSE FIRST THREE
PACKAGES SATISFIED. SO TRANSFER
IS NOT A TRANSFER IN MAKING IT
DIFFICULT. SO OVERALL TRAVELERS
WAY THE BURDEN OF TRANSFERRING
MORE HEAVILY THAN OTHER PARTS
OF THEIR TRIP. SO FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE TRAVELER THE
FEW WERE TRANSFERRED TO THE
BETTER. BUT NOT ALL TRANSFERS
CAN BE AVOIDED IN RESEARCH
POINTS IS THE WAY TO MAKE AT
THAT BURDEN THE- FIRST FIFTEEN
SECURITY THEN CONNECTIONS AND
RELIABILITY. THEN ACCESS TO
ACCOMMODATION AND THEN
AMENITIES IN A NUTSHELL. MAKE
TRANSFERS STATE RELIABLE INCOME.
AND FIRST IN KEEP THEM TO OBEY
MINIMUM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF DR
TAYLOR. SEEING NONE THANK YOU
FOR THE INFORMATIVE.
INFORMATION SIR AND WILL-
BEFORE TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE. NOW WILL GO ON A
NINETY NINE UNDER BRANKO. I
THOUGHT OF. MISTER KELLY CAN
HEAR US I CAN'T HEAR YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
WITH YOUR PICTURE BUT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AM WHAT WOULD MOVE ON
MISTER PATTERSON. I THANK
MISTER CHAIRMAN. MISTER KELLY
WE HAVE BEEN HERE BE SEEMS NOT
TOO LONG AGO THAT- WE WERE
DISCUSSING THE DISARRAY THE
INTERNAL CHAOS AS A RESULT OF
THE AUDIT BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AUDITOR. OF THE
INTERNAL CHAOS A- FOR ME LEADS
TO THE POSSIBILITY OF SOME VERY
SERIOUS. INVESTIGATIONS MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS HAVE YOU
PERSONALLY OR HAVE ANY BOARD
MEMBERS OR ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR
YOU OR HAS WORKED FOR YOU BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION. I
CERTAINLY AM NOT- I DON'T BUT
THE GETTING MY- BOARD MEMBERS
HAVE- AND BEYOND THAT I DON'T
KNOW. SO PEOPLE WHO HAVE WORKED
FOR YOU. BY THE AUTHORITY YOU
HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF ANY IT
BEING INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI.
WELL I. MR PATERSON WHAT I
CAN'T WHAT I CAN'T TELL YOU IS
AYE I. DO DO NOT KNOW. YOU KNOW
WHAT I HAVE SEEN THE LA TIMES
STORIES- BUT I DO NOT KNOW
WHETHER THERE IS AN ACTIVE FBI
INVESTIGATION GOING ON OR NOT
ABOUT ANYTHING RELATED TO OUR
PROGRAM. WHAT A DRY YOUR
ATTENTION TO. SEPTEMBER. TWENTY
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS IS A
LAWSUIT AT- THE UNITED STATES
DISTRICT COURT EASTERN DISTRICT
OF CALIFORNIA THIS DEPOSITION
NOW WAS PART OF A LITIGATION
BETWEEN WEST PACIFIC ELECTRIC
COMPANY. AND GATOS WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT PARTICIPANT IN HIGH
SPEED RAIL. ON NINE SEPTEMBER
TWENTIETH- MISTER ANDREW
ERICKSON WAS ASKED BY THE
PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY IF HE HAD
BEEN. CONTACTED OR INTERVIEWED
BY ANY GOVERNMENT AGENCIES HIS
ANSWER WAS. ARE THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION SAID
THAT A CURVED UP SOMEWHERE IN
MID TWENTY EIGHTEEN. ARM IN
FURTHER QUESTIONING IN THIS
DEPOSITION I HAVE THE
DEPOSITION IF MEMBERS WISH TO
SEE IT. THE PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEY
ASKED AGAIN FOR. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AUTHORITY WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE FBI. AND
WITH MISTER ERICKSON. HIS
ANSWER WAS YES. AND THAT
THEY'RE IN THE PERSON.
IDENTIFIED. WAS DIANA GOMEZ.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU AGAIN HAVE
YOU PERSONALLY OR ANY BOARD
MEMBERS OR ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR
YOU. OR WHO HAS WORKED FOR YOU.
OR THE AUTHORITY. BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI. SIR
PATTERSON I HAVE NOT BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION I KNOW
OF NO BOARD MEMBER WAS BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION AND I
THINK WHAT YOU MIGHT BE
REFERENCING- IS AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL OF NO SIR I'M GOING TO
I'M GOING TO QUESTION YOU ON
THAT IN A MINUTE. OKAY WHAT I
AM TRYING TO DETERMINE IS HOW
DOES THE CEO. YEAH OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY NOT KNOW
THAT ANDREW ERICKSEN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY OF TWENTY NINETEEN IN
THE DEPOSITION OF WHICH I HAVE
A COPY. WAS INTERVIEWED BY THE
FBI AND ONE OF YOUR PRINCIPAL
INDIVIDUALS. IN THE FRESNO AREA
WHO IS THE FACE AND THE VOICE
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL. WAS
IMPLICATED IN THAT ENQUIRING
AND YOU ARE TELLING US YOU KNOW
NOTHING ABOUT IT. WHAT I'M
TELLING YOU MISTER PATTERSON IS
THAT I KNOW THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL WHO WORKS WITH US.
ROUTINELY ON THE DOCUMENTS AND-
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS NO-
WASTE BROADER ABUSE BECAUSE
THIS FEDERAL MONEY ON THIS
PROJECT- THAT WE HAVE INVITED
THEM IN. A TO TRAIN OUR STAFF
ON OF THOSE ISSUES TO ASSURE
THAT WE- BEHAVE ACCORDINGLY- I
KNOW THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS- MADE
ENQUIRIES- SPOKEN WITH MS GOMEZ
AND WHAT I DON'T KNOW WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THE FBI. WAS
WITH- WITH THEM ON THAT- I DO
KNOW THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL- OFFICE HAS ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT- OF MISS
GOVERNMENT. AGAIN I THINK YOUR
ARE. OUT A- SICK. DISK OF THE
US DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
IN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. IS IT
NOT TRUE THAT IT IS THE
CRIMINAL DIVISION OF THE US
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION'S
INSPECTOR GENERAL. THAT IS AND
ASKING THESE KINDS OF QUESTIONS.
YEAH I GET MISTER PATTERSON
FORGIVE ME BUT I THINK YOUR-
SUGGESTING THINGS THAT I CAN'T
REALLY DO NOT KNOW TO BE TRUE
THE REASON I DON'T KNOW THAT TO
BE TRUE IS. OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL DID CONDUCT AN AUDIT OF
THE FEDERAL RAILROAD
ADMINISTRATION AT THE REQUEST
OF MISTER DENNIS. AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ON THE HEELS
OF THAT REQUEST- DID GET IN
CONTACT WITH US A TALK TO MY
AUDITOR WHO THEY TALKED TO
ROUTINELY MY INTERNAL AUDITOR-
AND THEY DID ASK ME AND SHE
ASKED ME IF WE'D BE INTERESTED
IN HAVING THEM TRAIN OUR PEOPLE
ON IDENTIFYING FREIGHT. OF
WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE IN OUR
CONTRACTING PROCESS IS TO WHICH
I SAID YES AND WE INVITED THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN TO DO
THAT. UP I. M. EARLY NOT TO.
HERE ABOUT OTHER ELEMENT OF
THIS INVESTIGATION OTHER THAN I
DO KNOW THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE- DID CONTACT
DIANA GOMEZ- ABOUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES- THAT THEY ASK- ASKED
FOR DOCUMENTS ALL. AND I
BELIEVE SHE HAD AN INTERVIEW
WITH. BUT BEYOND THAT I CAN'T
COME TO THE US AND I CERTAINLY-
IT NOT AWARE OF THAT ANY OF
THAT IS PART OF A- CRIMINAL
INTO. A CRIMINAL. INTO THE I.
G.'S OFFICE DO YOU I DON'
THERE IS. OFFICE THE WHO DOES
THE JOB WAIT WAIT. WASTE FRAUD
IN THE- THEY SPOKE WITH MONTHS
AGO AND THERE HAS BEEN NO
COMMUNITY. IN WEEKS MONTHS UP
WITH US. THOSE BUT I. G.
BECAUSE THERE'S A BETTER MONEY
I THIS PROJECT. IS ALWAYS PART
OF THIS. YEAH I WOULD DUB
SUGGESTED THE INTEREST IN THE
I. G. HAS A AWFUL LOT DO WITH
THE- BACK ON THE- MONEY AND-
THEY- BEHAVE. THAT I TOOK PLACE
IN THE UTILIZATION OF IT OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE SOUNDLY.
CRITICIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AUDITOR BUT THAT'S FOR ANOTHER
TIME. DO YOU DO YOU DISPUTE.
THE REPORTING IN THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES THAT IT IS THE
CRIMINAL DIVISION. BUT YES BUT
I GENERAL. THAT'S THE REPORTING
ALL RIGHT SO DEALING I WOULD
SAY IS THIS I HAVE NOT BEEN
CONTACTED BY ANYBODY I KNOW TO
BE PART OF THE CRIMINAL
DIVISION THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE I DO KNOW
THEIR INSPECTOR IN AUDIT UNIT
HAS CONTACTED US. ABOUT
FERRETING OUT WASTE FRAUD AND
ABUSE IN THE FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROJECT- THAT WE HAVE ASKED
THEM TO COME IN AND TRAIN OUR
EMPLOYEES. AND I DO KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE ASKED FOR DOCUMENTS
AND THAT WE HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
RESPONSIVE. BECAUSE I DO THEM
AS A PARTNER- I WELCOME THEIR
PARTICIPATION. IN FIGURING OUT
IF THERE'S ANYTHING A MESS AND
SO WE HAVE HAD COMMUNICATION
WITH THEM THEY'VE ASKED FOR
DOCUMENTS THAT WE PROVIDED THEM
AT EVERY TURN. THROUGH MY
AUDITOR'S OFFICE- INTO YOUR
COUNSEL'S OFFICE ABSOLUTELY BUT
I DO NOT KNOW I TO BE SITTING
HERE TODAY I COULD TELL YOU I
DO NOT KNOW THAT THERE'S A
QUOTE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
GOING ON BY ANY FEDERAL AND TO
THE OF OUR OUR OUR TO BE CLEAR
IT'S THE IT WAS REPORTED AS THE
CRIMINAL DIVISION OF THE US
DEPARTMENT. OF TRANSPORTATION.
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT THAT WAS
THE REPORTING CAN YOU
SPECIFICALLY. SITE ANY OUT.
ACTIONS THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN
ADMINISTRATIVELY OR AN OTHER
WISE- AS A RESULT OF YOUR SO
CALLED PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL IN OTHER
WORDS HAVE YOU FIRED PEOPLE
HAVE YOU REMOVED PEOPLE HAVE
YOU FOUND MALFEASANCE AND HAVE
YOU ACTED ON IT. YEAH AGAIN-
YOU KNOW THE FINDING ABOUT FEES
AND SO I HAVE NOT THE CERTAINLY
NOT DONE I WOULD SAY THIS UP.
THERE ARE THERE HAVE BEEN NO
PERSONNEL- COMPLAINS THAT WE
HAVE. RESPONDED TO- AND I HAVE
TAKEN MANAGEMENT ACTION- IN
DEALING WITH THOSE- BUT AS
THEIR PERSONNEL MATTERS IT'S
REALLY NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON
THAT IN ANY DETAIL HERE I WILL
TELL YOU. THAT I HAVE HAD A
CORRECTIVE ACTIONS WITH
MANAGEMENT PERSONNEL OVER
THINGS LIKE THAT- BUT IN TERMS
OF QUOTE. AND I'M JUST GONNA
USE THE TERM BROADLY HERE QUOTE
WASTE FRAUD AND ABUSE- THERE IS
NOTHING- THAT I'M AWARE OF FROM
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE
THE UP WE ARE ANYBODY AS I'M
SITTING HERE TODAY THAT- HAS
BEEN BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION.
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS ANSWER
NOT CRIMINAL. YEAH ANY IN THE-
AS TO WHEN OR IF. ARE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL GIVE YOU
ESSENTIALLY A CLEAN BILL OF
HEALTH THAT YOU'RE DOING IT
FINE NO I CANDIDLY DON'T
BELIEVE THEY EVER WILL BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THEIR JOB IN LIFE
WHICH IS APPROPRIATE IS TO BE
THE ENTITY THAT ASSURES FEDERAL
DOLLARS ARE SPENT
APPROPRIATELY. AND AGAIN MY
INTERACTION WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE TODAY HAS BEEN
MAKING SURE WE'RE GIVING THEM
EVERY IN ANY DOCUMENT THEIR
REQUEST AND THAT THEY TRAIN MY
PEOPLE MY CONTRACT MANAGERS ON
HOW TO IDENTIFY THOSE KIND OF
PROBLEMS. AND THAT'S WHERE I'VE
BEEN WITH THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE THE- YOUR TO
FOR. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF LOOK
FRESNO AND SAID TO CALIFORNIA'S
THE- BY THE MIDDLE OF THIS
WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF A GUINEA
PIG HERE. I NEED TO TELL YOU
THAT MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED ALL
KINDS OF INPUT. FROM WHAT
AMOUNTS TO WHISTLE BLOWERS
OTHER PEOPLE WHO. HAVE BEEN
TOLD THAT THE OPERATIONS- HAVE
REALLY BEEN SUSPICIOUS. I THINK
THE REPORTING A MALE LOS
ANGELES TIMES DEMONSTRATED-
THAT SOME OF YOUR CONTRACTORS.
OF LITERALLY- PRESSURED- SOME
OF THE VERY PEOPLE THAT- THEY
HIRED TO DO THE OVERSIGHT. INTO
UP MAKING THINGS UP. AND THAT
REPORTING. UP DO YOU DISPUTE.
YES AND I WILL TELL YOU UP I'LL
TAKE ZACH LEE MY VIEW ON THIS
THE FIRST IS. YOU KNOW WHICH LA
TIMES STORY YOU'RE REFERENCING-
IS IT I'M NOT CERTAIN BUT I
WILL SAY THIS I'VE CERTAINLY
READ A STORY WHERE SOMEBODY AN
EMPLOYEE OF A CONSULT NOT AN
EMPLOYEE OF MINE- HAD SUGGESTED
THAT SOMEHOW WE DON'T PUT ABOUT
BAD NEWS. AND I WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT THE DAY I READ THAT
STORY I THOUGHT TO SAY THE
LEAST THAT WAS IRONIC. BECAUSE
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE I PUT OUT
A LOT OF BAD NEWS- I HAVE- IN
THIS ORGANIZATION HAS OF COURSE
VERY HARD TO BE CLEAR- AND
TRANSPARENT ABOUT NOT JUST WHAT
OUR OPPORTUNITIES ARE WHAT OUR
CHAPTERS ARE. IN I. THE
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS. THAT WE HAVE
INCREASES IN SCHEDULE. THAT TO
DO. I MEAN I. GOING TO INCREASE
OUR TENDENCY TO DEAL WITH RISK.
AND I HAVE PUT THE TWENTY DRAW
BUSINESS PLAN THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S A NEED TO PUSH OUT ARE
VALID. TIME IN SO. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS NONE OF THOSE ARE NEWS.
ABOUT I HIM OUT BECAUSE MY JOB.
AND I J. THIS FROM TO FIVE YEAR
NOW WORK IN. THE PUBLIC'S IN
THE- SO. IS THERE IS NO VALUE.
IN KEEPING YOUR CHALLENGES
INSIDE. THE TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING FOR THIS PROJECT
PROJECT- I RESPECT THAT
IMMENSELY- AND MY JOB IS TO PUT
OUT EXACTLY WHAT ARE
CHALLENGES. AND OPPORTUNITIES
ARE AND TO FORM THE PUBLIC WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING TO DO ABOUT. IT
SO THAT'S THAT'S HOW I OPERATE
I WILL TELL YOU. THAT AND I
THINK THIS WAS MADE CLEAR
BEFORE- IN A PUBLIC SETTING
THAT IS OUR BOARD HERE- I DO
BELIEVE THAT. WITH RESPECT TO.
A CLAIM FROM A CONTRACTOR'S
EMPLOYEE. OTHER THAN CONTRACTOR
HAS HIRED OUTSIDE FOR. A TO
REVIEW THOSE COMPLAINTS. AND
THAT INVESTIGATION OF THAT
REVIEW IS STILL ONGOING- WHEN
I'M OF ONE. BUT THANK. I WILL.
CERTAINLY I ACCORDING. ON
ANYTHING THAT I MUST. YEAH SO.
I THINK IT'S A GENERAL
CONCLUSION HERE BY MANY OF US
ARE THAT THESE PREVIOUS BIT
BUSINESS PLANS HAVE ESSENTIALLY
I I'VE I'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
MENTOR IN TERMS OF MAKING
THINGS UP. AS YOU GO ALONG. UGH.
WHAT KINDS OF CONCRETE SPECIFIC
ACTIONS HAVE YOU TAKEN THAT WAS
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE US THE
KIND OF- CONFIDENCE THAT WHEN
WE'RE HERE NEXT TIME AROUND
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ALL KINDS
OF CHANGES AND- RE EVALUATIONS
AND RE CALCULATIONS. WELL I
WOULD SAY TO YOU MISTER
PATTERSON AS I DESCRIBED IN THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES THAT
MAKE THEM HERE- BUT I HAVE-
PERSONALLY TRANSFORM THE
ENTIRETY OF THE- OUR EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT TEAM- WE PUT IN A
CULTURE OF. OF REALLY BEING
MISSION FOCUSED- DOING THE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE I THINK
WE'RE SEEING THE AFFECTS OF
THAT WHEN I. SHOW YOU THAT WHAT
WE CALL THE A KPIS OF THE KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS THAT
SHOW OUR WORK IS ADVANCING-
LOOK I DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG
SECRET AS TO WHY THIS PROJECT
IS SET CHALLENGES. BUT WE GOT A
NEW CONSTRUCTION BEFORE THE
RIGHT AWAY WAS AND WE STILL
NEED TO GET A LOT OF RIGHT AWAY
IN THAT BECAUSE DELAY. AND COST
INCREASES. AND I WAS VERY
CANDID ABOUT THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I REMAIN CANDID ABOUT
THAT TODAY. MY JOB IS TO COME
HERE AND TALK TO YOU ALL ABOUT
OF WHAT THE- CHALLENGES- OF
RISKS AND OPPORTUNITIES ARE. OF
FOR THIS PROJECT. AND I A- YOU
KNOW I AND ALL RIGHT SO I'VE
MADE PERSONNEL CHANGES. WE'RE
MAKING GOVERNANCE CHANGES A
CONSTANTLY- WE PUT IN A
COMMITTEE PROCESS TO EVALUATE A
CHANGE ORDERS THEY COME ALL THE
WAY UP TO MEET. ABOVE A CERTAIN
LEVEL- AND I APPROVE THOSE IN A
GENERALLY REPORT THOSE- TO OUR
BOARD EVERY MONTH- WE HAVE PUT
IN GREATER TRANSPARENCY- I
THINK ANYBODY WHO WATCHES ARE
FINANCING AUDIT COMMITTEE OR
GOES THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS THAT
WE PROVIDE. A PUBLICLY EVERY
MONTH OR FINANCE AND AUDIT
COMMITTEE. CAN SEE EXACTLY
WHERE THE CHALLENGES ARE- IN
THIS PROJECT. WHAT WE'RE DOING
WELL AND WHAT WE'RE NOT DOING
WELL- IN SO ALL OF THAT IS
PUBLIC ALTHOUGH THAT IS
AVAILABLE. AND WHETHER I'M IN
THIS BODY OR ANY OTHER BODY- MY
POSITION IS TO ANSWER ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE VERY CANDID
AND FORTHRIGHT WAY- I SEE
AGAIN. NO VALUE IN TELLING YOU
WHAT THE CHALLENGES ARE A BY MY
BEST VALUE WAS TELLING YOU WHAT
THOSE ARE. THEY TELL YOU WHAT
WE'RE DOING ABOUT. AND SO WE
MAKE. CHANGE GOVERNANCE CHANGE.
AND WE REPORT OUR A COST AND
SCHEDULE ISSUES IN A WAY THAT
IS I THINK IMPROVED. FROM PAST
PRACTICE. WITH HER TO THE UP
THE RISKS OF CLAWBACK HOW YOU
ASSESS THIS. HAVE YOU MADE
CONTINGENCY PLANS IF THE CALLED
IF THE CLAW BACKS COME BACK AND
I WOULD POINT THIS OUT IT WAS A
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. WHO
RECOGNIZED THAT IT WAS A VERY
RECKLESS DECISION. TO PUT A
BUNCH OF MONEY FEDERAL MONEY
OUT. BEFORE YOU HAD RIGHTS OF
WAY HAD ANY. PROPERTY UPON
WHICH- TO BUILD AND IT WAS. THE
AUDITOR'S CONCLUSION. THAT
OTHER THAT THAT DECISION OPENS
SERIOUS RISK. OF PENALTIES FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ARE
THEIR CONTINGENCY PLANS IF YOU
HAVE TO CALL BACK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS TO GIVE BACK
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WELL UP
FIRST- I DO NOT SEE ANY BASIS
FOR- CLAWBACK OF THE TWO POINT
FOUR TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR ARE OF FUNDS THOSE
DOLLARS ARE SPENT. AND WE HAVE
MATCHED- ROUGHLY 56% OF THOSE
FUNDS NOW- AND- BY THE YEAR'S
END THEY'LL BE FULLY MATCH THAN
SO I SEE A NO BASIS FOR THOSE
DOLLARS BECAUSE BACK AT ALL BUT
SECONDLY WE ARE CHALLENGING
VIGOROUSLY IN LITIGATION. THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION
TO TRY TO CALL BACK THE NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
THAT WE HAVEN'T EVEN ACCESS
YEAH- I THINK ULTIMATELY THE
DECISION IS GOING TO BE MADE ON
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE DOLLARS
ARE. FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM
CLAWBACK COUPLE- IS GOING TO BE
DETERMINED WHETHER OR NOT WE
ARE GOING TO BE. DETERMINED ON
THE BASIS OF WHETHER OR NOT WE
MADE SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS ON
THIS PROJECT. AND MY NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IS TO DO THAT. IS TO-
MAKE PROGRESS TO SHOW THAT WE
ARE- HEADING TOWARD MEETING OUR
FEDERAL OBLIGATIONS IN TERMS OF
THE TIMELINE- AND THAT WE ARE
MOVING FORWARD. AN ADVANCING
THIS PROJECT CONSISTENT WITH
THE SPIRIT OF OUR FEDERAL MONEY
GRANT AGREEMENT. AND THAT'S
THAT'S MY PRIMARY OBJECTIVE. OF
ANY TERMS OF CONTINGENCY PLANS-
YOU KNOW IF THE CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS RIGHT NOW THAT HAVE COME
IN AT ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MILLION. DOLLARS A
YEAR OF FOR THIS PROJECT SINCE
CAP AND TRADE BEEN EXTENDED- IF
THAT CONTINUES WE WILL BE ABLE
TO FOR THE LOSS OF THE NOT
TWENTY NINE. I THINK OKAY AND
TRADE TO HIS TICKET FIVE EIGHTY
EVERY YEAR FOR THAT TO HAVE.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR
WITH THE- CAP AND TRADE IS
PRESS. YEAH REVENUES ARE VOTER.
IN THEM AND IN SO THOSE ARE
THINGS WE WHILE. A VERY CLOSE
IN TERMS OF A CONTINGENCY
THERE'S OF TWO WE WOULD WE
WOULD. OF YOU KNOW SO MORE FOR
FROM SO ELSE OR PROBABLY MORE
LIKELY WE WOULD REDUCE GO. OF
THIS PROJECT IN EXACTLY HOW
THEY WOULD DO THAT HOW WE WOULD
DO THAT- YOU KNOW I'M NOT. A
PUTTING OUT YET- TODAY BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
COME TO THAT- BUT THOSE ARE THE
OPTIONS THAT WOULD BE BEFORE.
REDUCE THE SCOPE TAKE ON A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT APPROACH.
TO HOW WE MOVED MOVE THIS FALL.
AND SO. THOSE ARE THE TWO ARE
ARE PRIMARILY PRIMARILY. THE
OPTIONS BEFORE. I START I'M
HEARING. TIME WILL TELL AS-
THAT LEE IT WILL BE WHAT UP
WITH A- TO THE COURTS TO DECIDE
SO YOU'RE GOING TO. FULL TIME
WILL TELL. WELL AGAIN I THINK
WE'RE GONNA PREVAIL LITIGATION
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO DEEP THE ROLE RISK
ANALYSIS ON ALL ELEMENTS OF
THIS PROGRAM INCLUDING A WERE
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS COME IN I
THINK IT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT- IN LIGHT OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN A GLOBAL IMPACT
ON A FINANCE IN THE ECONOMY-
AND SO WE'RE GONNA WATCH VERY
CAREFULLY WHAT HAPPENS OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF OCTAVES. AND
CERTAINLY IF YOU ARE RISK
ASSESSMENT AND ARE DEEPER RISK
ANALYSIS OF THESE KIND OF
IMPACTS WE WILL REPORT FULL
THROATED APPROACHES STORY TO
THE LEGISLATURE- BY YEAR'S END.
ONE FINAL QUESTION HAVE YOU
PERSONALLY OR HAS ANY BOARD
MEMBER OR ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR
YOU. BEEN SUBPOENAED BY A
FEDERAL GRAND JURY. NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE. WANNA TALK VERY
QUICKLY ABOUT. BEING RIPPED UP
AND BEING RIPPED OFF WITH
RESPECT TO ONE MORE THING. MY
HOME HAS BEEN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. TWO TERM MAYOR OF
THE AREA. I'VE KNOWN AND
APPRECIATED. THE FOLKS IN OUR
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY AND OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND IN
TALKING WITH EXISTING. PEOPLE
WHO HAVE HAD THEIR PROPERTY
TAKEN THEIR. CROPS RIPPED OUT.
ACCESS TO DECENT THE- WAYS OF
GETTING AROUND THERE THE
LEFTOVER PARTIALS I HAVE A LIST
HERE THERE'S A HALF A DOZEN. OF
FARMERS ON THIS LIST WITH ALL
KINDS OF ISSUES. AND THEY
BASICALLY FELL DOWN TO THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. HAS TAKEN
A PROPERTY HAS MADE LIFE LIFE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM THEY CANNOT
GET THE MONEY THAT THEY'RE OWED.
THAT THE IT SEEMS LIKE YOU HAVE
PLENTY OF STAFF MEMBERS. AND
PLENTY OF MONEY TO BUILD STUFF.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DON'T
HAVE THE WILLINGNESS OR OR THE
STAFFING OR THE ATTORNEYS. TO
DO JUSTICE TO THESE. FARMERS.
MY QUESTION IS DID DOES DOES IT
CONCERN YOU. DOES IT BOTHER YOU
THAT YOU ARE HEADING AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS REALLY
MADE LIFE MISERABLE FOR SOME OF
THE FINEST PEOPLE. IN OUR AREA.
AND I HEAR FROM THEM MISTER
KELLY YOU MAY NOT. BUT I DO
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WHAT DO YOU INTEND TO DO ABOUT
THAT. MISTER PATTERSON LET ME
START WITH THE LIST THAT YOU
HAVE. WE WHY DON'T YOU GIVE ME
THAT LIST AND WE WILL GO
THROUGH A CASE BY CASE AND
REVIEW THOSEISSUES AND I'M
HAPPY TO OR GO THROUGH IT AND
REPORT BACK TO THE FACTS ON
DIGITAL SIX AND I WANT TO TELL
YOU I TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY HOW
SENSITIVE IT'S FOR SOMEBODY- TO
WORK WITH US TO GIVE UP PRIVATE
PROPERTY- FOR THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT OF THIS PROJECT BUT I
ALSO WANT TO SAY. THE NET
BENEFIT OF THIS PROJECT IN THAT
REGION TO ME IS CLEAR. BUT WE
HAVE BEEN A HUGE PART. OF
EMPLOYMENT GAINS IN THAT. AREA
OF THE STATE THE THAT HAS BEEN
OF FOR A LONG TIME HIGHLY
DISADVANTAGED WHEN IT COMES
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND WE
HAVE PROVIDED MASSIVE
OPPORTUNITY I COULD BE PROUD.
OF THE FACT THAT I PUT OUT YOU
KNOW MORE THAN THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED- WORKERS DISPATCH TO
THIS PROJECT THESE ARE GOOD
PAYING. HIGH PAYING JOBS THAT
COULD SUSTAIN FAMILIES. IN
THERE'S NO WHERE I'M HAPPIER
THAT WE'RE DOING. THEN IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. A IT IS A
PASSION OF MINE. TO MOVE FROM
DIESEL EMISSION. A TECHNOLOGIES
CHECK CLEAN ELECTRIFY
TECHNOLOGIES TO IMPROVE THE AIR
CONDITION THE AIR QUALITY THAT
READ THE PUBLIC HEALTH. SO ALSO
WITH THE LIST THAT YOU HAVE. A
IT IS A VERY SENSITIVE MATTER
ON DEALING PEOPLE WITH DEALING
WITH PEOPLE AND THEIR PROPERTY.
AND I WILL GO THROUGH IT ONE BY
ONE BE WITH YOU THESE ARE ALL
JUST MISSED KELLY THESE ARE ALL
IN THE PROCESS FOR YEARS. YOU
WOULD KNOW WHAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS. BUT I WILL TELL
YOU IN TALKING TO MY FRIENDS.
THAT THEY ARE ASKING ME TO KEEP
THESE. CONFIDENTIAL BECAUSE
THEY FEAR RETRIBUTION. BY THE
STAFF AND THE PEOPLE THAT YOU
HAVE PUT IN CHARGE. OF THESE OF.
PAYING THESE PEOPLE WHAT THEY
ARE SUPPOSED TO GET WHAT THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY HAS
PROMISED TO GIVE THEM AND
CONTINUES TO USE EXCUSES AND
PEOPLE CAN'T TALK TO PEOPLE
THAT CAN MAKE DECISIONS YOU CAN
DECIDE TO THROW CONCRETE. BUT
YOU CAN'T DECIDE TO PAY THESE
PEOPLE. MISTER PATTERSON I'M
OFFERING TO HELP- AND I'M
OFFERING TO HELP WITH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IN THE
ORGANIZATION- AND SO AGAIN I'LL
DO THAT. OF WHENEVER YOU WANT
AND I WOULD JUST SAY WE WILL
BEGIN I DO NOT I DO NOT- WE
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY- THE
SENSITIVE NATURE OF. OF GOING
TO THE EMINENT DOMAIN PROCESS
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT PROCESS
IS GUIDED BY LAW. AND SOMETIMES
IN THAT PROCESS PARTICULARLY
NEGOTIATED PART OF. IT'S IN THE-
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES SOMETIMES
EOPLE WANT MORE THAN WE CAN
LEGALLY GIVE THEM IT'S A WE
HAVE TO WORK THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES BUT WHAT WE DO- THEM AT
ALL TIMES IT'S CLEAR
COMMUNICATION ON WHERE IT
STANDS WHERE WE ARE WHAT WE CAN
OR CAN'T DO IF THEY HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THAT I APOLOGIZE THAT.
THE TO YOU THESE ARE. OWNED
REVENUE. THESE END OF MAY OR
MAY NOT WANT TO DO THIS BUT- IF
THEY WOULD WANT TO ADD AS A
GROUP WOULD YOU AGREE TO COME
TO FRESNO AND HEAR THEIR
COMPLAINTS WITH ME. YES I'LL
HAVE TO FIND OUT WHETHER THEY-
ARE WILLING TO DO THAT BECAUSE
THEIR TRUST LEVELS IN YOUR
OPERATION ARE VERY VERY LOW BUT
LET ME SEE WHAT I MARKET I WORK
EVERY DAY TO IMPROVE THAT EVERY
DAY WELL WE ALL HOPE SO. THANK
YOU IF. MS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATE YOUR-
PUTTING THIS- HEARING TOGETHER
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE OF MISTER KELLY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AS WELL I HAVE
SOME COMMENTS FOR FIRST I DO
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU BASED
ON YOUR PRESENTATION- I AM AND
I AND I. I'M SORRY IF I MISSED
THE SOMEWHERE IN THE
DOCUMENTATION BUT WHEN THE
PROJECT IS COMPLETED AND
RUNNING MY SIMPLY THAT I MEAN
THE SECTION OF THE PROJECT NOT
THE ENTIRE PROJECT SO ONE
MERCED BAKERSFIELD SECTION IS
COMPLETE AND ELECTRIFIED- ARE
YOU WILL AMTRAK STILL BE
RUNNING. CONCURRENTLY ALONG
EITHER THIS RAIL OR ANOTHER
SECTION OF RAIL THROUGH THIS
AREA. THE PROPOSED A PLAN RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THEY WOULD NOT-
THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD
EXCLUSIVELY RUN SOUTH OF COURSE
AT. A TO BAKERSFIELD BUT I MUST
SAY THAT THAT. THAT
DETERMINATION IS GOING TO BE
PART OF AN OPERATING. OR MO YOU
AGREEMENT ON HOW- WE WOULD
ULTIMATELY WORKED OUT BUT BUT
THEY HAVE. A THE PLAN RIGHT NOW
IS A THERE WAS CERTAINLY NO NO
MORE THAN SEVERELY REDUCED-
SERVICE BUT RIGHT NOW THE
INTENTION IS FOR US TO RUNS OUT
THE PERCENT. AT THE BAKERSFIELD
FOR THEM TO RUN A NOR. DO THEY
HAVE TO AGREE TO THAT. A YEAH
BEALL TO BILLY THIS IS GONNA BE
AN OPERATION THAT THEY ARE IN
CHARGE WE'RE GONNA BE ASSET
OWNERS- OWNING THE ASSETS. OF A
WILL LEASE THE ASSETS FROM US-
TO OPERATE A HIGHER SPEED
ELECTRIFIED SERVICE- IN THAT
VALLEY- SO BUT YEAH I DON'T
REDO IT'S GOT TO BE REALLY PART
OF THEIR- BROADER OPERATIONAL
PLAN. I THINK SOME OF THIS IS.
UP OF THE LEADERSHIP OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S- JPA I THINK IS
INTERESTED IN- IN. FINDING
OTHER EFFICIENCIES LIKE A
SINGLE OPERATOR FOR ALL OF THE
SYSTEMS THAT THEY MAY. A
CONTRACT FOR AND AGAIN OUR
MODEL HERE IS THAT WE'RE ASSETS
OWNER ASSET OWNERS- BUT THEY
WOULD BE THE ONES TO DO- THE-
OF THE OPERATING ELEMENTS-
THROUGH. AN AGREEMENT WITH US
TO PAY. AT LEAST FOR ACCESS-
BUT THEN THEY WOULD- OF WORKING
THROUGH THE- OPERATING
ELEMENTS. THANK YOU- THAT'S THE
ONLY QUESTION I HAVE BUT I AM
GONNA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS AFTER
LISTENING TO. THE PRESENTATIONS
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE PRESENTERS IN THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR A VERY. IN DEPTH ANALYSIS.
AND I WOULD- ALSO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITHOUT MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE ANALYSIS
RAISES- AND THERE ARE MANY AND
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
MALL. BUT I THINK THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT DO
NEED TO BE- REALLY ADDRESSED-
YOU KNOW A FEW THINGS THAT I
HEARD TODAY I. KIND OF STRUCK
ME- ONE WAS- FROM- SECRETARY
KIM WHO. MENTIONED I THINK AT
LEAST ONCE MAYBE MORE THAN ONCE
THAT WE WERE ABANDONING
ELECTRIFICATION AND OR THAT
THERE IS A PROPOSAL TO ABANDON
ELECTRIFICATION. AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS SOMEONE WHO'S
READ THOSE WITH THOSE IDEAS AS
OPTIONS. I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
HAS TALKED ABOUT ABANDONING
ELECTRIFICATION THERE HAS BEEN
TALK ABOUT. HOW WHAT ON WHAT
SCHEDULE THE PROJECT WILL BE
COMPLETED AND I THINK THERE'S A
VERY BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SAYING THAT. SOMEHOW WE WOULD
DO HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE END
GOAL WILL BE TO NOT ELECTRIFY
IT. AS OPPOSED TO. A CONCEPT OF
COMPLETING DIFFERENT PHASES OF
THIS PROJECT- AND LEAVING
ELECTRIFICATION- FOR LATER
AFTER AS YOU AS YOU'VE HEARD
THE PROPOSAL THAT I HAVE MADE
AND OTHERS HAVE MADE. TO SHIFT
TO THE ELECTRIFICATION MONEY
INTO OTHER PARTS OF THE
pBACK TO ELECTRIFY THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM. AND THE REASON THAT I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT I WILL
SAY IS SOMEONE WHO IS.
CONTINUES TO BE A SUPPORTER OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA
AND THINK THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PROJECT THAT MY
BIGGEST FEAR ONE OF MY BIGGEST
FEARS FOR THIS PROJECT. IS THAT
WE CONTINUE WITH THE DOWN THE
PATH THAT WERE ON. AND COMPLETE
TO THE PROJECT AS YOU'VE HAD
THE OUTLINED IT. I THIS ONE
SECTION OF THE PROJECT IN THE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS. DON'T MATCH.
THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS THAT
YOUR- ANTICIPATING IN YOUR
BUSINESS PLAN. AND THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO BE SEEN TO HAVE SPENT
REALLY IN IN. HUGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHAT THE LARGEST AMOUNT
OF MONEY ON A SINGLE PROJECT
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
EVER DONE. AND A RIDERSHIP
NUMBERS FALL SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER THAN WHAT'S BEEN
PROJECTED AND THE PROJECT STOPS
AT THAT POINT. AND WE END UP
WITH. WHAT YOU COULD THINK OF
IS A BIT OF AN ORPHAN PROJECT
WITH THE ENTIRE PROJECT IS
NEVER COMPLETED. I STILL
DO SOME MORE ANALYSIS OF THE
ALTERNATIVE. OF INSTEAD OF
ELECTRIFYING OUT OF WORKING ON
THE PROJECTS THAT- IN THE
NORTHERN IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF THE STATE THAT WOULD THEN
LINK. THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO THE
BAY AREA. AND A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. INTO THE POPULATION
AREAS WHERE WE WERE I BELIEVE
WE WOULD HAVE A- BIGGER
INCREASE IN RIDERSHIP IN THOSE
AREAS TO SHOW THAT THERE IS
PUBLIC DEMAND. FOR ALTERNATIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND FOR RAIL
TRANSPORTATION. THEN I BELIEVE
THAT IT'S EASIER TO JUSTIFY
CONTINUING INVESTMENT IN THE
PROJECT. WHICH YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO ANYWAY BUT IF YOU
COMPLETE THIS SECTION. YOUR
RIDERSHIP FALLS BELOW
EXPECTATIONS AND I THINK WILL
BE VERY HARD. TO GO BACK TO THE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ASK THEM FOR A LARGE AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL. YOU INVESTING IN
THE PROPER. SOME OF THE OTHER
ASSERTIONS THAT I HEARD WAS YOU
KNOW A SECRETARY KIM WHEN HE
WAS SPEAKING ABOUT GHG
REDUCTIONS ABOUT THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTION SECTOR
BEING WITH THE ONE AREA WHERE
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION WITH GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS THAT'S ALL TRUE
BUT WE DON'T GET REDUCTIONS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS FROM
TRANSPORTATION BY SWITCHING
FROM DIESEL TO ELECT A LECTURE
CALL WE GET SOME SMALL AMOUNT.
WE GET ACTIONS AND GROUP HOUSE
GASES BY GETTING PEOPLE OF
AUTOMOBILES ON TO TRAINS THAT'S
WHERE YOU REALLY GET THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS AND I
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO. DO
A LOT MORE ANALYSIS ON THESE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS THEY ARE
BASED ON MULTIPLE TRIPS PER DAY
IN THE SYSTEM WE DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE RUNNING
THE AMOUNT OF TRAINS PER DAY.
THAT YOU'RE BASING YOUR
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS ON. I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE FULLY
EVALUATED THE IMPACT OF
TRANSFERS ON RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
AND WE'VE HEARD WE HEARD TODAY
FROM. OF DR BRIAN TAYLOR FROM
UCLA ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
TRANSFERS. A GIVEN THAT WERE
STILL UNCLEAR ABOUT. WHAT THE
TRANSFERS WILL MEAN IN TERMS OF
HOW MANY TRAINS A DAY THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO TRANSFER TO- THE
SPEED OF THOSE TRAINS. ALL OF
THAT IS STILL VERY UNCLEAR. I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO AT THIS
POINT HAVE A BIT OF A PAUSE FOR
WE ARE VALUE WAIT BILL. REALLY
SHINE A MICROSCOPE ON THOSE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS AND ON THE-
BASIS BY WHICH- THEY WERE
CALCULATED AYE I ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS IN THE LAST HEARING
THAT WE HAD WHEN WE ALL MET. IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I GET A
LOT OF WHAT I THOUGHT WERE
SATISFACTORY ANSWER OF WHERE
SOME OF THOSE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
WERE BEING GENERATED FROM AND
I'M NOT THAT THE ACTION STILL.
ARE IS TRUE RIGHT NOW IS THEY
WORK THE TERM. I KNOW I WOULD
TO SEE YOU KNOW A MORE DRILL
DOWN ON THAT- GIVEN THE CURRENT
CONFIGURATION OF THE PROJECT
THE TIME TABLE AND EVERYTHING
ELSE. AND LOOKING TO SEE IF
THOSE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS ARE
STILL JUSTIFIED. BECAUSE AGAIN
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT- THE- THE
NEXT STEP OF TRYING TO GET THE
NEXT ROUND OF FUNDING AFTER
THIS TO COMPLETE THIS PROJECT.
YEAH I IF WE HAVE A PROJECT
THAT ONLY RUNS FOR MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD YOU KNOW YOU SURE
THAT'S NOT HORRIBLE BUT THAT'S
NOT WHAT WAS TOLD TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S NOT WHAT
THEY WERE INVESTING IN WHEN
THEY VOTED FOR THIS PROPOSITION
THEY WERE VOTING FOR A SYSTEM
THAT GOES UP AND DOWN THE STE
FULL STATE OF CALIFORNIANS
CERTAINLY INTO THE BAY AREA.
AND I WOULD ARGUE YOUR OWN
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS ARE BASED ON
GETTING PEOPLE INTO THE BAY
AREA NOT JUST BETWEEN NOT JUST
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AS FAR AS I SEE IT AND I COULD
BE I MEAN IF I'M WRONG ABOUT
THAT PLEASE CORRECT. MY CONCERN
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE. OF A
FULL REPORT FROM YOU ON
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS- BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF TRIPS PER DAY THE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ANTICIPATING AT
THIS POINT ON THE DESTINATIONS.
ON WHATEVER WHATEVER OTHER
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT WE NEED THAT- WE
DESERVE THAT BEFORE WE GO
FORWARD AND WE DON'T WE ALSO
SHOULD HAVE SIDE BY SIDE WITH
THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS WILL BE
ON CLEANER THIRD GENERATION
DIESEL FAST TRAINS- WITH YOUR
NEW RULE- NEW TRACKS SO RATHER
THAN LOOKING AT RIDERSHIP
NUMBERS THAT ARE- SIMPLY EMPTY.
VERSUS HIGH SPEED RIGHT OF THIS
WHAT OTHER OPTION OF A SINGLE
SEAT RIDE FROM BAKERSFIELD ALL
THE WAY UP TO THE BAY AREA
VERSES THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
LECTER FIGHT HAVING TO CHANGE
TRAINS I THINK THAT'S REALLY
THE COMPARISON OF RIDERSHIP
THAT WE NEED TO SEE- BEFORE WE
DECIDE ON WHAT THIS INVESTMENT-
SHOULD BE GOING FORWARD. WORK
CRUCIAL STAGE IN THIS PROJECT
AND WHAT WE DO NOT IT'S GOING
TO HAVE A HUGE BEAR ON THE- OF
THIS PROJECT AND HOW. PLEASE
PEOPLE IN TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
LOOK BACK ON THE INVESTMENTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE AND
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GET THIS
WRONG. ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING.
THE AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING OF
AT THIS POINT AND HOW EVERY
DOLLAR THAT'S SPENT IS GOING TO
BE SCRUTINIZED. THIS YEAR AND
NEXT YEAR GOING FORWARD WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN JUST
BY EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR AND
WHERE THOSE INVESTMENTS GO. AND
I WOULD STILL ARGUE THAT
THERE'S A BIG CASE TO BE MADE
FOR INVESTING MORE IN. LAYING
THE FUTURE OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
IN OUR POPULATION CENTERS WHILE
ALSO ENJOYING THE CO BENEFITS.
OF HAVING MUCH BETTER IMPROVE
SERVICE FOR. RELATIONS CENTERS.
AND GETTING A LOT MORE PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR CARS- AND- GETTING
PEOPLE THEMSELVES DEMAND.
BETTER TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITHOUT I WILL
YIELD MY TIME BACK IN THANK YOU
AND- A MISTER CHAIR. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER KELLY
FOR BEING HERE. I JUST HAD SOME
QUESTIONS DIRECTED AT THE
POTENTIAL LEGAL RISKS THAT THIS
PROJECT MIGHT BE FACING- IN
PARTICULAR. WHETHER CERTAIN
ASPECTS OF THE BUSINESS PLAN
MIGHT CONFLICT WITH THE
EXPLICIT LANGUAGE OF. THE PROP
ONE A BOND ACT THAT WITH THE
VOTERS APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT- AND I WANT TO START BY
READING- QUOTING FROM. TWO
SECTIONS OF PROPOSITION ONE A-
OF THE BOND ACT. THAT
AUTHORIZED. ENDING STATE BONDS
ON HIGH SPEED RAIL- ONE SECTION
SAYS QUOTE THE PLAN PASSENGER
TRAIN SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY
THE AUTHORITY. OR PURSUANT TO
ITS AUTHORITY. WILL NOT REQUIRE
OPERATING SUBSIDY. A SUBSEQUENT
PASSAGE STATES THAT OF A
PARTIAL SEGMENT ACCORD OR IS TO
BE BUILT THEN QUOTE THE PLANNED
A PASSENGER SERVICE BY THE
AUTHORITY IN THE CORRIDOR OR
USABLE SEGMENT THERE OF. WILL
NOT REQUIRE A LOCAL STATE OR
FEDERAL OPERATING SUBSIDY. THAT
APPEARS TO ME TO BE A FAIRLY
EXPLICIT BAN ON TAXPAYER
OPERATING SUBSIDIES. SO MY
FIRST QUESTION OF YOU TODAY IS
WILL THE PLANNED INITIAL
SEGMENT FROM ARE SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD. REQUIRE AN ONGOING
OPERATING SUBSIDY FROM THE
TAXPAYERS YES OR NO. YES BUT
LOWER THAN WHAT THE TAXPAYERS
ARE PAYING TODAY. DOES THAT
CAUSE CONCERN FOR YOU OR YOUR
LAWYERS THAT ARE ADVISING YOU
THAT IF. AS YOU JUST SAID IT
WILL REQUIRE AN OPERATING SAYS
SUBSIDY DOES THAT DOES THAT NOT
CONFLICT WITH THE EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE I JUST READ FROM THE
PROPOSITION ONE A BOND. I DON'T
THINK SO I THINK SO MISTER
CUNNINGHAM OF THE REASON THAT
WE DON'T THINK SO IS BECAUSE-
UNDER THE MODEL THAT WE'RE
USING THE VALLEY WE ARE NOT THE
OPERATOR- WE WOULD WE ALL WE
ALL THE ASSETS. THAT WOULD BE
LEAST BY ANOTHER PUBLIC ENTITY
WHO WILL CONTRACT WITH AN
OPERATOR- TO RUN THE SYSTEM.
AND SO- THAT IS NOT- OPERATED
BY US AND JUST. I THINK PROVIDE
A FAIR. SORT OF COMPARISON HERE
ON SOMETHING THAT'S HAPPENING
TODAY. BUT IN CALIFORNIA BOTH
WITH THE- RECOGNITION AND EVEN
THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. IS YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW WE USE PROP ONE EIGHT
DOLLARS- TO ELECTRIFY THE
SEGMENT. OF THE CALTRAIN CORD
OR THE BAY AREA- BUT- THE
INCUMBENT OPERATOR IS OPERATING
ON THAT SYSTEM. BUT NOT US- IN
SO- IN THAT CASE WERE USING
PROP ONE EIGHT DOLLARS TO
ELECTRIFY. A SEGMENT IN THE BAY
AREA TO PROVIDE ELECTRIFIED
SERVICE PROVIDED BY ANOTHER-
AND THAT'S NOT A VERY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE ARE. PROPOSING THE
CELL IN THE- IN THE ABSENT
ABOUT. SO IT DOES NOT BECAUSE
YOU OR YOUR LEGAL TEAM
CONCERNED THAT THE- PROP ONE A
BOND ACT LANGUAGE SAYS- TRAIN
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY THE
AUTHORITY. FOR PURSUANT TO ITS
AUTHORITY. SO IF YOU'RE YEAH I
THINK THAT REFERENCE TO
PURSUANT TO ITS AUTHORITY- AND
I'M YOU KNOW I'M NOT A LAWYER-
BUT I THINK IT IS A REFERENCE
TO. A SECTION OF LAW THAT SAYS
YOU KNOW THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS SORT OF OUR MODEL
FORTY UP UNDER THE- CALIFORNIA
STATUTES FOR ANY DRAIN SERVICE
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILES PER HOUR. SO I THINK
THAT'S THE REFERENCE THERE- BUT
AGAIN IT'S WE'RE NOT RELYING ON
THAT AUTHORITY TO. PROVIDE
SERVICE HERE WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS- WE'RE GONNA BILLS OF ASSETS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
TO PUT INTO USE A RELATIVELY
SOON. UP AND- THROUGH A- WITH
THAT EXISTING PROVIDER THOSE
ASSETS CAN ELECTRIFIED THAT
PROVIDE. I CAN'T PROVIDE
SERVICE ON THAT SYSTEM WHICH
AGAIN IS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE AREA WITH A
CALTRAIN. OKAY IT DOES NOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE TEAM SOME STERN
THE- THIS COULD BE VIEWED AS A
WORK AROUND AROUND THE EXPLICIT
LANGUAGE OF THAT I JUST READ OF.
THE AUTHORIZING BOND ACT
BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING WELL.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTRACT WITH
THE THIRD PARTY AND LET THE
THIRD PARTY OPERATED THEREFORE
WE CAN USE TAX- SUBSIDIES TO
OPERATE IT. I AND I WOULD NOTE
YEAH THAT YET AGAIN TO BE FAIR
SICKENING TAXPAYERS ARE
SUBSIDIZING. THE SAN JOAQUIN
SERVICE TODAY. THAT A DIESEL
SERVICE AT THE JUNE OF EIGHTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. AND
WHAT WHAT WE ARE NUMBERS SHOW
THAT IF- WORKING WAS SAN
JOAQUIN'S TO IMPROVE THE
SERVICE ELECTRIFYING THAT
SECTION. AND THEM AS OPERATOR
OR OTHER PUBLIC ENTITY WHO IS A
CONTRACTING WITH THE OPERATOR.
OF PROVIDING THAT SERVICE IS
NOT A QUIRK AROUND IT'S IN
COMPLIANCE WITH PROP ONE DAY
WAS THAT AND SO WITH NATURAL IN
COURT DO YOU HAVE A LEGAL
OPINION THAT SAYS THAT THAT
WAS- CONSISTENT WITH THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BOND ACT. IT IS
NOT A- IT'S NOT JONES. SO I.
THAT THIS THIS NEW PLAN WILL
GET CHEN AND WORRY ABOUT THA
BECAUSE TODAY THERE WAS AN LA
TIMES ARE. WORK KOPP. OF FORMER
STATE SENATOR A RETIRED JUDGE.
WHO WAS THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. HE SAID INTO THE LA
TIMES TODAY AND I QUOTE IT
DEFIES THE BALLOT MEASURE
APPROVED BY VOTERS. AND YOU
ALSO SAID THERE WILL BE A
LAWSUIT AND I WANT TO BE THE
LEAD PLAINTIFF. I THINK YOU'VE
GOT A POTENTIALLY CHALLENGE
COMING AND SO THAT LEADS TO MY
NEXT QUESTION. WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
BUSINESS PLAN. AND A COURT
RULES AGAINST THE AUTHORITY
THAT. THE BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED
LINE IS NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THE
BOND FUNDS WOULD WOULD YOU HAVE%
WHAT WHAT HAPPENS THEN DO YOU
HAVE A CONTINGENCY PLAN. I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT IF THEY'RE- IN
AGAIN WE FEEL PRETTY
COMFORTABLE NOT WAS STANDING
WITH. A JUDGE COP. AHEAD IS A I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH HE KNOWS
ABOUT THE- STRUCTURE OF THE- OF
THE PROGRAM IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- THE IDEA THAT WE ARE
NOT THE OPERATOR I THINK THAT'S
A- AN IMPERATIVE POINT. I THINK
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL TO ALL
OF THIS- SO- YOU KNOW I DO I
DON'T KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF.
YOU KNOW. SORT OF- IF THERE ARE
YOU KNOW I SUPPOSE. LOOK THIS
PROJECT HAS BEEN THROUGH A LOT
OF LEGAL CHALLENGE OVER THE
YEARS- LEGAL CHALLENGE ABOUT
HOW IT WAS BEING SPENT HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED. ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES AND- YOU KNOW WE
WORK THROUGH THEM- WHICH
SETTLED ALL LITIGATION ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FRONT TODAY. AND
WE BUILT ON CIVIL COURT WHICH
IS. A TODAY OF. UP THERE IS
THAT WE'RE FOR SO I HAVE A
CONTINGENCY PLAN TO MY BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT I'M NOT SURE WE
NEED TO GO DOWN THAT ROAD I. WE
FEEL LIKE WE ARE. MEETING THE
LETTER OF THE LAW CERTAINLY A
PROP ON A. AND THAT THIS MODEL
BY THE WAY. NOT A MODEL THAT
THEN PASSENGER TRAIN SERVICE
INTO TODAY EXIT AM LEASES
TRACKS FRIGHT. THE ACE LEASE
TRACK FROM RAIL OTHERS THE SAME
ALL THE DENTIST CAL IN THIS
CASE WE ARE BILL. THOSE TRACKS
WE OWE THAT THE OPERATIVE FOR
THEM TO LEAST THAT AND THE
OPERATE SPEED RAIL SERVICE AN
INTERN MATTER AND WE GET BUILD
A SYSTEM THAT WE DESN'T
REQUIRE. THE SUBSIDY AND THEN
WE WILL BECOME A MORE DIRECT
OPERATOR IN SO IT'S AN INTERIM
SERVICE AND AGAIN THIS MODEL IS
BEING EXECUTED OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE TODAY. SO WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM ME THOUGH IS THAT
WHILE WE'RE DOING IT IN OTHER
PLACES SO IT MUST BE CORRECT
BUT YOU JUST SAID THAT IT'S
NEVER BEEN CHALLENGED IN COURT
BEFORE AND OF THIS TYPE OF
LEGAL CHALLENGES DIFFERENT THAN
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWSUIT THIS GOES
TO THE FUNDAMENTAL. VOTERS BUT
THEY WERE. TOLD HAPPEN AND WHAT
THE TOLD WOULD HAVE INTO EIGHT
WHEN THEY VOTE. TO ENACT THE
PROP ONE A BOND ACT. TO BUILD
THIS HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS
THAT TAXPAYER MONEY WOULD NOT
BE USED FOR OPERATING SUBSIDY.
THAT'S AT LEAST AS I READ THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE OR SO I SUGGEST
YOU HAVE A LAWSUIT COMING. SO
YOU MAY WANT TO COULD DEVELOP A
CONTINGENCY PLAN. FOR BECAUSE
IN MY VIEW AS AN ATTORNEY AND
IN THE VIEW OF CLINTON COP WHO
WAS AFTER ALL THE FORMER
CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS- YOU'VE GOT A
PROBLEM. ON THE LEGAL AND- OF I
DON'T KNOW WHICH LAWYERS YOU'RE
TALKING TO BUT I THEY SHOULD BE
TELLING YOU YOU GOT A PROBLEM.
SO THE OTHER THING YOU COULD DO
IS GIVEN THE LEGAL UNCERTAINTY
AND THEREFORE THE LEGAL RISK
AND THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THIS IS IN
A SMALL THING. ARE YOU COULD
FIRST SEEK LEGAL CLARIFICATION
EITHER FROM THE COURTS. FOR
LEGISLATIVE CLARIFICATION AS TO
THE INTENT OF THE BOND LANGUAGE
BECAUSE AFTER ALL IT WAS THE
LEGISLATURE THE PUT THE BOND ON
THE BALLOT. AND WE HAVE A BILL
THAT WE JUST MOVED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT WOULD. CLARIFY
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT. AND
WHAT IT WOULD SAY IF IT WAS
ENACTED INTO LAW. IS UP THAT
THIS LANGUAGE MEANS WHAT IT
SAYS AND YOU CAN'T DO A WORK
AROUND BY PUTTING SOMEONE
ELSE'S DECALS ON THE TRAIN. AND
SAY THAT THERE THE OPERATOR. UP
SO. I YELP FORTUNATELY I
REMEMBER FIRST. SORRY WELL I
MEAN TO BE TOTALLY CANDID I
MEAN. YOU KNOW. IT IT AT MY
CENTRAL CO NOBODY'S EVER AYE
THIS ALL PAY FOR FOREVER THE-
AS OTHER QUESTIONS APPOINT OUT
THE CO OVER ON THIS. OR STAFF.
AND ONYX THE SCOPES BEING
SCALED DOWN THE COST GOES UP
EVERYTIME WE TURN AROUND- I
WOULD BE PERFECTLY CONTENT AS
WITH MOST OF MY CONSTITUENTS IF
YOU LOST THIS LEGAL CHALLENGE.
BUT IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
MAKING IT WORK I THINK YOU NEED
TO DRILL DOWN ON THESE ISSUES
OR LET THE LEGISLATURE TAKE THE
LEAD IN CLARIFYING THE LAW
MEANS ORGANIT. THE CLERK
JUDGMENT FROM THE COURT THAT
SAYS THAT YOU CAN PROCEED IN A
MANNER THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE BOND ACT BECAUSE I
PERSONALLY DO NOT BELIEVE
YOU'RE DOING THAT. I THINK
THOSE OP OR OPTIONS WE- WE MAY
CONSIDER. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME SIR APPRECIATE. YOU.
THE REVERSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND THANKS TO BOTH
SECRETARY CAM AND TO YOU-
MISTER KELLY FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ALSO FOR
ENGAGING WITH US AS LEGISLATORS
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO RESPOND- TO AN END
QUESTION OF THE PROPOSED DRAFT
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN AND BY
ASKING QUESTIONS- IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT WE'RE
TURNING OUR BACK ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT IN OUR YOU
KNOW THAT ARE VOTERS APPROVED-
BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE PROJECT DOES PROVIDE
THE MOST OVERALL BENEFIT TO OUR
STATE IN ON TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
I'M ESPECIALLY BY REPLACING
AUTUMN WILL AUTOMOBILE TRIPS BY
PASSENGER RAIL TRIPS RIGHT
WHICH IS THE OVERALL GOAL LIKE-
MY COLLEAGUE MS FRIEDMAN
BROUGHT UP EARLIER AND SO I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO
COMMENT ON THAT- BUT- YOU
MENTIONED THE KPMG REPORT. AND
THAT ALL DUE TO MOVE IT THE ART
OF WAS EXTENDED FOR THE TRADE
IN SYSTEMS PROCUREMENT I DO YOU
HAVE OR TRACK SORRY YEAH DO YOU
HAVE A DAY A NEW REVISED STATE
I BELIEVE IT WAS ORIGINALLY
SEPTEMBER WHEN YOU INTENDED. TO
PROCURE THAT CONTRACT OR PUT
OUR REGION RIGHT. YES A
PROPOSAL FOR WERE ORIGINALLY
DOING JUNE AND THEN A DECISION
BY. OUR BOARD. OR NOT TO X.
THOSE IN SEPTEMBER AND NOW WE
PUSH THOSE BACK TO SIT. OKAY SO
MY QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT THAT
CONTRACT IN THE IN THE PROCESS
SO ACCORDING TO YOUR BUSINESS
PLAN. OF AND THERE'S A SECTION
F. WERE THAT DISCUSSES THE
RISKS- AND YOUR CONSULTANT-
WRITES THE TRACKING SYSTEMS
CONTRACTOR IS ENVISIONED TO BE
THE KEY LONG TERM CONTRACTOR.
OF THE AUTHORITY OVER A PERIOD
OF FORTY OR MORE YEARS I WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING.
THE ENTIRE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM IS AVAILABLE TO THE
OPERATOR. AS A RESULT IT WILL
BE THE MOST IMPORTANT CONTRACT
TO THE AUTHORITY AND INCLUDES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RISK
TRANSFER INCLUDING INTERFACE
RISK WITH OTHER CONTRACTORS.
AND ADDITIONAL SCOPE OF FUTURE
SEGMENTS. OF SO THIS APPEARS TO
BE A VERY SERIOUS VERY
IMPORTANT CONTRACT YOU'RE
PLANNING TO ENTER WITH. AND
EVEN FURTHER KPMG STATES AS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT ALSO
REQUIRES MAINTENANCE AND
LIFECYCLE PAYMENTS ONCE REVENUE
SERVICE COMMENCES. THIS PAYMENT
WOULD BE REQUIRED REGARDLESS OF
THE LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT IS
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE INTERIM
SERVICES AND THE CONTRACTOR
WILL HAVE TERMINATION RIGHTS
UNDER THE CONTRACT. EITHER
REVENUE SERVICE DOES NOT START.
SO GIVEN THIS IM KPMG
RECOMMENDS THEREFORE PRIOR TO
THE EXECUTION OF THE TRACKING
SYSTEMS CONTRACT IT'S IMPORTANT
SECURE A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. THE SUN HIKING RELATIVE
ALREADY AND OTHER RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE USE OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL ASSETS UNTIL THE
COMPLETION OF VALLEY TO VALLEY.
SO IT SEEMS YOU'RE STILL MOVING
FORWARD WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION CONCERNS FROM
THIS CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN YOUR RATIONALE FOR
ENTERING. INTO THIS CONTRACT
DESPITE THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'RE CONSULTANT- WROTE ABOUT.
YES I THINK THE REST THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THAT REFINED
BUSINESS CASE STUDY BY A KPMG
WERE SPOT ON- AND WHAT THE
CONSULTANT IS SAYING TO US IS-
THAT- WE SHOULD MAKE SURE. THAT
WE HAVE AT LEAST ENTERED AN
AMMO YOU- WITH THE ENTITIES
THAT WOULD BE INVOLVED IN THE
LEASE PAYMENTS A TO USE OUR
**** TO SURE- THAT OUR COSTS
FOR A THINGS LIKE MAINTENANCE-
ARE- ARE ARE COVERED BY THAT-
BY THAT LEASE AGREEMENT AND
THAT THAT- THE COMMITMENT TO-
TO- COVER THOSE COSTS IS. A
WILL BE PART AND PARCEL OF THE
OF THE ALTERNATE FINAL
AGREEMENT THAT WE WILL- ENTER
TO WITH WITH ANY OPERATOR YEAH
AND- WELL I THINK THAT'S RIGHT
AND- WE ARE- AT THE BEGINNING
OF A OF THAT THAT- KIND OF WORK
IN THAT COMMUNICATION. BOTH
WITH THEM- THE- SAN JOAQUIN TO
FOLKS. AND THE- CAL OF FOLKS
THAT JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S UNDERSTOOD. OKAY SO I
YOU KNOW FROM THIS REPORT KPMG
PROVIDES- ITS OWN EXPLANATION
FOR WHY. YOU MAY BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE CONTRACT AND
STATES THE TRACKING SYSTEM
CONTRACT HAS A MECHANISM FOR
DETERMINING THE CAPITAL COST OF
ALL SEGMENTS AFTER THE FIRST
SEGMENT. WHICH INCLUDES A
BASKET OF INDEXATION FACTORS
RELATING TO INFLATION FOR LABOR
AND MATERIALS. SO THIS COULD
INCENTIVIZE THE AUTHORITY TO
TAKE ADDITIONAL RISK BY ISSUING
A NOTICE TO PROCEED PREMATURELY
IN ORDER TO SECURE. A LOWER
PRICE DOES THAT SOUND RIGHT TO
YOU OR WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS. BE CLEAR NOT IT'S BEEN
A WHILE STILL LOOK AT THAT
SPECIFIC SECTION OF THAT
REPORT- BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT ONE. OF GETTING THE MO YOU
IN PLACE PRIOR TO THE EXCUSE OF
THE CONTRACT IS A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION OF ONE OF THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON. OF A AND B.
THAT THE CONTRACT IS STRUCTURED
IN A WAY WHERE- IT'S ALL SET ON
NOTICES TO PERCY- THE FIRST
NOTICE TO PROCEED IS GETTING
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
TRACK. PUT DOWN AND THE REASON
THAT WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT IS BECAUSE THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT UNDER OUR FEDERAL
FUND A FUNDING AGREEMENT. BUT
TO GET THIS WORK COMPLETED BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND SO THERE'S A REASON FOR US
TO MOVE FORWARD ON THE CONTRACT
I THINK THE PROTECTION ELEMENT
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE IS- OUR
BOARD PUBLICLY ASKED TO
APPROVE. THE NEXT NTP IT EACH
AND BE UP BEFORE WE DO IT'S OR
BOARD WILL HAVE A CHANCE WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC DISCUSSION-
IN OUR HEARINGS ABOUT. THE IS
IT READY IS FUNDING AVAILABLE-
IS THE WORK ON THE GROUND DONE
TO ENABLE THIS WORK TO BE DONE.
EVERY OF THAT THE IS ANOTHER
NOTICE TO PROCEED ANTI. THAT
HAS TO GO TO WAR WAR. AND THEY
WILL NOT A PER IT HELLO BINDING
IS A- AND THE WORK ON THE- IS
COMPLETED TO DO TO A TO EXECUTE
THAT WORK SO WE ARE IN A PLACE
WHERE WE HAVE TO TRY TO GET THE
TRACK DOWN WE GOTTA GET. A
TRACK CONTRACT THE GOING
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT TO DO SO THAT'S
JUST ONE HUNDRED NINETY MILES
AND THAT HE THE FOR MILES. OF
THIS PENDING CONTRA. BUT EVERY.
THING IS A SECTION NOTICED A
PER. THAT NOT GO FORWARD IF
WE'RE NOT. OF READY TO MOVE AND
SO I THINK THERE'S A BILL TO BE
CAUTIOUS APPROACH AS WE AS WE
GO FOR. WHY AT THE SAME TIME
GETTING THE TRACK. ON THE
GROUND. OR PURSE. TO OUR
FEDERAL FOR. AND I WOULD SAY
ONE THE THINGS IS. I KNOW IT'S
BEEN CONVERSE. ABOUT WHETHER
THE SHOULD BE. ELECTRIFIED OR
SYSTEM OR NOT. IN OUR VIEW. OF
THE SHOULD BE A CONSIST WITH
THE- RITUAL FOR PLAN. FOR THIS
ACT THAT WAS. BY IN TWENTY AND
IT'S ALSO BECAUSE OF THE WAY
CAN JUST. A SYSTEMS SELECT
SYSTEM AND TO TRY. A ITS MOST
EFFICIENT. THE TO DO THAT BUT
TOGETHER IN PUT DOWN TRACK OF
THE COME BACK LATER. THE END UP
KNOW DIG UNDER THE THAT TRACK
TO DO. JUST ELECTRIFICATION. SO
THAT THAT IS HOW WE HAVE
PROPOSED BUT I THINK THE
SEPARATE ANTI. GIVE AS A OF THE
PART. OF THE OF NOT GOING TO
TOO FAST. SO YOU. THAT YOU THAT
THE AND YOU. IS A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION AND DIESEL. FROM
ALL OTHER RISKS THAT WERE
OUTLINED IN THIS REPORT. DO YOU
INTEND TO REVIEW THEM AND- AND
DISCUSS THEM EITHER WITH THE
BOARD. OR OTHERS. BEFORE. THE
CONTRACT. YES AND NOT ALL THE
REST OF THE- OR TYPES. TO THE
THAT SO THERE ARE. A REST THE
WE HAVE TO. BUT WE SHOULD HAVE
BE MY OF THE AND IT WORKED
THROUGH SO FUN AND OTHER. SO
AGAIN. UP LOOK UP. WE ARE GOING
TO BE PRUDENT HEARING WE GO I
SAID UP EARLIER PRESENT. THAT
CERTAINLY THE TIMES AND ALL
THAT'S GOING ON THE COLD
NINETEEN WHICH MEMBERS HAVE. A
REFERENCE REQUIRE US TO BE
EXCEEDINGLY PRUDENT AND HOW WE
GO. I PUSHING BACK THE THIS GOD
WAS OF THE PRUDENCE I THINK. OF
WE'RE GOING TO DO A DEEPER DIVE.
ALL OF OUR IN OUR NOW IT ENSURE
THAT WE ARE IN A GOOD PLACE TO
MOVE AS WE- HERE INTO. AGAIN
THE BUSINESS PLAN LAID OUT.
WHAT WE THOUGHT THE BEST PATH
FORWARD WAS ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH
THAT WAS A LITTLE BIT IN FRONT
OF THE WORLD CHANGING
DRAMATICALLY. ADOPTED HAS-
WHILE WE- STILL THINK THAT THIS
IS THE- BEST APPROACH GOING
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE
TIME. TO DO A DEEPER DIVE AND
MAKE SURE. THAT WE'RE DOING
THIS CORRECTLY. NO MY CAN WITH
YOU KNOW THESE POTENTIAL RISKS
ARE. THAT YOU KNOW YOU WOULD
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR MORE FUNDING RIGHT AND
THAT. THIS PROJECT CONTINUES.
OF TO BE MUCH MORE- THAN WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE- AND SO.
THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS YOU KNOW
IF YOU STICK TO THE BUSINESS
PLAN THAT YOU HAVE. DRAFTED I
KNOW OTHERS HAVE COMMENTED ON.
YOU KNOW POTENTIAL TURN
ADDITIVES- THAT YOU MAY BE
EXPLORING- IN BUT- I THINK. YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THE RISKS ARE BEING TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. AND THAT WE DO
NOT ENGAGE IN TO A FORTY YEAR
CONTRACT RIGHT. BEFORE
ANALYZING THESE RISKS AND THE
POTENTIAL. OF **** IN.
ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT YOU WILL
LATER RETURN TO US TO APPROVE.
AGAIN I GENERALLY CONCUR WITH
THAT SENTIMENT INDICT THERE'S
MORE THAT WE NEED TO SAY. ABOUT
THE HOW WE ARE. ANALYZING THE
WRIST TED TO THAT- YOU KNOW- I
WANT TO CONSIDER THAT AND THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE- HOW WE ADDRESS
THAT THE EITHER THE FINAL A
BUSINESS PLAN OR BEYOND. YEAH
SO IT I THINK IT LEGISLATORS
WERE PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
PROJECT WERE ACTIVISTS ACTIVELY
SEEKING- POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES
OR WHETHER THE CURRENT.
BUSINESS PLAN IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO IMPLEMENT THE VISION OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN OUR STATE OF YOU
KNOW THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST IN
THE COUNTRY- IF IT- IF YOU'RE
TIMELINE IS CORRECT OR I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME PRIVATE. OTHER
PRIVATE ONES THAT ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT DEAL LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THE VIRGIN TRAINS-
BUT- YOU KNOW. WHEN WE STARTED
THIS THERE WAS A BIG VISION FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA-
IN OUR COUNTRY- BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT- IT IS DONE. OF
EFFICIENTLY AND YOU KNOW
DESPITE LIKE YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT THERE ARE.
CONSTRUCTION STARTED BEFORE THE
RIGHT OF WAYS AND YOU KNOW I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE NEW TO THIS
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE ARE CONTINUING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR CALIFORNIA AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ACTIVE AND
ASK QUESTIONS AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR AGAIN FOR
ENGAGING WITH US AND ESPECIALLY
IN THE ASSEMBLY WHICH- WE HAVE
BROUGHT UP. A LOT OF CONCERNS
AND WANT TO SEE OTHER PROJECT
ALL. THANK YOU. UNDER THANK YOU
SO IN. RIGHT AND I OF THE- OF
THE LEGISLATURE THIS IT'S
PROGRAM. ASSEMBLYMEMBER I THANK
YOU I'D DIRECTOR I MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB
OF COVERING A LOT OF THE REALLY
INCREDIBLE PROBLEMS FACING THIS
PROJECT ON WHAT I WANTED TO ASK
YOU IS GIVEN THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE AUTHORITY OVER THE LAST
DECADE AND ALSO GIVEN THE
EMERGING TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE NOW IN
DEVELOPMENT AND THERE ON THE
HORIZON. IF CALIFORNIA WAS
STARTING FROM SCRATCH TODAY
LET'S SAY WE ARE ONLY NOW
CONSIDERING WHETHER TO BUILD A
HIGH SPEED TRAIN SERVICE FROM
NORTHERN TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WOULD YOU RECOMMEND
UNDERTAKING THAT PROJECT. I
ABSOLUTELY WOULD AND THE REASON
I WOULD IS. I'VE BEEN PLAYING
IN TRANSPORTATION POLICY FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN A SINGLE
PROJECT THAT OFFERS AS MUCH AS
THIS ONE DOES- IN FULL BUILD
OUT- IN TERMS OF MOBILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS ALL IN ONE PROJECT
THERE IS NO DOUBT. THAT THIS
PROJECT IS EXPENSIVE AND WILL
TAKE A LONG TIME AND THAT WAS
TRUE THE DAY WAS ON THE BALLOT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE
VOTERS PROVIDED NINE BILLION
FOR A PROJECT ESTIMATED TO COST
FORTY FIVE BILLION. 20% OF WHAT
WE NEED SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE
WATER OUT IN REGARD FEDERAL
FUNDS AND WE'VE GOT ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDS THROUGH CAP AND
TRADE- BUT I CAN'T YOU CANNOT
BUILD ANOTHER FREEWAYS IN
CALIFORNIA OR EXPAND ENOUGH
AIRPORTS IN CALIFORNIA. TO
REDUCE TRAVEL TIMES LIKE THIS
PROJECT CAN DO OF THE IDEA THAT
WE CAN MOVE UP FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES OR AND
I IN ABOUT THREE HOURS AS
OPPOSED TO DRIVING IT AND SEVEN
OR EIGHT. OR AS OPPOSED TO
TAKING TRADITIONAL A RAIL THAT
TAKES THIRTEEN HOURS- THAT'S
WHY I WANTED TO THE PROJECT AND
THE ICING ON THE CAKE FOR ME ON
THIS IS THE ECONOMIC. OF THE IT
WENT SO PEOPLE TO. THOU FIFTY
THAT. RATED TODAY. OVER TWO
HUNDRED THAT IF WE DO MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD PEAS OF HYPE JOB
IT'S A VAMP. OF ANY BY BENEFITS
ARE TERRIFIC IS NOT ON IS THIS
A LOT. WE HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
USING RENEWABLE SOURCE OF POWER
SO THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT I
AM A SUPPORTER AND I WOULD I
WOULD ADVOCATE TO POLICY MAKERS
TO CONTINUE. TO TRY TO BUILD AN
INTERCITY INTER REGIONAL
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM TO GIVE CALIFORNIANS A
BETTER OPTIONS TO TRAVEL AROUND
THE STATE NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
SO THE DEVELOPMENT OF OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE AYE HYPERLOOP
TO TAKE ONE EXIT ROAD SYSTEM
THANK WILL A COMP THE
OBJECTIVES ARE MUCH. THAN
HIGHEST RAIL THAT WOULD CHANGE
OUTLOOK WHAT I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THE DEVELOPER OF HYPER BUT YOU
TALK ABOUT. I THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. A PROVEN
TECHNOLOGY AND THIS IS PROVEN I
MEAN THIS IS OPERATING IN EVERY
MAJOR OF ECONOMIC- POWER IN THE
WORLD EXCEPT HERE OF YOU KNOW
HIGH SPEED ELECTRIFIED RAIL-
AND SO- THIS IS A PROVEN
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS IMMENSE
BENEFITS FOR THE STATE AND THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN IT- AND SO
YES I WOULD HYPERLOOP I HOPE
THAT CONTINUES TO DEVELOP. MY
PERSONAL VIEW ON IT RIGHT NOW
IT'S JUST MY PERSONAL VIEW IS
THAT I THINK ITS APPLICATION IS
PROBABLY BETTER FOR GOODS
MOVEMENT THAT PEOPLE MOVEMENT
AT LEAST AT THIS POINT- UNTIL
WE SEE MORE OF- EXACTLY HOW
THAT WILL WORK BUT THAT'S
THAT'S MY SENSE BUT NOW. YOU
KNOW ALONG THE LINES OF YOUR
ACTION ON TECHNOLOGY I KNOW
OTHERS HAVE SAID THINGS OF LIKE
WHAT ABOUT A THOMAS VEHICLES
YEAH YOU KNOW I ALSO SUPPORT OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF A THOMAS OF
VEHICLES BUT THOSE VEHICLES OP
ON HIGHWAYS THEY'RE NOT GOING
TRAVELED TO MILES PER HOUR IN
SO AGAIN SO BENEFITS THAT YOU
COULD. OUT OF THIS OLD PRIDE TO
ME A IS STILL WELL WORK OF THE
GAS IT'S THIS. BEEN PART OF
THIS. THE PLOT TO WORK. THE I.
IF WE HAVE A GLUT WILL TO GET
IT DONE I DO J. TO COME OF US
FOR. THANK YOU. MR I APPRECIATE
YOUR MEGAN AND WITH US I THANK
YOU MISTER I DO HAVE TO
PANELISTS THAT LIKE TO GET THE
QUEUE. THEN YOU AND I CAN A
QUESTION ANSWER BUT I WANT TO
RISK THEIR TIME IN THE BEEN
JACKSON ALSO SO YEP LET'S MOVE
ON. REGULAR TO QUEUE UP YOU MAY
HAVE ONE THERE ARE. TIME WITH
BEGAN. ONE HOW INTERESTING CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OKAY YOU HEAR ME.
YEAH YES WE. OKAY WONDERFUL
GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER MY NAME
HELEN FOR ABILITY AND OFFICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ME TO AS
AFTER AND ALL ALLOW YOU TO
PARTICIPATE I REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY. AND SO IN MARCH
OFFICE RELEASED A REPORT WE A
WHEN TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN IN
THAT REPORT WE IDENTIFY BY MAIN
OVER ISSUE RELATED
CONSIDERATION ALL TRY TO SUMMER
AND BRIEFLY I'M THAT THAT THE
OUR GETTING KIND OF LATER I BUT
HOW CARE ALSO ENTER QUESTION TO
AND AS WELL AND FOR THE FIRST
EVER TAKE ISSUE THAT WE BROUGHT
UP IN A ROOM IS THAT THE CRIME
SCHEDULE APPEAR TO BE AN- AND
AMBITIOUS BOTH IN THE NEW TERM
AND THE LONG TERM. YOUR TURN.
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT
AND JUST CON I AND WE DO. YOUR
CITY PATENT AROUND BY TWENTY
TWENTY YOU ON AND THEY NEED TO
TAKE THAT APPROACH BECAUSE
THERE HAVE BEEN DELAYS THAT ARE
WHICH MEANS THAT THE FULL-
ACQUISITION ALL THE CARD READER
NEEDED PRETTY INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT ABOUT THE
CIVIL WAR BE COMPLETED BEFORE
THE ATTACK AND DEFEND
CONTRACTOR NEED TO BEGIN WORK I
TO WHAT THIS APPROACH IS
EXPECTED TO EXPEDITE THE
COMPLETION OF THE CONTRACT IT
WILL AND IT'S EXPECTED TO ADD
SIGNIFICANT COMPLEXITY. AND
RAISE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONTRACT. WE WOULD KNOW THAT
EVEN WITH MORE COMPLEX APPROACH
ARE THERE ISN'T MUCH WIGGLE
ROOM IN THE IN THE SCHEDULE FOR
THE PROJECT- FEDERAL GRANT
DEADLINE. SO CURRENTLY THE
AUTHORITY ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE
TO MEET THE FEDERAL GRANT
DEADLINE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
HOWEVER- IT WOULD REALLY
REQUIRE QUITE AN INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE RATE SO WE ALREADY-HEARD FROM AND MISTER KELLY
THAT. THE AUTHORITY HAD
INCREASED IT EXPENDITURE RATE
AND THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO
SO QUITE A BIT MORE THAN EVEN
THEY'VE DONE THAT FAR IN ORDER
TO MEET THAT. I DON'T GRAY THAT
MIGHT. I'M ALSO IN THE LONG
TERM. THE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS.
PROVIDE ABOUT AND FEES ONE OF
APPEARED. SO THAT THAT DEADLINE
OR THE DATE THE IN THE- IN THE
BUSINESS PLAN THE DRAFT THE
PLAN A DIFFICULT FINDING AND AS
WE'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT IN THIS
HEARING I'M CURRENTLY THERE
ISN'T FULL FUNDING FOR THE
PROJECT. AND THERE'S PROBABLY
THAT'S ABOUT IT AND THAT CAN
CHILI- CINCO WHILE COMPLETE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD BUT NOT.
BEING PART OF THE PROJECT. SO
THAT REALLY THE COMPLETE DATE
FOR THE- FULL VALUE VALLEY IN
PHASE ONE IS UNCERTAIN AT THIS
TIME. FOR THE SECOND KEY
OVERSIGHT ISSUE THAT WE WANTED
TO RAISE IS THAT FUNDING MAY
NOT BE ADEQUATE FOR THE PROJECT
AND AGAIN THERE ARE CERTAIN
YOUR TERM AS WELL AS LONGER
TERM CHALLENGES. THE PROJECT IN
THE AREA FOR A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THESE ALSO COME WITH THEIR
COLLEAGUES. AND SO IN TERMS OF
THE NEW TRIMS CHALLENGES THE
ACTUAL COST OF AMBER
TECHNICALLY SKILLED SEGMENT
COULD BE HIGHER THAN IN. THE
PROJECT HAS ALREADY EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASES- AND
GIVEN TO THE PATH. THE PATH TO
THE COST INCREASES AS WELL AS
JUST THE- NATURE OF THESE LARGE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
ESPECIALLY. BAKER SAID THAT MAY
INCLUDE SIX EXTENSION MERCED
BAKERSFIELD AND THOSE- ARE
REALLY AT THE EARLY STAGES AND
AS WE HEARD. OF ANY PROJECT AND
THE EARLY STAGES OF DESIGN
THERE THAT YOU MORE UNCERTAINTY
IN TERMS OF THAT COST. AND WE
ALSO THAT IT'S UNCLEAR IF THE
FINDINGS THAT ANTICIPATED
WAFFLING MATERIALIZE- SO
ESSENTIALLY THE- BAKERSFIELD
SEGMENT WELL I'VE DONE SOME
FUNDING SOURCES THAT YOU HAVE
MEANT CERTAIN KEY ONE OF THEM
WE HEARD ABOUT A LITTLE BIT IS
THE FEDERAL GRANT. THE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN FEDERAL GRANT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS.
THREATENED TO EXPAND BE USED
AND SO- THAT'S CERTAINLY A
WRECK FAIR. ADDITIONALLY THE
PLAN RELIES ON ESTIMATES THE
FUTURE CAP AND TRADE REVENUE.
AND THERE'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE
HERE AND PERHAPS EVEN MORE
UNCERTAINTY GIVING HER THE
NINETEEN AND- UNDER AND
CONCERNS THAT WHETHER YOU MIGHT
UP WITHIN A SHORT TERM. BOB
COOK HAPPENS RIGHT SO BOTH FIND
OUT WHAT THE NAY RESULTS ARE
VERY SOON BACK. ON THAT THE
CONFLICT. WELL COULD MAKE OF
THE STATE AFTER TO THE FEDERAL
FINE OR AND KEPT TRADE REVENUE
TO MATERIAL OR CAR CARD ARE
HIGHER THE THEY THERE NEEDS TO
BE FUNDING SOURCES PERHAPS THE
GENERAL. THAT THAT THAT IS
COMPLETELY GROSSED OUT I'M WE
DON'T KNOW IN TERMS OF THAT
TIGHTENING OF THE FUNDING IT
MIGHT NOT A LINE WITH PROJECT
PLEASE- THAT WE'VE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE KPMG TUDY
I'M NOT STUDY IDENTIFIED THAT
EVEN IF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
TIME IS THERE FOR THE PROJECT
FROM THE BAKERSFIELD EVEN IF
THE STATE HAS SUFFICIENT
CARPENTRY REVENUE IN WHICH CAME
AROUND. BUT HE MAY NOT A LINE
AND PARTICULARLY IF AND
CABINETRY REVENUES ON THE LOWER
END FOR EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE
SOME. CASH CERTAIN YEARS. WHAT
WE UNDERSTAND THE VEHICLE AND
WITH MY HOW TO ADDRESS THANK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT AT NEAR
WITHOUT AND IT COULD BE MORE
CAL TO PROVIDE AND BY NAME THE
PROJECT IF IT ANYTHING THAT'S
NOT A GOOD THE- I KNOW COURSE
I'M NOT. INTO ALONG TERM VALUE
CHALLENGE. AND I THINK ENOUGH
FOR THE REST OF THE CROWD. ARE
THERE CERTAIN UNCERTAIN HE
ABOUT. THE LEVEL OF KERR FOR
THE PROJECT- BOTH BECAUSE IT'S
JUST A LARGE SCALE. CAPITAL
PROJECT WE'VE ALREADY HEARD AND
CERTAINTY AND MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS AND THE VERY EARLY
STAGES WHILE SO THERE'S- A
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY
THERE- AND THEN ALSO AS- HAS
BEEN NOTED. THERE'S NO FUNDING
PLAN YET COMMERCE SAID DEBATERS
BEFORE BEYOND RESPECTIVELY. BUT
THE POINT. I THANK CLEAR HOW
THAT ADDITIONAL. FUNDING WOULD
BE WOULD BE NOT. YES THAT WE
WANTED TO BRING A- IT THAT AN
OPERATING SAID TO IS EXPECTED
TO BE REQUIRED AGAIN I KNOW
THAT COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT
THAT- SOME EXTENT I DON'T WANT
TO BELABOR THE POINT BUT
EVENTUALLY THE AUTHORITY
GRANTED TO USE THE THIRD PARTY
PUBLIC ENTITY TO OPERATE THIS
INTERIM SERVICE THE PEOPLE TAKE
COMPLIANCE WITH PROPOSITION ONE
A- AND THE MEASURE DOES HAVE
SOME LANGUAGE THERE THAT WAS
REFERENCE- AND- THAT. AT THAT.
GLORY FROM FRIEND REQUIRING
OPERATING. AT TO THIS APPROACH
WOULD BASICALLY SAID THAT THE
TAXPAYERS WOULD STILL END UP
POTENTIALLY SUBSIDIZING
OPERATION- BUT IT WOULD BE
THROUGH THE THIRD PARTY- AND SO
THAT DOESN'T REALLY NECESSARILY
CHANGE THE PRACTICAL THE FACT
THAT THE STATE WOULD BEAR
INTERSTATE TAXPAYERS WOULD BEAR
A PORTION OF THE DISTANT
OPERATING COSTS AT LEAST DURING
THAT NONE OF THAT. LAND SO
PROVINCIALLY. A CONCERN IN
TERMS OF THE SPIRIT OF THE
MEASURE. AND THEN- THE FOURTH
ISSUE I WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT. IS
REALLY THAT THAT THE FACT THAT
THIS INTERIM SERVICE DEPENDS ON
A VARIETY OF FACTORS. I KNOW
THERE ARE ALSO REFERENCES TO
RIDERSHIP AND- HOW DID OPTION
COMPARED WITH THE DORY THING
FOR COMPARATIVE MOTHER OPTION.
I'M REALLY BEEN ALICE'S THAT
WAS DONE BY THAT REALLY TRAIN
OPERATOR AND- IT REALLY DEPENDS
ON. A VARIETY OF THE TIMES.
THAT THEY MAKE IN TERMS OF
DURING THE MODELING I JUST
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THEM. THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
NOTABLE. ONE IS THAT THE
ANALYSIS ASSUMES THE COMPLETION
OF OTHER CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
ONE OF THE MAIN ONES THAT THE
FILM IS THE COMPLETION. OF AT
STATION AT AT MERCED THAT WOULD
SERVE. AS YOU. LOOK AT. THE
SAME ONCE. AS WELL AS A OPPOSED
HIGH RAIL AUTHORITY. SO
CURRENTLY. I'M WORKING IN THE-
THEY HAVE A SEPARATE. OCCASIONS
THAT'S ABOUT OVER MILE AWAY
FROM THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL.
PLANTATION AND TO THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE INTEGRATED. SO THE
ESTIMATE THAT PROJECT WOULD BE
COMPLETED AND FIND AT. THEY
ALSO- ALSO HE ANNOUNCES THAT
SEEMS PERFECT RELIABILITY AND
THAT'S NOT JUST THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SERVICE. BUT ALSO
CONNECTING TRAIN AND BUS
SERVICES AND THAT THEY WOULD
OPERATE WITH 100% RELIABILITY.
I'M HOWEVER CURRENTLY THOSE
OTHER TYPES OF SERVICES DON'T-OPERATE AT THAT LEVEL OF
RELIABILITY AND SO IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER. THAT WOULD MATERIALIZE.
IF YOU GO BACK TO DOCTOR
KILLERS POINTS HERE I THINK THE
REASON WHY THESE ASSUMPTIONS
ARE SO HE- BECAUSE- AND- THAT
BASICALLY THAT ANALYSIS ASSUME
REALLY THAT. EASY WE MUST
TRANSFER I'M AND NOT I THINK
ONE OF THE KEY THING THAT
DRIVING ON THE HIGHER RIDERSHIP
THAT THEY'RE ASSUMING. I'M
THIRTY THE EXTENT THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE STATION ISN'T WELL
INTEGRATED OR- WHAT THE
SERVICES DON'T PERFECTLY
CONNECTING PEOPLE HAVE TO WAIT
AND YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE IT
COULD BE A LESS DESIRABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTION OF HER
WRITERS SPEND IT IF YOU CAN.
ANALYSIS AND THEN AND I
ASSUMPTION THAT MY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHTED BUT IT ALSO YEAH
THIS ALSO WITH THEM- AS WOULD
MENTION THAT. BASICALLY THERE'S
NO COMPETING SERVICE- ALONG
THAT SEGMENT THAT THAT THAT
HAVE YOUR LOGO HE WOULD OPERATE
THERE. AND TO BASICALLY THE
FAMILY HE WOULDN'T OPERATE
SOUTH OF MERCED. SO QUICKLY
TRADE OUT REGARDING THAT. THE
COUNTY PROVIDE THEM CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CAN WHAT I'M SERVICE ON
THAT SEGMENT. AND EXCUSE ME
THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY CHANGE RIDERSHIP
WITH WHAT. SO WE JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT- IF SOME OF THOSE END
UP BEING OPTIMISTIC OR
INCORRECT THAT COULD DEFINITELY
CHANGED THE RIDERSHIP
ESTIMATES. THAT THE AUTHORITY
AND THE STORY HAS IN THEIR PLAN
AND THAT COULD CHANGE EVEN THE
RELATIVE- THE RELATIVE
RIDERSHIP BY VARIOUS OPTIONS
SO. I THERE ARE A COUPLE
OPTIONS THAT WERE LOOKED AT-
ONE IN THE LA AREA I WON IN THE
BAY AREA YOUR COMPARED AGAINST
THE OPTION AND- FOR THAT MUCH
THAT THE BAKERSFIELD MINE. I AM
CERTAINLY HOW THOSE DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES COMPARE WAITED
WOULD BE BASED ON. THE TYPES OF
ASSUMPTIONS AND WHETHER THAT
PLAY OUT. ALSO WHEN HE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE OTHER ALTER EXIST
IF YOU OF THOSE. LINE IF YOU
CAN SOME OF THE QUESTIONS. YOU
COULD DO A SHORTER LONGER
STATEMENT YOU CAN GRIND
DIFFERENT TAKE THE TRAIN BUT AT
A NEW. KIND OF PEOPLE TRAINED
COULD RUN EITHER YOUR MISSION
TRAIN. I'M CALLING YOU IF
DIFFERENT SET OF PROJECT AS
WELL IF YOU READ AT NINETY SO
THERE ARE. DIFFERENT OPTIONS
THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED. AND
THEN FINALLY- IN TERMS OF
ISSUES THAT THIS ISSUE I WANTED
HER HIGHLIGHT AND THAT WE THAT
WE HAD IN OUR REPORT IS THAT
THAT BECAUSE THE COACH PROVIDED
BY THE AUTHORITY. I DOESN'T
PROVIDE A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY SO
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
REALLY KEY POINTS. ON THE
AUTHORITY PLANS TO TAKE ACTION
IN TWENTY TWENTY- ON SOME MAJOR
THINGS THAT WELL KIND OF STAND
HAPPENED THAT THE STATE DOWN IN
THE PATH OF DOING WORK THAT THE
BAKERSFIELD. AND DOING IT ANON
ELECTRIFIED WAY. AND THE KEY
ACTIONS INCLUDE ENTERING INTO
THE TRACKING SYSTEM CONTRACT-
AND EVEN THAT FIRST INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT INCLUDE
THE ELECTRIFICATION COMMITMENT.
ALL OF THAT THE ONE PIECE. OF
ONCE THAT CONTRACT IS ENTERED
INTO THAT IT GETS HARDER TO
AND- THE LAYOUT YOUR VACATION
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU WANTED TO DO
THAT. AND ALSO THE AUTHORITY
PLANNED- IN TWENTY TWENTY YOU
PROCURE ELECTRIC TRAIN TO AGAIN
THAT WOULD START TO COMMIT THE
STATE IN THE NEAR TERM TO
RUNNING LIKE TO HIDE SERVICE.
AND ALSO TO- ACQUIRE RIGHT AWAY
OUTSIDE OF THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT SELECT THE
HERD. CURRENTLY THE AUTHORITY
IS JUST ACQUIRING PROPERTIES
WITHIN THE INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT. BUT THEY WOULD PLAN TO
START DOING THAT AFTER THEY
START MOVING BEYOND THAT- ALL
THE WAY UP TO MERCED AND IN
DOWN TO BAKERSFIELD AND EVEN
POTENTIALLY MOTHER AREA AS
WELL- ONCE THEY HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE. ACTIVE
SO IN THE COMING MONTHS. THE
ONE THOSE PROPERTY ACQUISITION
START- IT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO CHANGE COURSE
BECAUSE- WHILE THE STATE COULD.
GET RID OF THOSE PROPERTIES
THEIR COSTS THERE AND ALSO WITH
THEM DIFFICULT. FOR THE
PROPERTY OWNERS BOB. SO WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE
THAT IF A REALLY HE TIME THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THIS TO
MAKE A DECISION. ON THE PATH OF
THE PROJECT BECAUSE- NEXT YEAR
THERE MAY BE FEWER VIABLE
OPTION DO THE OPTION MIGHT BE
MORE LIMITED IN A LOT OF WAYS.
I'M SO COURSE THAT LEGISLATURE
COULD CONTINUE WITH THE
APPROACH IDENTIFIED BY THE
AUTHORITY. ON THE LEGISLATURE
COULD SELECT A DIFFERENT
APPROACH FOR EXAMPLE YOU COULD
JUST. TRY TO OKAY FINE THAT
FEDERAL GRANT- AGREEMENTS. ARE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH WAS REALLY
JUST KIND OF BASIC TRACK IN
THAT INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT. I'M WORKING MOTHER
APPROACH IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
REALLY COMFORTABLE MAKING THAT
DECISION. IF NOT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CERTAINLY-
DIRECTLY ACCORDING TO TAKE
ACTION TO HELP PRESERVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY THE DECISION COULD
BE MADE AT A LATER DATE. THAT
COULD INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE-
MODIFYING THE TRACK AND DEFENSE
CONTRACT SO THAT OF COURSE
NOTED TO PROCEED ONLY REALLY
INCLUDE. THE FEDERAL GRANT
SCOPE- ACCORD CAPS EVEN JUST-
DELAYING SOME OF THE HOT. I
COULD THE LINE ROLLING STOCK
FOR WE'RE DEALING PROPERTY
ACQUISITION OPTION
CONSIDERATION. AND SO I KNOW
THAT A LOT- HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO AYE CONTINUING
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE. ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
THE L. L. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR- WONDERFUL
UNBIASED A- REPORT AND WE
ALWAYS RELY ON YOU FOR. YOUR
EXPERTISE IN GUIDING US. WHEN
THESE ISSUES COME UP AND I
REALLY DO AFFECT THANK YOU FOR
THAT. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
MODERATOR- MISTER LUTON SEND
THE- CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PEER REVIEW GROUP. AND LUTON TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY HERE
ARE MY OWN NOW. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INVITATION TO
RIGHT HERE TODAY. ALL I AND I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRMAN'S
REMARKS ABOUT YOUR WITH YOUR
GROUP YEAH- I'M SORRY THAT I
CAN'T BE THERE IN PERSON BUT WE
ALL UNDERSTAND WE LIVE BUT WE
ARE FACING WITH KIND OF PUBLIC
GATHERING. AT FIRST WHEN I
REQUEST. FOR ALL. WHY OF WORDS
SHORT SHIRT ON I CAN YEAH DO IT.
ALL BY. WHAT IS GOING. ABLE TO
EVER WE CAN OKAY OR COMMON ON
THE DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY THE
PLAN ONE IS GOING TO PULL SOME
THE MERE. WE'VE ALSO MORE
DETAIL COMMON WOULD BE A
PRIORITY. FIRST OF ALL WE MEAN
ANYTHING WELL YOU WORK AND THE
BE IN THE OKAY. AND WE THANK
THE THERE'S A LOT. OF GOOD
PICTURE OF THE ISSUE SMALL.
REALLY DOES. CAREFUL WHEN YOU.
YEAH TWENTY POINT DOES NOT PLAN
THE AUTHORITY PROPOSED TO
COMPLETE THE L<c.cyan>G NOW UNDER</c>
WAY FROM A THERE THE POPLAR
AVENUE NORTH OF BAKERSFIELD
THIS WOULD FULFILL THE FEDERAL
OUR OBLIGATION. ADD UP THIRTY
THREE MILES AWAY FROM WHERE
SAID THAT TO MY DEAR I WOULD
COULD NOT PART OF THE ORIGINAL.
ONE COMPLETE NINETEEN LARA WENT
FROM POPLAR AVENUE ON IN THE
BAKERSFIELD. ELECTRIFY AND
SIGNALING EMPIRE ONE SEVENTY
ONE MILES LEFT IN AND PURCHASE
PRICE THREE ELECTRICAL AND.
SOFTWARE TESTING OPERATIONS. WE
ARE ONE ROOF. THE SYSTEM TO
WORK SEPARATE ARE A POSSIBLY
YEAH HE'S ELSE IT TAKES OR THE
STATE. THAT WOULD ACTUALLY RUN
TRYING COOLEY CONCORD. HIGH
SPEED RAIL FOR ALL OF THE COST
TO MAINTAIN AND OPERATE THE
WINE AND THE WILL. WE DIRECTOR
PLAN WORKING CRANE BILL WITH
THE NEW LINKS AND FULLY CORD
MAKE THE OPERATION OKAY AND
WITH THEM WORKING. REVENUE
STATION COULD BE BUILT ON THE
SAID. AWARD HELLO TERM.
CONTRACTUALLY GOING WELL LACK
OF PROTECTION AND IN DOING
MAINTENANCE THE ONE YOU WANT
CONTRACT FOR. THE CONTRACT
WOULD HAVE A SERIES OF NUMBERS
THE RECEIPT OR ANYTHING PLEASE
WHAT. OTHER THAN COMPLETED.
AWARD A CONTRACT WILL PREVENT
HIM PASSING AND LONG TERM
MAINTENANCE OF A HIGH SPEED LOW
AND THOUGHT. WE HAVE DISCUSSED
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES IN EARLY
OR WHATEVER IN THE MALL HE BY
WALTER GO HERE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN NARAL ADVANCE
THE- PROPOSAL. IF THE LETTER
WANTS TO HAVE OTHER OPTIONS YOU
WILL NEED TO REQUIRED THAT THEY
BE DEVELOPED BLACKHEART THE WAY
I LOOK AT RT CALTRAIN METROLINK
AND HELPFUL. WE ARE THIRTY FOUR
AND WHAT IS A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT WE DISCUSSED IN OUR WATER.
FIRST THE TERMS OF THE PROPOSED
WE HAVE NOT BEEN DEVELOPED OR
AGREED WITH POTENTIAL LENGTHY.
WELCOME TO GET SOMETIME LET ME
OSCE WILL COVER ALL OF THE
AUTHORITIES COSTS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVEN NOR IS IT A FAD WORD THE
USE OF A LEASE WELL WHAT WE CAN
BE AUTHORITY OF THE POOL THERE
AGAIN BUT THE- ONE I. IT IS NOT
THAT THE LEFT WILL CORRECT
REVENUE AND OPERATING COSTS FOR
SOMETHING HE WOULD HAVE. BEEN A
LOT. OF OPERATION. THE
ESTIMATED CAPITAL COST FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE WORK ON NOT
BEING STONE FINALIZE DESIGN AND
THEY PRESUME THAT THE AUTHORITY
WILL BE ABLE TO STAY WITHIN
BUDGET AND SCHEDULE FOR THE
RIGHT MORE. SOMETHING THAT THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO ON
THEIR EXISTING CONTRACTS. AND
BACTERIAL PROJECTING OF 70%
OVER RUN ON AVERAGE ON THE
CURRENT CONTRACT ALONG. WITH TO
THE BRING YOUR WAY. WE DO WORK.
THAT YEAH HAVE LEARN FROM.
NIGHT AND HE MADE ME CRY. MAJOR
TRAVEL AND GIVE YOU A NINE. THE
PROPOSED LONG TERM CONTRACT
CONTRACT ELECTRIFICATION SIGNAL
CONSTRUCTION AND MAKING WILL BE
COMPLEX THE DEVELOP. AND IT
SHOWS AN UNUSUAL DEGREE OF LIVE
TRANSFER TO THE CONTRACT THE
WORK. DELAYED OR PROTESTS FROM
THE CONTRACT COULD COULD BE
ACCURATE. AT THE EXPECTED
PERHAPS HAVE WILLING BASED ON
YEAH WHATHAPPENED TRADE
REACHING THAT NO YOU COULDN'T
COPE WITH NINETEEN IMPACT. IT
ALSO RELIES ON NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
GRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN WITHIN
YOUR- LONG TWO AND A HALF
MILLION OR SO AND ERA FUNDING
THAT WILL BE AYE WE ARE IF WE
HAVE ALREADY DOES NOT MEET THE
DEADLINE OF IN THE TWENTY TWO.
TWO AND THEY ALL RIGHT WE'RE
ABOUT. THANK YOU THEN THE WAR
WE RECKON. WITH THE IN PARTY
SHOULD NOT A WORD THAT WILL
STOP CRIME BUT THE- COMMITMENT
HAVE BEEN FINE WITH THE ARE. OF
THE ANYWAY FOR THE. INCLUDING
COMMITTED AND FOR THAT THE BILL
OF BE TO HAVE AND AGREED CODE.
OPERATE SCHEDULED. THE
AUTHORITY SHOULD BE DONE NOT
THE TRACK AND CON UNTIL ONLY A
VERY WITH OPERATE THAT FINE FOR
A MINIMUM THE FIRST NUMBER SHE
SHOULD BE ALRIGHT FOR OUR WORK
AND MARK ALL FUTURE. OVER
CONDITIONS ON THE FLY HE THE
OPERATING A. I'VE NOTED OUR WAY
BUT COULD BE. WAS OVER ANALYZE
WITH THE A BM B. RIGHT THAT IS
THE GET STARTED. IT COULD BE A
PRIORITY DONE WE COULD BECAUSE
BECAUSE- THE WONDERFUL WILL
EFFECTIVE BE TO FINISHING THE
SYSTEM OF MERCED THE BACK OF
THE OLD WON'T BE IN BURGER
OPTION. ALL IT DID FOR
INCREDIBLY DONE IT WILL TO
PRESSURE FINISH WITH THE
FOOTBALL AND THAT WILL WORK DO
SO WORKING WITH HAND BEYOND IN
OF THE YEAH APPROVED. THE
LEGISLATURE BEGIN BEACON WHAT
THE SOURCE WOULD BE. FINALLY
AND THE CALL THAT WE EXTRA
ALTHOUGH YOUR PEER REVIEW THE
BUT- NINE THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
I MEAN WHAT ALL COULD HAVE A
GOOD WORLD AND TRENDS. OF OUR-
I'M CAL RIPKEN THEIR ISSUE IS
THE BILL AT THE LONG TERM.
ISSUE. IT WILL NEVER BE STATE.
IF YOU CAN BECAUSE BY BUT AT
THE END INCREASE COSTS THE
ISSUE HELLO THE END. YEAH WHAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR YOU OKAY. AND YOUR
KNOW THE REVIEW WILL LOOK FOR
YEAR. AND WE ARE WILL HELP
HELLO BUT WE CAN ARM I WILL BE
TO GO COULD BE COLLECTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER TOM ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY OF A MISTER TOM
UP FOR REVIEW GROUP. XENON
MISTER THOMPSON AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR CANDOR AND
YOUR EXPERTISE I HAVE RELIED ON
YOU FOR. THE FIVE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN THE CHAIR- AS WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS PROJECT. AND
I LOOK TALK LOOK FOR TO TALKING
TO YOU THE NEAR FUTURE. ON
ADDRESSING YOUR CONCERNS TO THE
BOARD OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER KELLY. IS GERMAN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
ON THE- THIS LONG HEARING BUT
WE ONLY HAVE EVERY TWO YEARS TO
REALLY COVER. THIS AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- ACROSS
FOR TEASING DOT ALL RISE AS FAR
AS OUR- OUR ROLES OVERSIGHT.
SIR SO. I'VE GOT SEVERAL
QUESTIONS. AND YOU KNOW WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW.
LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW COALBED.
CALL THE NINETEEN WHAT EFFECT
ON PRODUCTION HASN'T HAD THUS
FAR. IT'S VERY GOOD QUESTION
WE'VE BEEN UP THERE IN SOME
WAYS WE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
BLESSED MISTER CHAIRMAN BECAUSE
FOR EXAMPLE- ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SITE. IT'S BEEN
VERY LITTLE- IMPACT- WE'VE GOT
A COUPLE OF POSITIVE- CASES
WE'VE TAKEN ALL THE-
APPROPRIATE- ACTIONS THE
ISOLATE OF THOSE EMPLOYEES.
AFFECTED AGAIN USER NOW THE
CONTRACTOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
WORKING ON THE CONSTRUCTION
ITSELF- AND SO WE HAVE VERY
LIMITED IMPACT AND AS I
REPORTED TO YOU EARLIER MY
PRESENTATION. WE'RE SAYING THE
CONSTRUCTION ADVANCE SO AT THAT
THAT PART IS VERY POSITIVE UP
WE ARE SEEING IN OTHER AREAS OF
SOME IMPACT WE DON'T ENTIRELY
KNOW YOU HEARD MISTER THOMPSON.
A MOMENT AGO SUGGESTS THERE
COULD BE IMPACTS TO THE- A CAP
AND TRADE UP AUCTIONS OF IT IN
THIS IS A- IT AS A FACT OF THE
OF THE PANDEMIC ON THE- GLOBAL
ECONOMY WE ARE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WATCHING IT VERY CLOSELY SO
THAT'S- THE ONE AREA WHERE THIS
QUESTION- I MENTIONED THAT- IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS-
WE'VE HAD A- REQUEST. FROM
COMMUNITIES AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
HAVE MORE TIME TO RESPOND TO
OUR DRAFT DOCUMENTS THAT WE'VE
RELEASED IN SOME CASES THEY'VE
ASKED FOR AS MANY AS- THIRTY OR
FORTY FIVE DAYS AND WE HAVE
GRANTED ON. TO THUS FAR FIFTEEN
SO WE CAN. GIVE THEM MORE TO
OMIT BUT ALSO TRY TO LIMIT. THE
IMPACT ON OUR WORK. BUT THE
ANOTHER PLACE A THAT WE'RE SAY
OF SOME OF THE IMPACT- AND- I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT- THERE IS A
LITTLE LESS. THERE ARE CERTAIN
DAYS THE RIGHT WORD BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT- BIDDERS ON THE
ATTRACTED SYSTEMS CONTRACT ARE
BEING A CAUTIOUS AND VERY-
DELIVERED OF IN IN IN SORT OF
CAUTIOUS ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
OF SHORTY BONDS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT IN TODAY'S FINANCIAL
MARKETS SO THAT WAS PART OF THE
REASON WE DELAYED- BY. BUT
ABOUT TWO MONTHS THE TRACKING
SYSTEMS CONTRACT- SO. YEAH
WE'RE SEEING IT IN A KIND OF
BITS AND PIECES IN VARIOUS.
PARTS OF THE PROGRAM AS I SAID
WE'VE BEEN BLESSED OF THE
CONSTRUCTION LEVEL ABOUT WE
ARE. MISSING SOME IMPACTS AND
SOME OF THE OTHER OTHER PACES
AND IT'S AND IT'S ENOUGH FOR I
THINK WE HAVE TO DO A DEEPER. A
BIT OF A DEEPER DIVE ON THE
RISK ASSESSMENTS HERE.
APPRECIATE THAN WHAT. AND IT
JUST KIND OF KIND OF TAG ALONG
WITH MISTER THOMPSON SAID ABOUT
THE CAP AND TRADE- YOUNG YOUR-
RELIANCE ON IT THUS FAR. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE NEW BUDGET HAS
BEEN PROJECTED WITH YOU- NET
OPERATING LOSS. THE TWO
BUSINESSES WILL HAVE OCCURRED
BECAUSE OF GO AHEAD AND DO THE
NEW BUDGET NOW SAYS IT
RETROACTIVELY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THEY WON'T BE
ABLE TO CLAIM THOSE LOSSES AND
THEN THE TAX CREDITS THAT THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO ASSUME THIS
YEAR I'M THINKING THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE A REPERCUSSION
DOWNSTREAM NOT ONLY TO THE
ECONOMY BUT ALSO. YOU KNOW THE
BASIS OF THESE THESE COMPANIES
WON'T HAVE THAT MONEY TO BE
BUYING EMISSION CREDITS-
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THAT-
THAT MONEY ANYMORE OR THAT
ABILITY TO. NIELSEN THEIR
LOSSES OR THESE TAX CREDITS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
PAST SO. I THINK IT CAN BE BE
WARRANTED- GOING FORWARD THAT
THE RELIANCE. AND THE
CONSISTENCY OF THE GREENHOUSE
GAS FUND THAT CAP AND TRADE
MIGHT BE IMPACTED DIRECTLY- FAR
MORE THAN YOU CAN REALIZE JUST
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE BUDGET. A NUMBER TWO
WHEN I LOOK AT YOU KNOW THE
INVESTMENT- OF CAP AND TRADE
INTO THE PROJECT. YOU KNOW
CARVE THEIR INNER SCOPING PLAN
SAYS THAT THE STATE'S EMISSION
GOALS HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONTRIBUTE. 1% OF THE REDUCTION.
GOING FORWARD BUT YET WE'RE
INVESTING 25% OF THE CABIN
TRADE REVENUES INTO THIS
PROJECT. HAS THERE EVER BEEN A
CASH BENEFIT ANALYSIS DONE
MISTER KELLY THAT TO KNOW THAT
THIS MONEY IS WELL SPENT ON A
MISSIONS VERSES THE 1% VERSUS
WHAT COULD BE DONE ELSEWHERE.
OF VALUE. YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW
BUT I WOULD SAY THIS- MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT- THE CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS GOING TO THIS
PROGRAM OR ACHIEVING. OF MANY
OF THE OBJECTIVES OF THE CAPITA
RIGHT PROGRAM LAID OUT. UP AT
FULL OF FILLED OUT THE THIS
PROGRAM WILL. EXCEED BY ITSELF
JUST THIS PROJECT- IN TERMS OF
THE MISSION BENEFITS ALL OF THE
CAP AND TRADE- A PROGRAMS
FUNDED TO DATE- THAT ARE NOT
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN TERMS OF
THE- TOTAL REDUCTION OF CARBON
DIOXIDE. IN SO- AND THAT'S
ACCORDING TO CAR THAT'S NOT
ACCORDING TO US THAT'S THAT'S
IN IN CARBS DOCUMENTATION SO I
THINK. ONE I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT A TO A CAP AND TRADE
IS ALSO IS SUPPOSED TO EXPAND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND JOBS
AND I THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT WE ARE THE OF VERY. OF
IMPORT THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF WHAT WE DO- AND I'M I'M
VERY PROUD OF THAT THE WORK IN
THE END SO- AND THREE OF THEY
WANTED CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS TO
LARGELY BE FOCUSED IN.
DISADVANTAGED AREAS AND AGAIN
IF YOU LAY OVER THE SORT OF
THE- THE IDENTIFICATION
DISADVANTAGED AREAS WITH. ARE
THE PROPOSED ALIGNMENT- WE LAY
WE- WE'RE WE'RE SORT OF THE
POSTER CHILD FOR- FOR INVESTING
IN THOSE IN THOSE COMMUNITY.
AND SO IN THAT SENSE I THINK
IT'S- A- IT IS BEST TO GET THE
TRADEOFF NINETY WHERE WE ARE.
THE IN MANY WAYS THE EXAMPLE
OF- OF WHAT CAPITA RATE
DOLLARS- COULD DO- THAT WAS
STANDING ARE PROBLEMS OF THE
PAST I THINK THE- THE BETTER WE
GET THE MORE THAT WILL PAY OFF.
THANK YOU- IN YOU MENTIONED
YOU'RE ABOUT 40% ON THE-
INITIAL ONE HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
MILES HOW MUCH RAIL HAS BEEN
LAID. A TRACK NOT. BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T EXECUTED THE
TRACK CONTRACTED. HOW MANY
PARCELS- DID YOU BUY IN THIS.
WITH ME AND NOT YOU PERSONALLY
BUT THE AUTHORITY BY AND HAVE
NO NEED FOR NOW HOLDING- KIND
OF STAGNATED- RESOURCES. BUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN UP TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON ON ON THAT THAT
NUMBER ARE TOTAL OR PARTIAL
PROCUREMENT TO DATE-
ACQUISITION IS ABOUT SIXTEEN OH
THREE IN TERMS OF TOTAL PARCELS
THAT WE PURCHASED. UP SOME OF
THOSE- THEY DO HAVE MORE THAN
YOU IMMEDIATELY NEED BUT THEN
THERE'S OTHER THINGS WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER ABOUT WHERE WE LOCATE-
THE OTHER PART MAKE YOU KNOW
MAINTENANCE FACILITIES- OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE PART OF THIS
THAT MAY NEED MORE THAN JUST.
THE TRACK ITSELF- AND SO A SOME
OF THAT IS THE STUFF THAT WE-
STEP TO GO THROUGH WHAT I WOULD
HAVE TO GET BACK WITH THE
SPECIFIC ON HOW MANY PARCELS
WE'VE PURCHASED THAT MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED SURPLUS I DON'T. I
DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME RIGHT
NOW THAT I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE YOU GETTING BACK TO
ME ON THAT SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
YOU KNOW THE- ALLOCATED BOND AT
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE BOND
SERVICE THE DEBT IS EVERY YEAR
THAT WE PAY OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE FOR THE BOND
MONEY WE'VE BORROWED SO FAR FOR
THIS PROJECT I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE- WHAT THE
INTEREST RATE IS IT WOULD BE. A
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS ANY OTHER
GEOPARK. AND USUALLY IT'S
PRETTY. PRETTY GOOD OF YOU KNOW.
TO BE HELPFUL TO KNOW WHEN WE
LOOK AT A REALLOCATION OF BOND
YOU KNOW WHAT IS WHAT IS.
UNNECESSARY EXPENDITURE RIGHT
NOW IN THE IN THE COMING BUDGET
AND THE ALSO THE NECESSARY
HUMAN SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
DEPLETED. AND ALSO WHAT IS THE
COMPOSITION AND AGAIN SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO TAKE PAUSE AND LOOK
AT WHAT IS IT A PRIORITY. AND
SEEING SOME OF THE STATE
AGENCIES BELIEVE THAT THEY
DON'T. HAVE ANY REASON TO PAUSE
THEIR MISSIONS. ARE ON THE BACK
OF OTHER PEOPLE'S ODD YOU KNOW.
BEING IMPACTED BY THIS COVE
INDOOR OR THIS IS RECESSION
WE'RE WE'RE ENTERING INTO
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC SO I'D
REALLY BE INTERESTED TO KNOW
WHAT THE BOND THAT GOING
FORWARD AS OR YEARLY IS- SO
THAT I CAN MAKE A- BUDGET
DECISION WHEN I COMING OF. FORD
AND I KNOW IT'S AN OBLIGATED
GEO BUT THE FURTHER ALLOCATION
WILL BE HAVE TO BE CONSIDERED.
WHEN WE HAVE THAT ALSO THE
RIDERSHIP. NOW I APPRECIATE THE.
B. THE ASSUMPTION THAT THERE
WILL BE THIS EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE. OUR UTILIZING
HIGH SPEED RAIL DIRECTLY DUE TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT BUT
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY PEOPLE
THAT LIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT IS THE SANCTION IS TWELVE
TRAINS AN HOUR. WHICH IS HIGHLY
UNLIKELY YOU LOOK AT THE
CONNECTIONS THAT FROM THE SAN
JOSE AUTHORITY OR THE BUS TO
LOS ANGELES. IT JUST DOESN'T
SEEM THAT- THOSE NUMBERS ARE
ARE FAIR WORKABLE NUMBERS WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT NIGHT I
WOULD APPRECIATE. SOME
RECONSIDERATION DONE THAT YOU
KNOW THE- RIGHT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING THE
BUSINESS PLAN HONESTLY MISTER
KELLY. WE'RE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE PUTTING THESE TOGETHER
THESE NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY
BENEFACTORS OF THIS PROJECT.
AND SO I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
SEE IT IS AND WE HAVE THE PEER
GROUP REVIEW GROUP. DISPUTE A
WE HAVE THE LA DISPUTING IT- SO
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE.
ROLLING BACK IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT CONTROLLER THE
BUSINESS PLAN IS. UNDER
SCRUTINY. AND SHOULD BE
REVIEWED AGAIN. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT COMPONENT OF IT TO ME.
I WAS IN THE BOOK SECTION I
WOULD GO RIGHT TO FICTION AND
REALLY DOES. LEND ITSELF TO
THAT IT'LL HAVE TO PROMOTE THE
PROJECT. LIKE THAT TO BE ABLE
TO. WE UTILIZE ALL THE OTHER
NUMBERS IN THE IN THE IN THE
SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO COME TO
THAT I JUST WANNA KNOW WHAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY USING THEIR
MILLION MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
JUST IF I MIGHT ON THAT POINT.
THE YEAH THE NUMBERS USE FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SECTION-
CAME FROM THE MODEL THAT WAS
USED. FOR THE OF THE STATE RAIL
PLAN AND THE- OF REAL WORLD OF
WORK THAT- THE SAN JOAQUIN IS
AN ACE. OF BOTH SEE TODAY AND
WHAT THE PROJECT IN THE FUTURE-
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT TERMS OF-
YOU KNOW. OF ANY CONFLICT WITH
US ON WHAT THOSE NUMBERS SAY
IN. DECISIONS WE MAKE GOING. A
GOING FOR REMEMBER WE WERE.
WE'RE NOT THE OPERATE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE THE OPERATORS ON THE
SECTION OF THE INTERIM-SO I
DON'T- YOU KNOW I WANT TO USE
THESE NUMBERS TO MAKE. GOOD
DECISIONS LIKE YOU DO. AND IF
THERE'S- ADDITIONAL PEER
REVIEW. AT THAT THAT YOU THINK
WE SHOULD. UNDERTAKE TO
SOLIDIFY OR GIVE MORE CREDENCE
TO. OF THE NUMBERS WILL
CERTAINLY. I CONSIDER THAT YEAH
PROJECT THAT IN ONE OF THE
THINGS TAT REALLY TROUBLES ME
AS WE LOOK AT. HI THE ADDITION
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE REQUIRED
TO ADD THE EXTENSION CLOSELY
ELECTRIFICATION. THE THIRTY
YEAR MAINTENANCE CONTRACT
PROPER RATIONS THE TRAIN
PROCUREMENT. AND THAT'S TO GET
SOMEBODY NINETY MINUTES FASTER
THAN THEY COULD. ON BASS STRING.
AND AGAIN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IS
I DON'T WANNA BE A DETRIMENT
THIS PROJECT BUT I WANT THE
MONEY SPENT IN A FASHION. THAT
IS THE VALUE. AND RIGHT NOW
THIS WAS IN MY ESTIMATION TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE VOTERS WERE
TOLD SOMETHING AGAIN YOU WERE
ACTUALLY CORRECT THEY WERE VERY
FORTHCOMING SAYING THAT ONLY
NINE BILLION DOLLARS WAS GOING
TO BE ALLOCATED GEO MONEY. A
BOND MONEY BUT WE NEVER GOT A
PRIVATE PARTNER THE WANTED TO
TAKE ON THIS RISK BECAUSE OF
THIS PROJECTS ENORMOUS RISK
AND- SO THE BRUNT OF THE
PROJECT IS BEING PAID FOR CAP
AND TRADE FOR THEM WE WERE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO SECURE SOME ARE
AMONG THE AND IN. SOME FEDERAL
MONEY BUT ON THE V. THE
ABSOLUTE. ROAD THAT THIS IS
TAKEN- THERE'S NOT A PRIVATE
ENTITY ONCE IN SUCH AS WITH A
TEN FOOT POLE WITH A RISK OF
CONSTRUCTION AND WE HAVE
VERSION IS GOING OUT AND DOING
THEIR PROJECT IN THEIR TIME
LINES ABSOLUTELY BLOW US WE
KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ACQUISITION BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
THE RIGHT AWAY ALREADY- OF- OF.
OVER A CHOIR OF PARCELS ON YOUR
OWN THE- BUT- IN THIS PROJECT-
IN A REALLY NEEDS TO. HIT THE
PAUSE BUTTON REEVALUATE AND
AGAIN I'M I'M LOOKING AT SOME
OF THE NUMBERS THAT WE ARE
INTENDING TO SPEND. ON THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WE CAN BYHALF
OF THE HOUSEHOLDS. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ALL BRAND NEW
ELECTRIC CARS. SERIOUSLY AND SO
ON AND THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO
MAKE A BUS CONNECTION AND THEY
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A TRAIN
CONNECTION. IN AT THE END AT
THIS POINT TIME SO. AGAIN WE
KNOW MAY ELEVENTH ARMY. I JUST
WOULD BE CONCERNED THEY'LL SIT
IN TRAFFIC ON I. NINETY NINE.
YEAH I MEAN NO THE AND THE AYE.
ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM HERE IS TO PROVIDE. YOU
KNOW OF FASTER MOBILITY OPTION
FOR FOLKS THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE
THEM TO SIT IN. JOKE IN-
CONGESTION. AND SO AGAIN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I YOU KNOW I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU WANT US TO
EXPLORE GIVE YOU MORE
INFORMATION ON I DO THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THERE HAS TO BE A
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER THERE IS
A CONTINUED WILL- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO UP A BILL THIS
PROJECT AND- AND NOT FOR MY
MONEY I CERTAINLY HOPE THERE
IS- BECAUSE- I THINK IT'S THE
MOST TRANSFORMATIVE THING I'VE
SEEN IN MY CAREER- IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT CAN DO AND I UNDERSTAND
pNOBODY WHO WISHES WE COULD
BUILD MORE THAN ME IN TERMS OF
A BIGGER SEGMENT IN A SEGMENT
THAT COULD REACH MORE PLACES
BUT I AM CONSTRAINED BY
AVAILABLE MONEY. AND SO WHAT WE
ARE PROPOSING WITH THE MONEY
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE- I
SHOULD BE VERY CLEAR IS NOT
JUST. THIS ELECTRIFIED SECTION
BETWEEN THESE TWO CITIES. BUT
IT IS ALSO COMPLETING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK. ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO LA IN
ANAHEIM. COMPLETING ALL OF THE
BOOK AND PROJECTS OF BOTH LA-
AND THE BAY AREA- AND ONCE THAT
IS DONE. I THINK WE CAN REALLY
START TO DE REST. WHAT THE REST
OF THE REST OF THE PROJECT IS.
GONNA LOOK LIKE AND THEN I
DON'T THINK WE NECESSARILY WILL
NOT SEE PRIVATE MONEY. A COME
IN I THINK WE HAVE TO GET SOME
OF THIS RISK OUT OF THE WAY-
AND THAT'S ONLY A CHEAT BY.
WORK YEAH AND I YOU KNOW AGAIN
CONTINGENCIES A RISK TO ME AND
I WAS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. CONTINGENCY IN REST
MEANS MISTAKES MISTAKES MADE.
AND OR ASSUMPTIONS THAT WARRANT
NAILED DOWN. WHEN YOU MADE
THIS. COMMENT THAT. THIS
PROJECT WILL LET YOU KNOW LATER
WHAT IT COSTS. I'M NEVER
APPROACH TO CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT WITH WHERE THE- OWNER
HAS TOLD ME. YOU KNOW TELL ME
WHAT. TELL ME WHAT IT WILL COST
ME LATER GET STARTED. JUST IT'S
JUST NOT IT'S NOT THE WAY WE DO
BUSINESS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY- AND SERIOUSLY- WHEN I
LOOK AT THE BUSINESS PLAN IN
THE CONTINGENCIES AND RISK
FACTORS THAT HAVE BEEN
INCLUDED. ALMOST DOUBLE THE
TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT
HIMSELF. AND SO YOU'RE LOOKING
AT PATTING YOUR NUMBERS FOR
MISTAKES AND ASSUMPTIONS AND
WHAT WE USED TO CALL OKEY DOKE
IN THE IN THE INDUSTRY. AND YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF OKEY
DOKE SCUM IN OUR WAY THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE AND- WE FEEL.
WE FEEL IT. YOU KNOW. THE
AUTHORITY- ONLY COMES TO US FOR
MONEY. WHEN THEY NEED IT WE
FEEL THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE OT
PART OF PARTNER OF. SHARE THAT
WITH YOU WHEN YOU'RE THE
SECRETARY TRANSPORTATION- GOING
FORWARD IT'S JUST IT'S A WE
DON'T HEAR FROM THE AGENCY AT
ALL. AND ONLY WHEN IS THIS TIME
AS WE HAVE OUR TIME OF THAT. IN
PUBLIC. YOU KNOW AND SO AND ONE
OF THE OTHER QUESTIONS I DO
HAVE HIS IT'LL HOW MUCH IS- THE
LITIGATION COSTS BEEN TO DATE
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT LITIGATING.
FOR RIGHT AWAY AND ALL THESE
OTHER THINGS I MEAN THIS IS MY
DIRECT A GOING AWAY FROM THE
PROJECT AND HOW MUCH IS.
ANTICIPATED FOR LEAD-
LITIGATION- GOING FORWARD. OFF
TO GET THAT FOR YOU I DON'T
HAVE THAT FOR ME OKAY I HAVE
ONLY ONE MORE QUESTION ON THAT
NOTE. N. IS CHANGE ORDERS TODAY
FROM DAY ONE WHAT HOW MUCH HAVE
THE CHANGE ORDERS ADDED UP TO.
OF GOING FORWARD. FOR ME THE
ORIGINAL ONTRACT PRICE AND HOW
MANY CHANGE ORDERS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL-
BECAUSE AGAIN WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS DESIGNED.
BUILDING A LOT OF FACETS AND-
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE SEEING
COST OVER RUNS. AND BE HELPFUL
TO KNOW KIND OF IN OUR ROLE OF
OVERSIGHT. WHY AND YEAH AND
WHERE. YEAH OF MISTER CHAIRMAN
WILL GET THAT INFORMATION FOR
YOU AS WELL A CHANGE ORDERS WE
MAKE AVAILABLE ON OUR- WEBSITE
TODAY BUT WE WILL- PUT
TOGETHER- THAT INFORMATION AND-
AND- AND PUT IN FRONT OF YOU
AGAIN FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. AND
I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS FROM YOUR-
EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA BUT- YOU
KNOW IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT TO.
GET INTO CONSTRUCTION AND MAKE
COMMITMENTS ON SCHEDULES OF
BEFORE YOU HAVE THE RIGHT AWAY
IN HAND AND I THINK THAT THAT
IS FUNDAMENTALLY- THE REASON
THERE HAS BEEN. A DELAYS AND
COST OF THIS PROJECT AND- AND
SO- YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD
WE'RE TRYING TO. GET A BETTER
HANDLE ON THAT. GET OUR
SCHEDULES- CONFIRM BASED ONLY
KNOW THE RIGHT WILL BE
AVAILABLE. THE END UP BEFORE
THAT FASHION BUT I WILL. I WILL
GETTO YOU THE- ACOSTA CHANGE
ORDER. A NUMBERS THAT YOU
REQUEST RICHARD THAT I JUST
HAVE ONE MORE QUESTION RENDON.
AND YOU'RE OFF THE HOOK. A
CERTAIN. SO YOU MENTION YOUR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF THE TO THE
TRANSPORTATION ARENA. AND YEAH
YOU WORK AS A STAFFER. IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
THEN SECRETARY TRANSPORTATION
HOW MANY YEARS OF CONSTRUCTION
EXPERIENCE DO YOU HAVE. TO RUN
THE LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT. IN CALIFORNIA. WELL AS
A PROJECT MANAGER AT ARPANET
EARLIER ENGINEER. WHAT I I'VE
STE MISTER CHAIRMAN I STEP I
PUT I'VE SPENT MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE IN PUBLIC SERVICE. AND HAS
BEEN MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE. IN
DOING TRANSPORTATION POLICY
THAT INVOLVED SOME OF THE OTHER
LARGEST TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE. OF
THAT THAT IS WHAT I'VE SPENT MY
TIME. DOING AND- AND- AND
LEARNED QUITE A BIT ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION FINANCE. THE
TRANSPORTATION CONSTRUCTION.
AND THOSE THINGS. AND SO- YOU
KNOW I COULD DO THIS JOB AND I
BROUGHT IN EXPERTISE. ON MY
MANAGEMENT TEAM WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DECADES OF THAT
EXPERIENCE. MY CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER IS ONE I WOULD POINT
TO- AND OTHERS AS WELL- AND SO
I'VE IMPROVE MY MANAGEMENT TEAM
IN THAT REGARD. FROM WHERE THE-
I WAIT A HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WAS BEFORE. AND I
BRING TO THIS JOB. MY
EXPERIENCE WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
BUT I THINK EQUALLY IMPORTANT.
A TO SEE THE PROJECT BEFORE.
APPRECIATE THAT AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO BECAUSE- YOU KNOW.
IN MY ESTIMATION AND MY ROLE IN
EIGHT YEARS I'VE SEEN.
CALIFORNIA HASN'T ON MEGA
PROJECTS WELL. THE BAY BRIDGE
WAS KIND OF A OF. PROJECT IT
COULD HAVE BEEN DONE A WHOLE
LOT BETTER AND- AND NOW NOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS PROJECT
IN IS THE COST OVER RUNS AND-
AND THE YEAH I GUESS THE
ANTICIPATION A GETTING STARTED
YOU KNOW AND- AND PUTTING THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE- NOT
ACQUIRING RIGHT AWAY. HAS BEEN
COST TO THE TAXPAYERS HUGE SUM
OF MONEY BUT THEN YOU ALSO LOOK
AT A PROJECT IS COMING DOWN THE
PIKE WITH THIS TUNNEL PROJECT
AND CONVEYANCE. IN CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
THESE PROJECTS WELL AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO. SOME KIND
OF PROCESS BEING PUT IN PLACE
WHERE THERE'S A CHECK AND
BALANCE SYSTEM A BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW. I DON'T FEEL THAT WE HAVE
THE PROPER OVERSIGHT OF THIS
AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT.
THEY'RE DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT.
AND SO I'M MISTER KELLY
APPRECIATE YOU YOU TOOK A ROLL
IT. IS CONTROVERSIAL AND I HOPE
THAT YOU WERE- SUCCESSFUL IN
AND BRING IT BACK TO. WHAT THE
VOTERS AND HOPE FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. IF SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO A PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO THE MODERATOR.
MODERATOR. A LADY GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES HE'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN
IN THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
ZERO OPERATE WILL THEN PROVIDE
YOU A NUMBER AND I WILL.
ANNOUNCE YOU BY THAT NUMBER.
YOU ARE SO FIRST- WE WILL GO TO
NUMBER SIXTY THREE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT WITHOUT
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
FRESNO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
MIKE LEONARDO- WE SUPPORT THE
PROJECT. IS PROPOSED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN BY
CONTINUING THE WORK AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TOWARDS THE
FIRST SEGMENT OF FULLY
ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS HAS BEEN THE
DIRECTION OF THE AUTHORITY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. AND
SCALING BACK THAT WORK IN THE
VALUE AT THIS JUNCTURE WE
BELIEVE WOULD BECAUSE OF
ADVERSE ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO A
REGION THAT DURING THE LAST
RECESSION HAD SOME OF THE WORST
UNEMPLOYMENT THE COUNTRY. WE
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE MAINTAIN
THE COMMITMENT TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ABOUT ONE IN THEIR
FORTIES BUSINESS PLAN THE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THANK YOU SIR. CHECK OUT
ALL NEXT. NUMBER NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OF MY NAME
IS RICK HARNISCH AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
ALLIANCE WERE A MEMBER MEMBER
SUPPORTED NONPROFIT ADVOCATING
FOR FAST FRIEDMAN AFFORDABLE
TRAINS OF ALL KINDS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY- WE URGE THE STATE
TAKE TO. WORK AGGRESSIVELY TO
COMPLETE ELECTRIFIED TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILE AN HOUR
HIGH SPEED LINE LINKING
DOWNTOWN BAKERSFIELD OR MERCED.
CAN BEGIN OPERATIONS ON THAT AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE- THIS IS THE
BEST FIRST BUILDING BLOCK
TOWARDS A HIGH SPEED LINE THAT
WOULD LINK LA AND SAN FRANCISCO
IN UNDER THREE HOURS IT WILL IN
ITS INITIAL FORM- BUILD NEW
LINKAGES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BY CONNECTING WITH ALREADY
EXISTING AND EXPANDED TRAINS
AND BUSES THAT WILL LINK AT ALL
OF THE HIGH SPEED STATIONS.
THERE IS ALREADY A LOT OF
TRANSFERS HAPPENING BETWEEN THE
SAN JOAQUIN TO CONNECTING BUSES
AND OTHER TRAINS. THIS WILL
MAKE THOSE SERVICES MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MUCH MORE COST
EFFECTIVE TO OPERATE FOR THE
STATE. THE OTHER THING THE
FOCUSING ON THIS HIGH SPEED
LINE WILL DO WILL DRIVE
REGULATORY INSTITUTIONAL
INNOVATIONS. THAT ONLY OCCUR IN
AS YOU ARE ACTUALLY MOVING UP
PROJECTS THROUGH COMPLETION. SO
YOU'VE ALREADY ACCOMPLISHED
SOME OF THOSE THINGS IN TERMS
OF PERSUADING THE OFFER A TO-
ADOPT NEW TRAIN SEC
REGULATIONS- ISSUES WITH
ESTABLISHING NEW
ELECTRIFICATION- AND ONE KEY
INNOVATION COULD BE. CREATING
EITHER BETTER CONNECTIONS-
THREE THROUGH SERVICE THAT
ISN'T QUITE TECHNICALLY
POSSIBLE YEP BUT COULD BE BY
THE TIME IS BUILT IF YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON. CALIFORNIA IS A
FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
A STRONG GREEN ECONOMIC
CONNECTIONS- IT'LL LOOK MUCH
LOWER IMPACT AND DOING OTHER
MODES. AND AGAIN PLEASE SEIZE
THIS OPPORTUNITY BY COMPLETING
ELECTRIFIED- BAKERSFIELD MERCED
HIGH SPEED LINE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO BOB GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR FRAZIER AND
MANY MEMBERS- MY NAME'S STEWART
FLASHMAN I'M AN ATTORNEY I SENT
YOU A LETTER- THIS MORNING VIA
THE- THE CONDUIT AND- I'M GOING
TO VERY BRIEFLY GO OVER A FEW
OF THE KEY PARTS OF THAT
LETTER. IN IN POINT I WANTED TO
MAKE IN MY TESTIMONY IS THAT
WHAT YOU. ARE NEW HERE DODD VIA
A POPCORN A AND- THERE'S. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF. BUT THEN
HE DID IS SPONSORING A LEGAL
CHALLENGE I'M ALSO IS. GEN I'M
HEIDI RAIL AND EXPLICATION
LUCIEN'S DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND BOTH OF WHOM HAVE ALSO
BEEN INVOLVED IN LITIGATION
AGAINST THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. CAN YOU GET ME THE
VISUALS THAT ARE. ALLEN DURING
THE AUTHORITY FOR THIS PROPERTY.
AND I'M AFRAID TO ADD TO YOUR--POINTED OUT OF THREE- BY ONE OF
YOUR ONE OF YOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BALLOT MEASURES SPECIFICALLY
SAYS. THAT A **** THE PART THAT
THE PLAN PASSENGER TRAIN
SERVICE WE PROVIDE ORLOFF WHO
IS PURSUANT TO ITS AUTHORITY
WILL NOT REQUIRE OPERATING
SUBSIDIES. NOW THE PURSUANT TO
ITS AUTHORITY WAS MENTIONED BY
PEOPLE BUT WHAT WE ARE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE OPPOSITE. AUTHORITY
IS THAT. HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS EXCLUSIVE
AUTHORITY. TO RUN TRAINING OVER
A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILES PER
HOUR SO EVEN IF THE AUTHORITY
DELEGATE THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
TO ANOTHER AGENCY THAT AGENCY
IS DOING OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE PURSUANT TO A PARTY IS
A PARTY. AND THAT PROHIBITED BY
THE BOND MEASURE. GOING TO
ANOTHER AGENCY AND RENTING THE
FACILITIES OUT THIS MARKET TO
AROUND THE PROBLEM DESPITE WHAT
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
MADE THINGS AND I WOULD URGE
YOU TO SEEK AN INDEPENDENT
LEGAL THIS IS LEGAL OPINION ON
THIS PERHAPS FOR EXAMPLE BY
GOING INTO THE COURTS. FOR
DECLARATORY RELIEF AND GETTING
THE COURTS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO GUEST
LEGAL OR NOT OTHERWISE YOU ARE
TAKING AN ENORMOUS RISK WITH
TAXPAYER MONEY. ONE OF THE-
MENTION IN TERMS OF TORNADOES
THAT COULD BE LOOKED AT AFTER
TEN YEARS AGO THE- SYSTEM ASSN
YEAH. ALREADY ABOUT DOING A
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. AND
THE AUTHORITY PUSH THEM OFF BY
SAYING NO WE'RE NOT INTERESTED
IN DOING WHAT YOU WANT TO DO WE
ONLY WANT YOU TO DO WHAT WE
WANT TO DO. I THINK IT MIGHT BE
WORTH REVISITING ALTERNATIVE
PLANS AND A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP THAT WOULD NOT
NECESSARILY TO WHAT THE
AUTHORITY IS PROPOSING BUT
BEING THAT WOULD PREVENT I
SPEED RAIL SERVICE ACROSS THE
STATE. EXCERPTED. NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ANNA HARVEY AND I'M WITH THE
SAN FRANCISCO PLANNING
DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO I'D LIKE TO SUMMARIZE
THE COMMENTS HE MADE AND THE
LETTER THAT WE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MID MARCH- WILL
BE SENDING A SIMILAR LETTER OF
SUPPORT TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IN THE NEXT FEW DAYS-
THE SITTING COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
DROP TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN TO EXPAND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FRAGMENTED SILICON
VALLEY AND TERMINATE. AT THE
SAN FRANCISCO SALESFORCE
TRANSIT CENTER. WE REVIEW WITH
YOU HIGH SPEED TRAIN SERVICES
THER BECAUSE VITAL TO OUR CITY
AND REGION. HIGH SPEED RAIL
COME. TERM TO SERVE OUR GROWING
POPULATION. SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY
AND LIKE THE BAY AREA THE
CENTRAL VALLEY GROWING ECONOMY
AND COMMUTER BASE AND IT'S
ATTAINABLE MATTER GIVING PEOPLE
MORE OPTIONS OF WHERE THEY CAN
LIVE AND WORK. THIS SEGMENT
WILL PURSUE ELECTRIFICATION AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR OWN LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATE AND- LOCAL. I COULD
BROWN'S ALL THE MORE IMPORTANT
GIVEN THE CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS IT CAN GENERATE KEY JOB
IN THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
REGIONS OF THE STATE. WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT AFTER THE
CATACLYSMIC IMPACT OF COOK AT
NINETEEN. FIFTY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO THIEVES THE
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY THAT THE
PLAN IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE PATH
TOWARD REALIZING THAT THEY
NEVER GET BENEFITS. THAT A FAST
CLEAN MIGHT BE TRAINED TO
REPORT FOR OUR. CITY THE BAY
AREA AND THE ENTIRE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AND ABOUT
CAPTION. THE NEXT WILL BE
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME AS
WELL ALL OVER VICE PRESIDENT
WITH THE FRESNO COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION AND
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF THAT AT
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN. A CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC WOES ARE BECAUSE OF A
LACK TRANSPORTATION TO WORK BUT
THE LACK OF AVAILABLE SKILLED
JOBS THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH
RESILIENT AND DIVERSIFIED
ECONOMIST MUCH LIKE YOU FIND IN
POPULATED COASTAL CITIES.
SPEAKING OF WHICH WITH RISING
COSTS AND SLOW SLOW GROWTH IN
THE LARGE COASTAL METROS THE
CENTER VALLEY IS ONE OF THE FEW
REMAINING PLACES OF CALIFORNIA
WHERE IT'S POSSIBLE TO PLAN FOR
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH WHILE
BUILDING ECONOMY THE
COMMUNITIES INCLUSIVELY. NOT
JUST BY TWENTY THIRTY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY OVER THE PAST DECADE
LOCAL LEADERS HAD THE POSITION
THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO NOT ONLY
CONNECT OUR POPULATION CENTERS
AT FULL SPEED BUT TO ACCELERATE
INVESTMENTS IN A REGION GRIPPED
BY UNABATED POVERTY
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DANGER SUPPORT
AIR QUALITY. AT THE GUINEA PIG
OF THIS PROJECT AND FRESNO WE
HAVE BEAR THE BRUNT OF ROAD
CLOSURES IN BUSINESS
INSTRUCTIONS TO THE RIGHT OF
WAY ACQUISITION PROCESS. YES
WE'RE STILL SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE
THE LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES ON
OUR ECONOMY ARE TOO GREAT
REASON BEAN NEARLY ONE IN FOUR
PEOPLE LIVE IN POVERTY IN
FRESNO ALONE THAT WAS BEFORE
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HIT
A PREVIOUS ECONOMIC CRISES
PROVIDE ANY INDICATION THE
CENTRAL VALLEY MAYBE WHAT THE
LAST AREAS TO RECOVER FROM THIS
CRISIS. NOW IS NOT THE TIME
TIED TO FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
JOBS IN REINVESTMENT FROM
CAPITOL START CENTRAL VALLEY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL TO CENTRALIZE
NEW DEAL WITH IT WE CAN DRIVE
AND ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION AND
FINALLY CONNECT WITH THE PRESS
THE STATE WITHOUT IT WE ARE
ONCE AGAIN LEFT WITHOUT THE
TOOLS TO OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE FAILED TO
VEGAS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THE NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO LIANE
EAGER NINE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
A COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND AS WILL JUST
STATING. HERE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE ARE DEPENDING ON
INNOVATION WE'RE DEPENDING ON-
NEW TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO
BRING US OUT OF. THE STATE THAT
WE BUT AND FOR A LONG LONG TIME
I HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
WE FIND HAVE LOOKING TO IT WHEN
WHERE TRACKING NEW BUSINESS
INTO THE VALLEY. YOU KNOW AND I
THINK I HEARD- AS I WAS
LISTENING TO SEE SOME OF THE
SPEAKERS ARE ABOUT THE
POPULATION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE ARE OVER FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE. GROWING AREA IN
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AS WE KNOW- IN THE BAY AREA AND
IN LOS ANGELES- GROWTH HAS
REALLY STYMIED THERE THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH ROOM IN THE MORNING
OR TO THE COURT TO GROW THEIR
AS I TRAVEL AROUND THE-
BRINGING ARE YOU STILL. OF THE
NIGHT. BRINGING BUSINESS THE
CENTER VALLEY AN ANTI
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE WAS IN. IN
THAT WOULD WHAT THE CONNECTION
HIGH RAIL FROM THE ABOUT TO NOR
AND SOUTHERN CAL. AND WE'RE NOT
IN IN PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
VALLEY AND WORKING OUT WHAT
WE'RE INTO IN IT THOSE. IN THE
CENTER VALLEY AND THEY CAN'T
CONNECT TO THE OTHER. IT'S NOT
GOING DO IT AND YOU GO. TO HAVE
THE BUSINESS IN NORTH AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
ONLY WAY TO ENSURE. THAT THE
FOR AROUND THE IN THE WORLD
HAVE. TO THOSE OTHER OF THE
THANK YOU RAIL. WE HAVE BEEN A
SUPPORTER FOR ELEVEN YEARS NOW
WITH BIG. IT HAS BROUGHT JOHN.
IT HAS RUN OUR UP HOPE WITHIN
TO RALLY. AROUND THE WORLD
PEOPLE ARE WRITING HIGH SPEED
RAIL WITH GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR CARS AND INTO
TRANSPORTATION IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD YOU COULD DO IT
AND WE SHOULD DO IN CALIFORNIA
THE AIR QUALITY IN THE VALLEY
SOME OF THE WORST IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. THE ONLY WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF
THEIR CARS SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO CONTINUE. TO MAKE THIS
RIGHT YOU MAKE SURE WE DO THIS
RIGHT AND TO SUPPORT THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN THANK YOU
NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN THIS GUY HAD. AT THE
STATE THE MARTIN SEVEN I
REPRESENT THE AGENCY WHICH
OVERSEES STATES SERVICE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AFTER
WATCHING THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROCESS FOR TEN YEARS AND ALSO
WATCHING OTHER MAKE UP PROJECT
BEING DEVELOPED IN THE URBAN
AREAS I'M PRETTY CONVINCED THAT
CENTRAL VALLEY IS THE ONLY
LOCATION THAT WILL ALLOW FOR A
TRUE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM.
AND THE ACCOMPANYING HIGH SPEED
RAIL INDUSTRY DEVELOPMENT. IN
MY OWN BACKYARD THE BARD
EXPANSION FROM FREMONT WITHIN A
DAY. IT'S NOW ESTIMATED TOTAL
DEFENDER NINE BILLION DOLLARS A
TWENTY ONE MILE THAT'S ALMOST
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS AMONG.
IF THE NEEDED EXPANSION FOR HER
BUT IT HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT
THAT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DISAPPEAR QUICKLY AND URBAN
CONSTRUCTION ENVIRONMENT. WITH
CENTRAL VALLEY ONE BUYER BUT
OFFERED FOR HIGH SPEED FUN AND
THEN THE ONE STOP OPTIONS FOR
EXPANSION. THIS WILL SAVE THE
CLOSER LOOK. IN FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS A MILE. I HAVE A
BILLION AND THE FUNDING BEING
WORK BY THE- WELL I'M A
DIRECTLY ACROSS. WHAT IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN HELP IN
DURING THE FANDOM TIME WHAT
HAPPENED UP WITH. TO WORK IS
THAT BENEFIT NUMBER OF LAW. THE
NOW IS A LITTLE. ON THE AND I
THINK THE TICKET A DEEPER DOWN
OF A PUBLIC PEOPLE WHO THE
DEATHBED INTO SOME IT'S AN- BUT
THE SAME. THAT BAY AREA. STATE.
ONE CONSOLIDATE OP. IN ONE
STATE SIGNIFICANT NINE. WHAT
ARE THEY OPERATION ON AND ABOUT
DOES THAT AND PAIRING THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL THINK WITH YOU CAN
ALSO THE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
STATE WE WILL NOT FACE.
ACTUALLY A LOT FOR THE SAID
THEY ARE FOR THE SERVICES THAT
ARE RUNNING NOW EVEN WITH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL TAKE LIKE THAT
WARREN A CLOSER LOOK YOU WE CAN
AT BACK OF LEVERAGE NEXT OF THE-
IT REALLY DOES.
TRANSFORMATIONAL THE STATE THAT
OTHER AREAS HAS NOT HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO DO AND THE VOTERS
DID EXPRESS A DESIRE FOR A
TRANSFORMATIVE SYSTEM IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT NOW THEY MAY
HAVE NOT BEEN AWARE OF THE
TECHNICALITIES AND THEY'RE NOT
HERE ON TECHNOLOGY NOW BUT THEY
DID FOUND THE STATE MOVED AWAY
FROM THAT THE STORE PEOPLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. AND GET
VERY SERIOUS ABOUT IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY THIS ONE STOP.
PHONE OF WORKING IN THE- THERE
THE PHOTOGRAPH AND- THE- FROM.
GAINS AND AREAS. I WOULD OUR
EVERYONE LUCK WITH. TO DELIVER
THE PROJECT EVICTING INTO
BETTER MODEL. THANK YOU. BUT
WILL GO TO TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
DON'T STONE HIGH REPRESENT
THEIR COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION- I WANTED TO COMMENT
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO IMPLEMENT THE
FRESNO. THE MAYOR SAID FRESNO
BAKER STILL HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
ROOM OFF READING SEGMENT- COULD
YOU STOP SAID KING SO AREA AND
THE DEER. I WOULD THINK THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT PROJECT IN
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY FOR A NUMBER
OF REASONS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
TOUCH ON CONTINUOUSLY.
ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY WATER WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR SUCH.
SIGNIFICANT PARTNERSHIP AN
IMPROVEMENT WITH WITH- BUT OUR.
STATE PARTNERS. WE REALLY HOPE
THAT THIS. A BUSINESS PLAN WILL
BE PASSED FOR IT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF HOW WE
DEVELOPED A MORE STABLE
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE SAFER MORE
EFFICIENT AND CLEAN OR MOBILITY
OPTIONS TO OUR RESIDENTS. WHO
APPLE UP AND DOWN THE STATE- IT
ALSO RELEASED OUT OF SOME OF
THE PRESSURE FOR HER FOR FREE
MOVEMENT SAW ANOTHER FACILITIES
THAT THAT WON'T BE UTILIZING
COMMUTER RAIL TRACKS ARE BUILT
HERE- THANK YOU. JUST SO YOU'RE
AWARE WE HAVE TWENTY THAT ARE
STILL IN Q. NEXT TO A GO TO
NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD EVENING SURE
FRAZIER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S VETO KIAS
AND I'M A SUPERVISOR FOR THAT
INSTEAD OF SOFT COUNTY. I AM
CURRENTLY THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THE SPORTING
GOODS MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CABINET. AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS
LEADERS TO BEACH COUNTY. I'M
ALSO CHAIR OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OPERATION
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN RAIL
SERVICE. I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT. THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL TRAP TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY BUSINESS PLANS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND HIGH SPEED RAIL
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS PURSUE
THE MERCED FRESNO BAKERSFIELD.
HIGH SPEED RAIL INTERIM
OPERATING SEGMENTS. WITH
ADDITIONAL STOP IN KINGS TO
LARRY AND MADERA PROVIDING HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE TO
CALIFORNIANS AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE TIME. THEM SAID THE
BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
ARENA IN ARENA INTERIM
OPERATING SEGMENT WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS THE CONNECTIVITY TO
OTHER DESTINATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. TO BETTER
CONNECTIONS WITH THE ACE AND
SAN JOAQUIN RAIL SERVICES IN
THE NORTH. AND THE SAN JOAQUIN.
THROUGH A BUS SERVICE AND TO
BAKERS FROM BAKERSFIELD.
TRAVELING TOWARDS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ARE SAN JOAQUIN
STRIKE POWER AUTHORITY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY DRAFT A
BUSINESS PLAN HIGHLIGHTS THE
COORDINATION. THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AT AS THEIR TRIPOLI TRAIN
OPERATOR. YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S RAIL SERVICE WILL
FULLY INTEGRATE WITH AND
SUPPORT THE SUCCESS OF TE
MERCED BAKERSFIELD. HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN ROOM OPERATING SEGMENTS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR VISION. OF THEIR TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN IT'S TIME TO
DELIVER TRUE HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATIONS TO CALIFORNIANS AS
PROMISED TO THE VOTERS. WE URGE
THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN
THANK YOU. NEXT WILL BE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR HEAD. THANK
YOU ARE MY NAME IS MATT TREE
BROWN THE CHIEF A DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES FOR MADERA COUNTY AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING- WHY
MADERA WHICH IS A GROUP-
INVOLVING BOTH THE CITIES OF
CHURCHILL IN THE CITY MADERA
AND THE COUNTY MADERA AMONGST
OTHER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
INCLUDING THEIR UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- AND OTHERS- JUST
WANTED TO URGE THE SUPPORT- AND
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR. THE
TWENTY TWENTY DRAFT BUSINESS
PLAN THAT HI FI REELS PUT OUT-
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO SEE
INVESTMENTS AND EMPHASIZE THE
COMPLETION OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL- AND WE LOOK FOR A HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO COMPONENTS AND
TEN FOR A PERMANENT BUT THEIR
STATION- AS A PART OF THE
PROJECT AS WELL- AND PROVIDING.
GREAT ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
RESIDENTS YOUR ACCOUNT THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A NUMBER THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THIRTY
NINE PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. WILL MOVE TO NUMBER ONE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JIM
FRAZIER THIS IS KEITH DONE HERE
ON BEHALF TODAY OF THE HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF OUR WORKERS
AND SAY THE CALIFORNIA'S WELLS
DISSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED TRAINS. WE LIKE TO BE-
VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
MEASURE AUTHORITIES BUSINESS
PLAN AND JUST MAKE A STATEMENT
THAT THIS IS REALLY A-
INVESTMENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY HOPEFULLY THE START OF A
NEW NEW DEAL. THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS ALWAYS BEEN A LAGGING
INDICATOR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS BEEN ONE
OF THE LEADING ECONOMIC ENGINES
IN THE WORLD FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ALWAYS KEPT TRYING TO
CATCH UP THIS INVESTMENT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IS GOING TO
HELP REDUCE SOME OF THE WORST
CONGESTION IN OUR STATE AS WELL.
pI'M PROVE THEIR QUALITY IS SOME
OF THE CITIES THAT YOU KNOW THE
TOTAL BY REDUCING CLOSED
FORMALLY PEOPLE TODAY SO THIS
IS A CRITICAL INVESTMENT WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
BUSINESS PLAN. LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT SOME OF THE LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS SLEEPING
CUENTAS CALLING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA AND
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING YOU
MISTER FRAZIER AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR OVERSIGHT
OF THIS PROJECT IT'S A EFFORTS
HERE THAT OF YOURS THAT HELP US
MAKE SURE THAT THE VOTERS GET
WHAT IT IS THAT WAS PROMISED
WHICH IS. CONNECTING EIGHT OF
THE TOP TEN MOST POPULATED
REGIONS OF THE STATE AND TO
EXPAND OPTIONS FOR WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE AND WORK THAT BEING SAID
WE ARE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN AND THREE WRITTEN
AND WANT TO THANK MISTER KELLY
FOR HIS EFFORTS AND LEADERSHIP
TO THAT EFFECT. TODAY THERE ARE
OVER THIRTY TWO JOB SITE AND
ALMOST NINE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
PER DAY WORKING ON THIS PROJECT
AND PROJECTS LIKE THIS AND
HOPEFULLY MORE IN THE FUTURE
WILL HELP US MAKE SURE THAT WE
RECOVER AT THE STATE SO WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK.
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF HIS
MIKE MURPHY ON THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY MERCED AND- WANT TO SHARE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY HIGH SPEED REAL
BUSINESS PLAN. AND WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE STATE MOVES FORWARD
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PURSUE THE MERCED FRESNO.
BAKERSFIELD INTERIM OPERATING
SEGMENT EARLIEST POSSIBLE TIME.
THE PERCENT FRESNO BAKERSFIELD
INTERIM OPERATING SEGMENT
ENABLES PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER
OPERATORS TO. ENHANCE
CONNECTIVITY THE OTHER
PASSENGER RAIL SERVICES IN
MERCED. WHERE THERE'S ALREADY A
COMMITMENT- OF OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS TO BRING A INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES. TO CONNECT WITH HIGH
SPEED ROTH. THE INTERIM
OFFERINGSEGMENT WILL IMPROVE
OPERATIONAL RELIABILITY ON THE
STUDY CREATED PASSENGER ONLY
RELYING WHICH ALLOW FASTER MORE
FREQUENT ON TEN SERVICE. WILL
CREATE THE BACKBONE OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM AND- WHAT
DEMONSTRATE THE VALUE OF HIGH
SPEED. RAIL SERVICE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. NEXT TO A NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS US
STEVE ROBERTS FROM THE-
PRESIDENT I'M PRESIDENT THE
RAIL PASSENGERS SO SEASON OF
CALIFORNIA NEVADA. WELL PACK IS
AN ALL VOLUNTEER NON PROFIT
PASSENGER REAL ADVOCACY GROUP
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WITH MEMBERSHIP
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AFTER
VIEW THE TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN THE REAL PEG BOARD
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BUSINESS
PLAN AND THE PROPOSED OPERATING
PLAN. LEVERAGING AND IMPROVED
AND EXPANDED A SAN JOAQUIN AND
HIGH SPEED RAIL NETWORK WILL
BRING SERVICE AGREEMENTS TO ALL
OF CALIFORNIA MAJOR URBAN AREAS
NORTH AND SOUTH AS WELL AS
RURAL AREAS IN ADDITION AS A
RESULT OF RIDERSHIP GROWTH
COMBINED WITH LONGER INTERCITY
TRIP BLANKS. THEN YOU FIND A
LONG URBAN COMMUTER ROUTES THE
INTERMONTANE PLAN WILL YIELD
THE GREATEST GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. ALSO THE
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION HIGH
SPEED RAIL MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD BRING SHE CANNOT
MAKE ACTIVITY NEAR TERM TO
CITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY DURING THIS PERIOD OF
ECONOMIC STRESS. FOR THE REP
EXPO ALSO FEELS THE- DIVERGE
OPTION IS AS RISKY IF NOT
RISKIER AND THE FOCUS ON
BUILDING A TRUE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRUMP GROUP IN CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND ALSO A KEY BENEFIT OF TO
HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS ITS ABILITY TO.
DEMONSTRATE THAT TRANSFORMATION
IS. POTENTIAL OF AND THIS NEW
MODE OF TRANSPORTATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THESE
COMMENTS AND I HAVE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN COMMENTS AS WELL THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOE CRUISE ON BEHALF THE CITY
SAN JOSE THE CITY APPRECIATES
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONVEY OUR
SUPPORT OF HI FI RAIL TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN AS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED IT IS BY ALL
THE WORK CONTINUE GENERATING.
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS IN A MOTOR
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS OF THE
STATE. EXPRESS YOU KNOW THE
AREAS HARDEST HIT. BY THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
ALSO SUPPORT ELECTRIFICATION OF
RAIL TO REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS.
AND GREATLY IMPROVED TRIP
TIMES. THAT THIRTY WITH THIS
PROJECT. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK.
BUDGET TO MAKE EVERY EFFORT. TO
DELIVER A PRODUCT THAT NGUYEN
COMPLETE WILL CONNECT A THE TOP
TEN MOST POPULATED REGIONS OF
THE STATE. AND GREATLY EXPAND
OPTIONS WHERE PEOPLE CAN LIVE
AND WORK. AGAIN MISTER CHAIR WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK YOUR
DILIGENCE IMPROVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU. NEXT
TO IT A NUMBER SEVENTY THREE
THESE YOU HAD. CHAIR NUMBER
AGAIN I GALLON AND I DON'T
THINK ABOUT RISK MANAGEMENT ON
BEHALF OF CALTRAIN IN SUPPORT
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN. IN THE PROJECT
THAT IS NOT THE WAY FOR SEVERAL
YEARS BUT THE CORE THE
ELECTRIFIED AND STARTING IN THE
VALLEY AND INVESTMENT IN THE
BOOK AND OUTLINED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHUCK RELY UPON THE EXACT
AFFECTED DRIVE YOU KNOW THE
FRIENDS ON BUT THERE IT TO
LARRY KING BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL- ISP TONIGHT IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN AS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED. YOU KNOW I HAVE THE
GOOD FORTUNE OF BEING ON THE
GROUND IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FOUR
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
THAT ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
HIGH SPEED RAIL TODAY. I WANT
TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
THERE'S EIGHT HUNDRED
APPRENTICES WORKING WITHIN THE
TRADES ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT THAT THE HUNDRED
APPRENTICES TO HAVE A SHOT AT A
CAREER. EIGHT HUNDRED
APPRENTICES OF A SHOT AT A
LIVING WAGE EIGHT HUNDRED
APPRENTICES OTHER SHOT AT BIBLE
HEALTH CARE AND ATTENTION AT
THE END OF A LONG CAREER- AGAIN
I HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE OF
RUNNING PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT HELP PEOPLE
QUALIFY FOR THESE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. WITHIN
THE AFFILIATED TRADES THAT ARE
ON CONSTRUCTION ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO GENERATE THESE KEY JOBS YOU
KNOW IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT
IS A GAME CHANGER I KNOW I'VE
HEARD SOME OF THE SPEAKERS
TODAY AND I WAS QUITE
DISAPPOINTED WITH SOME OF THE-
ATTITUDES- THAT WERE DISPLAYED
BY SOME OF OUR ELECTED LEADERS.
BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT FOR ANOTHER
TIME- WE NEED TO BE BOLD WE
NEED TO BE PROGRESSIVE WE NEED
THIS CHANGE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO I DO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN AS CURRENTLY.
PROPOSED THANK YOU. ALL NEXT
WE'RE GONNA NUMBER SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM MY NAME
IS JENNY CAN OUR YEAR AND
THAT'S THE CITY COUNCIL
DISTRICT FIVE A SIMPLE YEAH I
WANT TO SAY THAT I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A BAG DRAFT TWENTY
TWENTY AT HIGH SPEED RAIL-
BUSINESS FINANCE AND I'M ALSO
THE STRONG SUPPORT AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THAT HI
STEVE YELLED STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. TO EMPLOYMENT
OF THE MERCED FRESNO
BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
RAM OPERATING SEGMENTS I WITH
ADDITIONAL STAFF AT KINGS AND
TULARE AND MADERA AND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO EXPRESS MY
OUT OF MY **** IT BEING AND PAY.
OF THIS AB. DRAFT AB. NEXT PLAN
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEDICARE AND REMEMBER MY
NAME IS DIANE NGUYEN AND I AM
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
REPRESENTING THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS. THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNCIL GOVERNMENT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO IMPLEMENT THE
MERCED FRESNO BAKERSFIELD HIGH
SPEED RAIL INTERIM OPERATING
SEGMENTS WITH ADDITIONAL STOPS
CHECKING CALARE AND MADERA.
THERE IS ALREADY INVESTMENT OF
OVER ONE BILLION DOLLARS YOU
CONNECT EIGHT IN DOCKING WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL. THE
TRANSFORMATIVE BENEFITS INCLUDE
BETTER AIR QUALITY GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS. REVITALIZATION
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
CENTRAL VALLEY ALL OF WHICH ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR SUSTAINING BY
BRICK AND THRIVING COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY. EXCELLENT A
NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND THE CHAIR OF
FRAZIER THANK YOU FOR. OF
HOLDING THESE MEETINGS TODAY
AND ALL THE STAFF ALL OF THE
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE I'VE BEEN
ON THE PHONE FOR FOUR HOURS AND
SEVEN MINUTES AND YOU'RE STILL
THERE THANK YOU FOR A- BEING
DILIGENT JIM AND HEARING ALL OF
US FROM SPENDING THE TIME I
REALLY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. I
AM A MY NAME IS BILL HOW LUCKY
I AM A MEMBER OF MODESTO CITY
COUNCIL ALSO EX OFFICIO ON THE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION- PAST CHAIR AND
CURRENT MEMBER OF STANISLAUS
COUNCIL GOVERNMENT AND ONE OF
THE SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THE
DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSAL WITH THE
INTERLINKING REMOTE OF MUCH
MERCED DOWN- TO BAKERSFIELD ON
THE STOP TO FRESNO AND MADERA
AND KINGS TO LARRY. ALL OF
THOSE POSSIBILITIES THAT WILL
CHANGE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
CURRENTLY IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED SINCE COLBERT- YOU'LL
SEE THAT THE NUMBERS. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IN MARCH AND
ARE ONLY NOW TWELVE POINT NINE
MEMBER SAID POINT FIVE. OF
PERCENT THESE A PERCENT TWELVE
POINT 9% MERCED- MERCED TEN
POINT FIVE MADERA EIGHT POINT
THREE AND STANISLAUS. TEN POINT
EIGHT FRESNO TWELVE POINT THREE
ALL ALL DOUBLE DIGITS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF STAMPS FOR. THOSE
NUMBERS ARE SERIOUSLY HIGHER
I'M SURE NOW TWO MONTHS LATER
AFTER CO. THESE JOBS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE CREATED ONCE THE
TRAINING HAS THE ABILITY TO RUN
ITS TRACKS. FROM BAKERSFIELD TO
SACRAMENTO AND ACROSS THE
INITIALLY ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
SAN JOSE WITH THE EIGHT.
INTERCONNECTION H. TRAINS
OPERATING AS WORK FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND NOW THE ABILITY TO
REACH OUT A CENTRAL VALLEY AND
HELP US OUT HERE. IS A
SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT I VERY MUCH SUPPORT.
AS I SAID THE BUSINESS PLANS
AND THE EFFORTS OF EVERYONE- IN
THIS MULTI MOGUL FUTURE THAT WE
ARE DEVELOPING. IN THIS AREA OF
OUR STATE THANK YOU. HAVE A
GOOD DAY. OCTOBER THE NUMBER
ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME
THEY'LL JUMP THIS YOU'VE GOT
COR HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DESKTOP TABLET GOVERNMENT THAT
THE UP MOST OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS COVERED BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT THEY FELT- I'LL JUST
SAY THAT WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUSINESS PLAN I APPRECIATE
THE TOP. BUDGET DECISIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE TO MAKE
THEIR VIEWS ON PRESIDENTE
TIMES- BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE PROJECT WILL HELP IMPROVE
THE ARE ALL THE YOU KNOW BOB IS
IN NON ATTAINMENT AREA- AND WE
HOPE THAT ITSELF ABOUT REDUCE
OUR THE DAILY MIGRATION OF GAP
HOW LEGAL ARE OCCUPANT. VEHICLE
THAT HAPPY BOOK YELP POPCAP
BECAUSE OF THE JOB THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROJECT WILL HELP WITH THAT AND
BURKE I LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE- MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS A BY THE PROJECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT WILL NUMBER ONE
FIFTY. PLEASE YOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN READ THE
COMMITTEE. MET HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL TO
OFFER OUR SUPPORT OF THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED AND BY THE
PUBLIC PROJECT IN THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. WE
APPRECIATE. LOOK. YOU SEE HERE
OKAY THANK YOU I DIDN'T I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW START. MANY
THOUGHT GOING OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROJECT. WHILE THERE ARE
DIFFICULTY THAT EXIST LIKE ON
ANY ULTRA LARGE SCALE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT IS
IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND. ALL
THE GOOD THIS PROJECT HAS
ALREADY BROUGHT TO MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE. AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY ALONE NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
IT'S GOING FIFTY THOUSAND JOB
YEARS EARNING MIDDLE CLASS
WAGES AND BENEFITS FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AS WE KNOW
TODAY INVESTED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE ANOTHER FOUR
POINT WORK IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AMONG MANY OTHERS.
AND ONGOING CONSTRUCTION OF A
CRITICAL KEY TO MEETING THE GHG
EMISSIONS STANDARDS. SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE. ALL THESE ARE ALL
IMPORTANT AND YOU COULD FAX IT
DISCUSS WE SHOULD NOT FORGET
THAT THIS TYPE OF PROJECT IS
EXACTLY WHAT WORKERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY NEED.
FROM THE GOVERNMENT DURING
TIMES OF RECESSION WHAT WE FIND
OURSELVES IN NOW. WE ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THIS PROJECT. I CANNOT
FIND NEW CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
MOVING FORWARD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TO BE ABLE TO RECESSION
AND NOT FORGET THAT DURING THE
LAST RECESSION UNEMPLOYMENT.
WELL HISTORICALLY LEVELS ALL
OVER THE CITY. AT THE HIGHEST
POINT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WITHIN CONSTRUCTION IN THE
SENATE RALLY. THOSE EMPLOYMENT
AND- UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WERE
OVER 50% AND FROM ARE CRAFT.
JACK HELPS MITIGATE THAT WHICH
WE KNOW COMING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT THIS
TRANSFORMATIONAL PROJECT. NEXT
WILL NUMBER ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
FRAZIER- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS JOHN MOFFITT
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES JUST WANNA LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS INCLUDING
MISTER SMITH- WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUSINESS PLAN AS
IT'S CURRENTLY PROPOSED AND-
APPRECIATE THAT BENEFITS
PROJECT WILL HAVE IN THE LONG
RUN- BUT ALSO ONE EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FACT TAT
PROGRESS CONTINUES ON THIS
PROJECT IS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDED JOBS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- DURING OUT. DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES SWITCHED FROM
THE EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S-
BUSINESS PLAN AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS PROJECT THANK
YOU. BUT NEXT TO THE NUMBER.
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
DAVID SHOWN BROWN PRESIDENT OF
THE TRAIN WRITERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE CURRENT
ISSUE OF CALIFORNIA REAL NEWS
OUR NEWSPAPER I HAVE A LONG
ARTICLE ON THE DISMAL FUTURE
AHEAD FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL IT'S
BEEN EMAILED TO THE COMMITTEE
AND HOPEFULLY FORWARDED TO EACH
OF THE MEMBERS. WE ARE LONGTIME
SUPPORTERS OF HSR BUT ALSO HAVE
LONG OPPOSED THIS SPECIFIC HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT WE SEE IT AS
UNLIKELY TO EVER PROVIDE USEFUL
SERVICE OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY THERE'S NO PRIVATE MONEY IN
THE PROJECT IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE VIEWS OF THE CHAIR AND
MISTER KELLY. IT'S NOT THE RISK
IT'S THE IT'S THAT THE
POLITICAL COMPROMISES ON ROUTE
DESIGN WERE MADE EARLY IN THE
PROJECTS HISTORY THEY'RE GOING
TO PREVENT IT FROM EVER TURNING
AN OPERATING PROJECT BECAUSE OF
THAT THERE WILL NEVER BE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN THIS
PROJECT WHICH IS WHY IT IS
ULTIMATELY IN FEASIBLE. THE
IDEA THAT THE STATE SHOULD BE
THE SOLE FUNDER OF A MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD WINE IS NOT ONLY
RIDICULOUS IT'S NOW IN FEASIBLE
DUE TO THE STATE'S FISCAL
CRISIS. EVEN IF THAT PROJECT
WAS SOMEHOW COMPLETED IT WOULD
STILL BE COMMERCIALLY
MEANINGLESS AS THERE WON'T BE
ANY PROFIT. IN MY ARTICLE I LAY
OUT IN ORDER LEE PLANNED TO CAN
COMPLETE CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
ONE IN THE FRESNO AREA AND THEN
SHUT DOWN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT. THE ARTICLE OFFERS A
SERIES OF IDEAS ON HOW TO SPEND
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS TO PRODUCE
FAR HIGHER RAIL RIDERSHIP. ONE
POINT I'D LIKE TO STRESS FOR MY
ARTICLE WE BELIEVE THAT CHS
SURREY'S INSISTENCE ON SIGNING
A CONTRACT FOR ELECTRIFICATION
IS THE DIRECT BEAR TO THIS
COMMITTEE. THEY'RE QUESTIONING
WHETHER YOU HAVE THE POLITICAL
COURAGE TO ORDER THEM TO NOT
PROCEED WITH THE CONTRACT. RACH
URGES THE COMMITTEE TO ADOPT A
RESOLUTION INDICATING ITS
UNWILLINGNESS TO FUND
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TRACKS AT THIS TIME. I
LOOK FORWARD TO MEETING WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HOME MY NAME IS JOHN SPAULDING
ON THE EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF
THE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IN
BAKERSFIELD. WE ARE ONLY IS HIS
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN.
HAVING BEEN AN ADVOCATE OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE-
BENEFITS BROUGHT TO KERN
COUNTY. WE ARE ENJOYING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED CONSTRUCTION JOBS
THAT WILLING. INCREASE AS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS PROPOSED
EXTENSION. REVENUE CHAPTER ON
INTO BAKERSFIELD. THE
COMMITMENT TO CONNECT OUR STATE
BY HIGH SPEED RAIL. IN THIS
ECONOMIC TIMES IN KERN COUNTY
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE WORKING
TO HELP CLEAN THE AIR AND
ENVIRONMENT TO A MUCH NEEDED
AREA. THIS PROJECT OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CONSTRUCTION
JOBS AND TRADING FOR CAREERS.
JEFF HAD OUR VETERANS THROUGH
THE HELP LISTA HARD HATS SMALL
BUSINESS WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES. PLEASE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROJECT. HAVING WORKED ON THE
INTERSTATE HI FIVE HIGHWAY
PROJECT FOR THOSE OF YOU MAY
REMEMBER THAT WAS DONE IN
SEGMENTS. AND LOOK AT WHAT IT
DOES TO CONNECT OUR STATE NOW
WITH IT HAS BEEN UPDATED IN
THIS PROJECT IS MUCH NEEDED.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. THE NEXT OVER THE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUSINESS PLAN. ADDITIONALLY WE
LIKE TO ECHO PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
OF SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATION
TO IMPLEMENT THE MERCED FRESNO
BAKERSFIELD INTERIM OPERATING
SEGMENTS. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ALLISON MACLEOD ON BEHALF OF
THE SACRAMENTO REGIONAL RAIL
WORKING GROUP WHICH INCLUDES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AND THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY BUSINESS PLAN.
SACRAMENTO REGION WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE BUILD OUT OF THIS
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENTS FROM
BAKERSFIELD SOMERSET BY
INCREASING CONNECTIVITY FOR OUR
REGION YOUR OTHER RAIL LINE.
CONNECTION A HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
MERCED THE EIGHT RAIL AND
AMTRAK SAN JOAQUIN IT'S
CRITICAL FOR SACRAMENTO AND
WILL ALSO MEAN FASTER
CONNECTION FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
ESTABLISH REGIONAL SYSTEMS
INCLUDING CALTRAIN. PART BACK
REGIONAL TRANSIT THE CAPITAL
VALLEY LINK AT THE YEAH. THIS
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR IMPLEMENTING THE
FULL HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM
BETWEEN THE BAY AREA SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OVERALL ARE
SACRAMENTO REAL WORKING GROUP
SUPPORT THE MANY BENEFITS THAT
WOULD COME FROM THE BUSINESS
PLAN INCLUDING FACTOR FREQUENT
AND RELIABLE PASSENGER RAIL
SERVICE. IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION
CONNECTIVITY AIR QUALITY
BENEFITS AND INCREASED
RIDERSHIP ACROSS RAIL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. YEAH.
NEXT TO A NUMBER SEVENTEEN WHO
HAS. A NUMBER SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY IS THIS ME.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY GREAT
I'M SORRY THIS IS DAVID CAMERON
AMENABLE IS NINETEEN I'M THE
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
DANGERS RAIL CONFERENCE- THE
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION MEMBER
TEAMSTERS UNION PASSED A
RESOLUTION AND ITS NATIONAL
CONVENTION. A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO SUPPORTING THIS PROJECT.
EFFICIENT SUCCESSFUL ECONOMIES
DEPEND ON EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS WITH CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
TO LONG HAVE BEEN LOCKED OUT
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES ECONOMIC ENGINES. IT'S
A NOW THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE STATE IT IS THE WORST
THEY'RE NOT JUST IN THE STATE
BUT IN THE NATION HIGH SPEED
RAIL ADDRESSES BOTH OF BILLS.
THE LATEST NUMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE SEEKING UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THAT TRANSLATES INTO A
PLUS 20% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE AND
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE. HIGH
SPEED RAIL WILL BE AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE IT WILL BE AN ALBUM BARE
METAL BENEFIT AND WILL HELP HI
THIS CENTRAL VALLEY. INTO THE
REST OF THE STATE THANK YOU.
NEXT WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOSE RODRIGUEZ AND I AM A
COUNCIL MEMBER OF THE CITY
MADERA. ANY COMMISSIONER FOR
THE MADERA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION OUR
FIRST AND FOREMOST FROM VERY
HIGHLY SUPPORTED OF THE- HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRACK TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS AND ALSO ON A LINE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUSINESS
PLAN AS CURRENTLY PROPOSED- IF
REALIZE THIS PROJECT WILL
CONTINUE TO GENERATE- KEY JOBS
AND AS I QUOTE MOST
DISADVANTAGED REGIONS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BEING ONE OF
THOSE. AND THAT ALSO PROVIDE-
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR RETURNS THAT
ARE HIGHLY DENSELY POPULATED TO
BE ABLE TO- MOVING TO THE- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS PROJECT TO BE
REALIZED AGAIN LET'S COMPLETE
WITH THE BORDERS AND ASK FOR
AND THAT'S CONNECTING ARE
HIGHLY DENSE POPULATED AREAS.
AND EXPAND OPTIONS- I WHERE
PEOPLE CAN LIVE AND WORK IN
ACTUALLY CAN A WEEK ALL MY
TIME- I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE NOTES THAT A TWELVE NO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT ALSO
INCLUDING THE STOPS AT KING'S
TULARE IN MADERA. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND ALL OF
FLORIDA FOR THIS PROJECT TO
ACTUALLY COMING. COMING TO
FRUITION. WE HAVE ONE FINAL IN
OUR CUTE THE MOMENT I WILL GO
TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS ON THE THIRTY TH DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN MY
NAME IS TO BAN APARTMENT. ON
BEHALF OF BURKE. BURKE THE
PORTS HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THE
VISION OF THE FUTURE CALIFORNIA
AT HOPE TO ACHIEVE. WE SUPPORT
THE DRAFT BUSINESS PLAN AND THE
CONTINUED BUILD OUT OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO CONNECT SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROMOTES GOOD PLANNING AND GOOD
GOVERNMENT RESEARCH EDUCATION
AND ADVOCACY. WE HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTING COMMENTING ON
EVERYTHING QUALITY REPORTS AND
PAPERS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL FOR
DECADES. AND ENGAGED IN
NUMEROUS LOCAL PROJECT BUT A
PART OF HIGH SPEED UP
INVESTMENTS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION TO OUR
SUPPORT FOR ENCOURAGES THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO PURSUE
ELECTRIFICATION OF WELL. WE
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS AND
GREATLY IMPROVED TRIP TIME. AND
TO COMPLETE WITH THE VOTERS
HAVE ASKED FOR. CONNECTING
EIGHT OF THE TEN MOST POPULATED
POPULATED REGIONS OF THE STATE
EXPANDING OPTIONS OF WHERE
PEOPLE CAN LIVE AND WORK AND
BRINGING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND INVESTMENT TO COMMUNITIES
OF OPPORTUNITY. AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THANK YOU. AND WE DID
OF MORE IN WE HAVE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS DAN LET THAT
I REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
REAL WORKING GROUP. ARE WORKING
GROUP INCLUDES ALL THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PANNING AGENCY
THE RATE REGIONAL RAIL
OPERATORS. MAJOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN THE SACRAMENTO TO
MERCED CORRIDOR. ARE TWENTY
AGENCY WORKING GROUP HAS BEEN
INVOLVED IN COURT A PLANNING.
FOR PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE
BETWEEN TACKLING OWNER SAID
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX. WE ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE HYDRO
FORTY DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN THAT INCLUDES
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE MERCED
FRESNO BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED
RAIL INTERIM OPERATING SEGMENT.
WITH ADDITIONAL STOPS IT CAME
TO LARRY AND MADERA. SACRAMENTO
AND NORTHERN TENNESSEE VALLEY
WILL GREATLY BENEFIT THAT
PROBLEM IS FROM HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATIONS. ARE WORKING GROUP
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT IMPROVED
AND EXPANDED PANEL KEEN APRIL
SERVICES. SACRAMENTO MERCED
WILL DIRECTLY CONNECT TO AND BE
INTEGRATED WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE AT THE MULTI MODAL HELP
STATION IN DOWNTOWN MERCED. I
WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE SAN
JOAQUIN SERVICES WITH OUR
EXTENSIVE THROUGH A BUT NETWORK
THAT TAKES PASSENGERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO
PETE INTO THE INTO MY BREEDING
SEGMENT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
AND FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK BRIAN KELLY AND HIS STAFF.
FOR THEIR EFFORTS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU. AND AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MISTER MODERATOR. AND
I'M GONNA TAKE EVERYBODY'S OF
FOR CALLING IN AND WAITING
PATIENTLY TO SHARE THEIR
COMMENTS AND THEIR- THEIR
CONCERNS AND COMMENTS ABOUT THE
PROJECT. AND THEIR SUPPORT
ALSO- I THINK WHAT I WANTED TO
START OFF WITH IS NOBODY IS
SAYING THIS PROJECT SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD. AND HOUSE MOVES
FORWARD AND HOW THE MONEY IS
SPENT. BUT TODAY I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE OF EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION IN THE HEARING
WILL THINK STAFF FOR BEING HERE
LATE. I FRANK THANK YOU KNOW I
REALLY CAN'T CONTAIN MY
DISAPPOINTED WITH THIS GRAPH
BUSINESS PLAN. IT'S CLEAR TO ME
THAT IT'S BASED. LIFE I GUESS I
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED EVERY
BUSINESS PLAN THAT I'VE SEEN TO
DATE HAS A BUILT ON MISLEADING
OR OUTRIGHT INACCURATE
INFORMATION IT HAS NOT. EVER
BEEN ATTAINED. I'M DONE. THIS
HAS TO STOP. IF WE WERE
CONSTRAINED BY THE CURRENT
GLOBAL PANDEMIC I WOULD
SCHEDULE MORE HEARINGS TO
REALLY DIG INTO THE QUESTIONS
RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUES TODAY.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT THE CULTURE PROBLEMS OF
AN ORGANIZATION SEEMS HELL BENT
ON BUILDING ELECTRIC TRAIN
WHETHER IT'S- WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA. WE'VE
GOT TO GET REAL ABOUT THIS
PROJECT BEFORE IT GETS TOO LATE.
IN A DIFFERENT SITUATION I
BELIEVE WE SHOULD DISCUSS WAYS
TO CHANGE THE ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE OF THE AUTHORITY.
THIS PROJECT SHOULD BE MANAGED
BY A DEPARTMENT DIRECTLY
ANSWERABLE TO THIS AGENCY
SECRETARY AND THE GOVERNOR. AND
SUCCESS AND FAILURE SHOULD
DIRECTLY REFLECT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT ON ON
ACCOUNTABLE BOARD. AS IT STANDS
THE LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY
FEELS TOO MUCH LIKE THE
CONSULTANTS ARE RUNNING THE
SHOW AND NO ONE IS LOOKING OUT.
ON THE STATE'S BEHALF.
UNFORTUNATELY MY COLOR
COLLEAGUES AND I NEED TO
WRESTLE WITH EVEN BIGGER
CHALLENGE IS TODAY. AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS TOPIC WILL GET
TO THE ATTENTION IT DESERVES
RIGHT NOW. KIND OF
DISAPPOINTING. BUT BELIEVE ME
WHEN THE OPPORTUNITY ARISES I'M
GOING TO DO ALL I CAN TO GET
THIS PROJECT BACK ON TRACK I
HOPE ONLY HOPE. THAT IT WILL BE
TOO LATE. I REALLY DO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING
ME TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HIM ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. AGAIN
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO STOP THIS
PROJECT WE'RE TRYING TO GET IT
DONE RIGHT THAT IS OUR ROLE AS
LEGISLATORS. AND OVERSIGHT OF
THIS PROJECT. THANK YOU FOR ALL
FOR COMING THIS HEARING TODAY.
BUT LOOK THIS HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROGRAM IS ONE LARGEST INSTRUCT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY. AS SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN IN A CONSTRUCTION A
GENERAL CONTRACTOR ALMOST MY
ENTIRE LIFE. IF I WANTED TO SEE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT COMPLETED
AS EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE I WILL PUT SOMEONE
WITH CONSTRUCTION EXPERIENCE IN%
CHARGE OF IT SUCH A DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE. INSTEAD THE
ADMINISTRATION HIRED A
LEGISLATIVE STAFF PERSON TO BE
THE DIRECTOR OF THIS
ORGANIZATION. HE'S A VERY NICE
MAN. IT'S CLEAR THAT THEY HIRE
THIS PERSON NOT BECAUSE HE CAN
ENSURE THAT THE PROJECT IS
BUILT WELL AND THE STATE'S
MONEY IS BEING SPENT THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE IT'S BECAUSE HIS
EXPERT EXPERTISE IS TO CONVINCE
THE LEGISLATURE TO DO WHAT HE
OF THE GOVERNOR WANT THEM TO DO.
JUST PUSH THE PROJECT FOR. I
FRANKLY CANNOT TAKE SERIOUSLY
ANY PLAN TO TRY TO SELL ME ON
ITS POTENTIAL BENEFITS WHEN THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE HAVE NO IDEA
HOW TO BUILD THE PROJECT BEING
PROPOSED. I HOPE THE AUTHORITY.
AFTER MUCH. CONSIDERATION IN
HEARING THE LA- THE PEER REVIEW
GROUP GROUP SENDS THE BUSINESS
PLAN BACK TO THE DRAWING BOARD
WITH MORE REALISTIC APPROACH
AND I'LL BE WRITING A LETTER TO
THE AUTHORITIES SAY THAT I DO
NOT SUPPORT THIS BUSINESS PLAN
I BELIEVE IT'S MISSTATING FACTS
AND I WANT TO SEE REAL NUMBERS.
I'M ALL ABOUT PEOPLE GOING TO
WORK. IN SUPPORT OF THAT I'VE
BEEN THE CARPENTERS UNION MOST
OF MY LIFE. BUT I DO NOT WANT
TO SEE THE PEOPLE'S MONEY TO
SPEND IF THE MONEY IS SPENT
ELSEWHERE ON A BETTER VALUE.
PEOPLE STILL WILL GO TO WORK.
WITH THAT MAJOR IN THIS SERIES
THANK YOU.